we'll also take your calls at area code
202-626-4898
blowback is a cia term describing the
unintended consequences of american
policies and up next chalmers johnson
talks about his book which examines us
decisions made during and after the cold
war
blow back the costs and consequences of
american empire argues that u.s policies
put into place during that time are
responsible for today's economic turmoil
and political instability
his remarks were part of an event hosted
by the new america foundation here in
washington d.c
thank you all for being here today my
name is steve clemons i'm vice president
of the new america foundation for the
folks in the back come on up their seats
right up here
might as well make it quick and quick
and easy here before
we actually begin with chalmers
welcome to the new america foundation
many of you are new faces andy why don't
you take a seat right up here
and uh we would be very pleased to have
you back on other occasions if you've
not been here for other forums we sort
of pride ourselves on often having small
intimate sessions today is a a little
bit broader and bigger in the room uh
than normal uh but feisty discussions
about affairs that we think uh are
important on a number of fronts we have
a very active agenda and if you're not
already on our list uh please feel free
to leave a business card and i'll add
you to our list uh later
it's a tremendous pleasure for me today
to introduce our our speaker um who is
uh
whose new book blowback uh the costs and
consequences of american empire
i thought would be savaged by
the press and by reviewers uh without
uh
much distinction all across the country
because chalmers is very much taking a
contrarian line on the sort of moment of
american triumphalism uh that so many uh
people here in washington sort of seems
to to argue is is
is uh the way they see things
uh blowback
received a review i think in uh business
week
and uh chalmers called me and says if
you want to know what it feels like when
the empire strikes back
uh read the review but since that review
it's uh there have been a number of
reviews who've come out and made the
case that this book is has begun to sort
of identify and to sort of create a real
counterpoint to the sort of western
triumphalist notion that we see
sort of slushing around washington and
is beginning to identify a certain or or
at least give give a
form to a school of thought that is
beginning to look at the costs and
consequences of our engagement abroad
at the same time recently down in san
diego with the association for asian
state studies meeting a group of
chalmers phd students
phd students of his that have included
beth bowles and others uh from uc
berkeley
uh
a fresh rift sort of a tribute it's not
really
because some of his students really took
chalmers on but it basically is a number
of students who come together and
present original pieces of work that
were in part either inspired by or in
response to the body of work that
chalmers johnson brought to the field of
political science international
relations international political
economy uh for so many years
and it was during this forum
down really began to get a sense of how
profound chalmers johnson's
contributions in the field of
developmental the developmental state
have been
many of you know that he was dubbed
by bob neff uh some years ago as
godfather of the revisionists after hit
the publication of his book metis in the
japanese miracle which really focused on
uh
the way in which the japanese grew an
economy and making it very clear that
there are alternative ways to thinking
about economic development that
exists either within the chicago school
of economics or here in washington about
those that think about economics and
public policy issues
um chalmers is also known by many to be
the king of the one-line zinger
the sort of provocative moment i
remember talking to him about uh
institutions and nonprofits who were
engaged in public affairs and we were
talking about council on foreign
relations many of you are members i'm a
member chao didn't want to be a member
any longer uh chao uh
fought
on relations it just wasn't
producing the kinds of uh uh stem
changing and sort of uh
being outside the status quo that he
thought the the council needed to and so
he
and his uh the comment he got back from
the council was no one resigns from the
council on foreign relations they just
die
uh
chal said consider me dead
and i don't think
but in any case uh he has he's really
made tremendous contributions but the
reason that this last story is important
is that he has taken on uh engagement
after engagement institution after
institution i think in ways that very
few of us in washington do i think
washington and many of us that are
engaged in this business including
myself tend to be risk averse it's not
to say that chalmers johnson is reckless
but chalmers johnson does not
pull his punches based on the risks he
fears from an institutional arrangement
or institutional alignment to which he
has to pay service and i think it's a
really tremendous pleasure for us to
bring him into washington to sort of
talk about
i'll end my comments in just a moment he
has published some 12 major books i
remember recently we had a
an editor from the free press here who
said to some of our our fellows here
you'll be lucky in your life if you
produce six books and that's really
really good chalmers has done 12 and may
it may be 14 now i've lost count
not only blow back but he's just edited
a volume
entitled okinawa cold war island
in which i had a small hand as well
these are a collection of papers
published by the japan policy research
institute jpri has been chal's home for
the last six years he and i created the
japan policy research institute six
years ago and it has turned into not
just a boutique on japan affairs but
probably the single most
important i think virtual organization
that exists out there it exists on a
couple of computers in new mexico
california washington and whatnot but it
has one of the largest libraries of
original pieces
on u.s asia relations on japan relations
on political economy on culture on
history john dower recently won the
national book award and yesterday won
the bancroft prize for his book
embracing defeat
and before that book came out one of the
most important pieces out of that book
was published as a jpri working paper
chalmers is president of the japan
policy research institute and the
objective of jpri is to publish material
original thing pieces that simply will
not be published anywhere else so it's
become the place of record one of the
most interesting things is that we have
a site on the website
so if you want more information
send something here and it goes to a few
of us and we answer it and we're getting
countless numbers of high school
professors and professors in college who
aren't necessarily japanologists who are
using the website of japan policy
research institute as their automatic
course syllabus and so it's having
tremendous influence and this is the
kind of influence that chalmers has had
for so many years so it's a great
tribute to have chalmers talking about
blow back the costs and consequences of
american empire steve thank you
thanks very much went on a little long
but
it's a great pleasure to be here
i also want to thank the new america
foundation for giving me this
this forum
with which to
present some of our my ideas so let me
get into it and then have a good debate
our intelligence agencies the cia and
its rivals in the pentagon have a
history of creating neologisms to
describe our world that cover up more
than they reveal
these have been lofty coinages like host
nation support meaning that foreign
countries pay for our troops based on
their soil
scientific sounding phrases such as exo
atmospheric kill vehicle which in planar
english describe weapons that have never
killed anything but are unimaginably
expensive
and military jargon like low intensive
warfare that repackages the most brutal
strife in the antiseptic language of the
global strategist
the pentagon says it trains the armed
forces of our client regimes in foreign
internal defense but this often amounts
a little more than state terrorism
against their own people
among the most assiduous recent
graduates of such american training
programs were the armed forces of
indonesia which over the past two years
managed to oust a president
rape or kill a thousand chinese
shopkeepers in jakarta and gave
democracy a truly bad name in east timor
we were training them up until september
9th 1999 as they were killing their own
unarmed citizens
every now and then however a new word
emerges from the labyrinth of our secret
services
for which we might be thankful
the american press has recently started
to use the term blowback
central intelligence agency officials
coined it for internal use
in the wake of the decisions by the
carter and reagan administrations to
plunge the agency deep into the civil
war in afghanistan
it wasn't long before the agency was
secretly arming every mujahideen
volunteer in sight
without considering whether they
who they were or what their politics
might be all in the name of ensuring
that the soviet union had its own
vietnam-like experience
the united states public may believe
that the destabilization of the soviet
union was worth the 1.8 million afghan
casualties the 2.6 million refugees and
the 10 million land mines left in the
ground there
but it does not yet know about all the
blowback its afghan adventure has
unleashed
not so many years later these afghan
freedom fighters began to turn up in
unexpected places they bombed the world
trade center in new york city murdered
several cia employees on their way to
work in virginia
as well as some american businessmen in
pakistan who just happened to be to
become symbolic targets and gave support
to osama bin laden a prime cia asset
back when our national security advisers
thought giving guns to religious
fundamentalists was a great idea
in this context blowback came to be
shorthand for the unintended
consequences of american policies kept
secret from the american people
in fact to cia officials an increasing
number of american international
relations pundits blowback has become a
term of art acknowledging that the
unconstrained often illegal invariably
secret acts of the last remaining
superpower in other people's countries
can result in retaliation against
innocent american citizens
their dirty tricks agencies are at pains
never to draw this connection between
what they do and what someone sometimes
happens to the people who ultimately pay
their salaries
so we are supposed to believe that the
bombings of american embassies in east
africa in 1998 the proliferation of
sophisticated weapons around the world
or the crack cocaine epidemic in
american cities are simply examples of
terrorism the work of unscrupulous arms
dealers drug lords ancient hatreds rogue
states anything unconnected to american
global policies
perhaps the term globak can help us to
re re-link certain violent acts against
americans to the policies from which
they secretly sprang
from the hollowing out of key american
industries due to the export-led
economic policies of american satellites
in east asia to refugee flows across our
southern borders from countries where
u.s supported repression has created
hopeless conditions or u.s supported
economic policies have led to
unimaginable misery blowback reveals to
us a longer history of american imperial
hubris
we might also consider widening the
words application to take in the
unintended consequences american
policies may have for others
for example even if the american
policies that our government fostered
and that produced the economic collapse
of indonesia in 1997
never blow back to the united states
the unintended consequences for
indonesians have been staggering they
include not only poverty and loss of
hope in the world's largest islamic
country
but serious ethnic violence and perhaps
political disintegration
uh i've not too long ago traveled from
jakarta to jogjakarta by train and uh it
is uh
really quite astonishing to have seen
the place where the the green revolution
without question the greatest success to
see the setback of 30 years of progress
to now half the population is making a
dollar a day
our dirty hands in overthrowing
president ayande in china and installing
geno pinochet who subsequently killed at
least four thousand of his own citizens
are just now coming fully into the open
when blowback from our policies mainly
strikes other peoples it has a corrosive
effect on us debasing political
discourse and making us feel duped when
the news finally emerges
professor david kaleo has observed and i
quote
the international system breaks down
not only because unbalanced and
aggressive new powers seek to dominate
their neighbors but also because
declining powers
rather than adjusting and accommodating
try to cement their slipping
pre-eminence into an exploitative
hegemony
i believe the united states the end of
the 20th century fits this description
the american people believe that their
role in the world is virtuous that their
actions have been for the good of others
as well as themselves
and they insist that even when their
country's actions have led to disaster
their motives were still honorable
but the evidence is building up that in
the decade following the end of the cold
war the united states seriously misread
the nature of the world and the role of
the united states in it
instead of leading through diplomacy and
attempting to set a good example it is
resorted most of the time to bluster
military force and financial
manipulation
on the economic front through an excess
of hubris and imprudence the united
states in the 1990s set out to compel
all the economies on earth to remodel
themselves to look like the united
states
this ignorant project not only failed it
brought discredit to the very idea of
free trade
as the seattle demonstration suggested
and as the as the issue continues in
washington this week
and raised serious questions about the
motives of the united states in the
world economy
the world is still poised on the edge of
a possible global recession caused by
the united states even if the u.s itself
has thus far been the least affected by
the world economic crisis
even if a collapse of global demand is
avoided these misguided american
policies have set back 30 years of
economic progress in southeast asia
particularly in indonesia
and have laid the foundations for future
economic political and military
retaliation against the united states by
the devastated nations
in february of
1998
the u.s secretary of state madeleine
albright
defending the use of cruise missiles
against iraq declared and i quote
if we have to use force it is because we
are america we are the indispensable
nation we stand tall
we see further into the future unquote
the evidence suggests precisely the
opposite
i believe this negative american role
grew out of the structural
characteristics of the cold war
and the strategies the united states
pursued
particularly in east asia to achieve
what it thought were its interests
during that period
the united states created satellites in
east asia for the identical same reasons
that the soviet union created satellites
in east europe
during the course of the cold war the
ussr intervened militarily to try and
hold its empire together in hungary and
czechoslovakia the united states
intervened militarily to try to hold its
empire together in korea and vietnam
the united states incidentally killed a
great many more people in its two losing
interventions i was a veteran of the
korean war
than the ussr did in its two winning
interventions
the richest prize in the soviet empire
was the former east germany
the richest prize in the american empire
remains japan
japan today much like east germany
before the wall came down
remains a rigged economy brought into
being and maintained by the cold war
japan's peoples are tired people are
tired of the half century of american
troops on their soil and the gray single
party regime that presides in tokyo
walter ulrich and eric honaker appear as
dynamic modern leaders when compared to
most of the prime ministers japan's
liberal democratic party has put in
office since nineteen fifty five
raymond our own once described the
soviet union's lieutenants in east
europe as shameless mediocrities which
fairly well also describes the united
states lieutenants in japan uh steve
clemons just wrote a
very nice op-ed in the san diego union
this past week uh
arguing in essence that the way mr mori
was chosen as prime minister is
indistinguishable from the way zhang
zemin's successor might be chosen in
beijing
certainly secretive and certainly in its
insider operation
just as the two satraps of the german
democratic republic faithfully followed
every order they ever received from
moscow
each and every japanese prime minister
once in office gets on an airplane and
reports to washington
and just as in the former east germany
japanese voters long ago discovered that
nothing they do ever seems to change
their political system so long as they
are allied with the united states
serious japanese have learned to avoid
politics like the plague voting only in
local elections
where they often vote communist because
at least the party is competent and
honest and communism itself is no longer
relevant to any country in east asia
japanese political idealists tend to
become nihilus not unlike their german
brethren before 1989.
the soviet union started setting up its
satellites largely because they could
not compete with the largest of the
united states in the marshall plan
this of course reflected a major outcome
of world war ii the soviet union had
been severely damaged by the war whereas
the united states emerged essentially
unscathed
the ussr recognized that in the conflict
between democracy and totalitarianism
that was developing in post-war europe
it was on the less popular side it was
not on the side of history
in eastern europe it could not bring its
supporters to power through the ballot
box and it therefore ruthlessly ousted
local democrats
in the czech coup of february 1948 and
elsewhere
it imported stalinism claiming it was
merely a version of leninism of
socialism
the soviet union also had a national
security need to try to secure its
western approaches
by contrast after japan's defeat
the united states was never directly
threatened by any regime in east asia
least of all china which had been
devastated by war and revolution
we therefore built our system of
satellites for more genuinely
imperialist reasons although the united
states government argued that
sino-soviet communism and the domino
theory made our efforts necessary
the united states decision to create
satellites in east asia followed from
two sets of events the first of course
was the communist revolution in china
which meant that american plans for a
new post-war international order in east
asia based on an alliance with china
were no longer viable
we were unwilling to go to war against
the popular forces of chinese communism
in order to prop up zhang kai-shek
we therefore reversed ourselves and our
policies for the occupation of japan
giving up on efforts to democratize the
country john dower's new book that steve
mentioned uh uh that won the
national book award is really brilliant
a discussion of this from the japanese
point of view for once rather than than
the view of macarthur and his staff
we gave up on our efforts to democratize
the country
committed ourselves instead to making
japan our unsinkable aircraft carrier
fuching kubo in east asia
japan replaced china as america's
primary east asian ally
american policy devoted itself to
defending japan and making it an
alternative to the appeals of the
chinese revolution within japan and
elsewhere in east asia
we did not try to roll back the chinese
revolution
but as a result of truman's intervention
in the chinese civil war that is his
order to the seventh fleet to defend
taiwan and the the end police the taiwan
strait
and macarthur's excesses in korea
we still ensured chinese hostility for
at least two decades
needless to say the united states did
not consult the japanese people about
these decisions any more than stalin
consulted the checks but is installing
clement gotwald as his puppet
we cultivated and installed in power
remnants of the japanese wartime
establishment and the neo-fascist right
because they were unquestionably
anti-communist
our reliance on old war criminals in
japan
former prime minister former minister of
munitions nibusuke kishi in tojo's
wartime cabinet became japanese prime
minister between 1957 and uh and 1960. i
guarantee you if albert speer had become
chancellor of germany the new york times
would have noticed uh but uh they
didn't in the case of
of mr kishi and as well as the cia
finance single party regime from 1949 to
1993
these were the mirror image of soviet
policies in the former german democratic
republic
these policies actually led to a revolt
against the united states in nineteen
sixty
the largest mass demonstrations in
post-war japanese history protesters
surrounded the parliament building and
demanded that lawmakers not ratify the
japanese american security treaty
the situation became so tense that
president eisenhower was forced to
cancel his proposed visit to japan
the first sitting president ever to
visit tokyo 15 years later was gerald
ford
using its rigged majority the japanese
conservative party forced through
ratification of the treaty keeping
american troops in japan but japanese
politics never regained the trust of the
public
newly elected president kennedy then
sent ambassador edwin o'reichauer and
his japanese-born wife to paper over the
differences and from these efforts there
emerged in american ideology
reinterpreting japan as a misunderstood
democracy
even the war years emerged from this
reinterpretation as a brief aberrant
interlude
domestically japan's liberal democratic
party turned over foreign policy to its
u.s masters and the revival of the
economy to its dirigi state bureaucracy
by the end of the 1990s japan was the
world's second richest country
the richest in per capita terms uh just
as as in the case of east germany if you
had to live in the east bloc germany was
always the most comfortable place to
live if you were not interested in
politics
by the end of the 1990s 1990s japan was
the world's second richest country but
with a government remarkably similar to
that of the former east germany
the second reason why the americans
decided to build military satellites in
east asia was an unintended consequence
of our concern that in the face of the
ussr's efforts
the rest of europe might go communist
in order to support britain france and
holland the united states abandoned its
world war ii promises to help liberate
these nations asian colonies
instead as these colonies fought to free
themselves from their defeated overlords
the united states replaced the former
imperialists
this meant that in east asia
except for our own colony of the
philippines we ended up on the wrong
side of history much as the ussr was in
europe
even in the philippines which we granted
formal independence on july 4th 1946 we
kept our largest military bases until
the filipinos expelled us in 1992.
however
the main
cold war conflicts in east asia and
southeast asia were not between
democracy and totalitarianism
as they were in europe but between
european colonialism and national
independence
the reluctance of the main european
powers to give up their colonies led to
wars of national liberation in indochina
against the french in malaya against the
british and indonesia against the dutch
in all of which the united states either
vacillated or supported the site of
imperialism
after the dutch were driven from
indonesia the british fought a
decade-long war against insurgents in
malaya finally acquiescing in malayas
becoming malaysia and singapore
after the french were defeated
militarily in vietnam the united states
fought an incredibly bloody and
prolonged conflict before it was also
forced to abandon its imperial role
there
we also supported a long counter
insurgency in the philippines against
guerrillas who considered the
post-independence filipino government a
creature of the united states
only after our defeat in vietnam did we
begin to adjust to the idea that east
asia was different from europe
nixon's opening to china was the first
sign that some understanding of east
asian history was finally starting to
penetrate washington mines
the problem for the united states was
that national communist parties had
filled the vacuum of leadership of these
east asian liberation movements since we
were supporting the europeans in their
attempt to keep their colonies
in order not to see all of east asia
possibly even including japan as a
neutralist regime come under the
influence of nationalistic communist
parties the united states from time to
time use the same brutal methods the
ussr resorted to in eastern europe to
hang on to its sphere of influence
the data from korea is just now
beginning to come out no gun re the
taejong massacre are nothing compared to
the killings when we were totally in
charge of korea between 1945 and 1949.
we were the authority
they will come out particularly with the
news today that
kim dae-jong will be meeting uh
in another few months with
kim jong-il of north korea
the
the best example of this as i say was
the role played by the united states in
south korea from 1945 to the present a
history that has been almost totally
suppressed in the united states
south korea has been occupied by
american forces virtually continuously
since the end of world war ii
it was the scene of the most important
armed conflicts of conflict of the early
years of the cold war
the place where the united states and
china fought each other to a standstill
and froze relations with each other for
20 years until joe and ly and richard
nixon unfroze them
thanks to the united states and the
former ussr
when 1945 divided the country for their
own convenience a half century later
korea remains the last place on earth
whose borders are determined by where
the armies of world war ii stopped
for more than 40 years the united states
sacrificed its own economy in order to
win and retain the loyalty of its
satellites in east asia this is the way
it differs most
from the stalinist regimes in east in
east europe
during the cold war and for the decade
after its end the united states offered
the east asians a deal
the deal was unrestricted access to the
american market
and it defended east asian protectionism
and mercantilism
in return the east asians accepted and
helped pay for american military bases
in their countries and gave at least
verbal support for american foreign
policies this is the situation as we
talk there are a hundred thousand
american troops in japan and south korea
and the japanese still have unrestricted
access to this market in fact many of
you may recall
a decade ago when
the current mayor of tokyo and
nationalist figure
ishii harassing tarou and
the late president of sony
akio morita wrote a book called the
japan that can say no nobody in this
country seemed ever to understand what
they were saying they were saying the
deal is you people don't complain about
trade deficits you're starting to
complain about them the deal is you keep
your troops here and we sell in your
country that's
that's the the quid pro quo what are you
complaining about we might one day if
you want to keep complaining about the
number of hondas and toyotas send the
third marine division home
it wouldn't it would actually be a very
healthy thing if they would do that
for the first half of the cold war
down to about 1970
the united states also encouraged the
east asians to take positive advantages
of these terms in order to prosper
economically
economic growth was the american way of
inoculating them against communism
neutralism socialism and other
potentially anti-american political
orientations
the east asian non-communist countries
accepted this deal
and worked hard at what was called
export-led growth
a euphemism meaning primarily privileged
sales to the american market
the japanese led this movement but
behind them were three ranks of
followers
the first were the newly industrialized
countries of south korea taiwan hong
kong then
a british colony and singapore
they were followed by the late
developers of southeast asia malaysia
indonesia thailand and the philippines
most recently they were all joined by
china at present the world's fastest
growing economy
the japanese like this so-called flying
geese pattern flattered that they were
the lead goose and the inspiration for
the others that followed
all of them assumed that the destination
of these flying geese namely los angeles
and from there the rest of the american
market
was a permanent feature of the
international environment
and so long as the cold war existed it
was as permanent as anything ever is in
interstate relations
over time however this pattern had
serious unintended consequences
it produced gross over investment and
excess capacity in east asia
it also produced the world's largest
trade deficits in the united states over
300 billion dollars per year at the
present moment
huge trade surpluses in east asia japan
is the first country in history to
generate a hundred billion dollar trade
surplus
and in general a lack of even an
approximation of equilibrium in supply
and demand across the pacific moreover
contrary to the communist accusations of
neocolonialism these terms were costly
to the united states they cost american
jobs destroyed american manufacturing
industries and smashed the hopes of
american minorities and women trying to
escape from poverty they did not smash
the hopes of white male investors and
therefore anybody who protested was
declared an isolationist or a
protectionist
the american government continued to
accept these costs as the price of
keeping its empire together
from about the nixon administration on
the us did start to negotiate more or
less seriously with the japanese and the
other so-called miracle economies to
open their markets to american goods and
the can't of the time level the playing
field
but the attempt to lessen trade friction
and open reciprocal markets in east asia
always collided with a security
relationship in order to level the
economic playing field the united states
would also have had to level the
security playing field and this it was
never willing to do let me be candid
with you i have talked with officials at
the ministry of international trade
industry who say so long as the marines
are happy in okinawa that guarantees it
don't even talk to us about retaliation
that is
if if the president united states
doesn't understand that he should talk
it over with the secretary of defense
and he'll explain it to him
basing a capitalist economy on export
sales rather than domestic demand
ultimately contains the seeds of its own
its own destruction
it subverts
the function
of the unfettered world market to
reconcile and bring into balance supply
and demand
instead of producing what the people of
a particular economy can actually use an
export regime thrives on foreign demand
artificially engineered by an
imperialist power
in east asia during the cold war this
strategy worked so long as the american
economy remained overwhelmingly larger
than the economies of its dependencies
and so long as only japan perhaps one or
two other smaller countries pursued this
strategy
but by the 1980s the japanese economy
had become the size of two germans
moreover virtually everyone else in east
asia and potentially every
underdeveloped country on earth had some
knowledge of the miracle economies and
was trying to duplicate japanese-style
high-speed growth
the over capacity for things oriented to
the american market or that were needed
to expand east asian productive capacity
even further became overwhelming
there were too many factories turning
out automobiles television sets
semiconductors petrochemicals steel and
ships for too few buyers
the current global demand for
automobiles for example peaked at around
50 million vehicles but capacity has
already grown to 70 million as a result
of the global economic crisis that began
in 1997 for example auto sales in
southeast asia fell from 1.3 million in
1997 to 450 000 in 1998.
meanwhile the hollowing out of american
industry continues unabated even though
american trade representatives sometimes
berate japan for its protectionism and
dumping the japanese have learned simply
not to listen
whenever the u.s trade representative
seems about to do something serious
about japanese predatory trading
practices the japanese government
invokes the us secretary of defense
the pentagon then tells the ustr that in
that famous phrase the broader
relationship
meaning the 50 or so us basis in japan
and the hundred thousand troops in
northeast asia
takes precedence over any other
interests of american citizens if there
should be an active protest from
american industry or labor the central
intelligence agency or the defense
intelligence agency steps in and finds
or invents
a new military threat to justify the
pentagon's primacy
these are the cost of maintaining the
american empire
perhaps these american policies made
strategic sense during the period from
approximately 1950 to 1970 when they
also had the desirable consequence of
bringing real competition such
complacent industries as american
automobile manufacturing
but today these old policies are utterly
destructive of both the security and
economic well-being of both the united
states and japan
they continue to alter the american
economic system away from manufacturing
and towards finance capitalism
and they prevent japan from producing an
economy they can stand alone and trade
with other economies on a mutually
beneficial basis
the day of reckoning for american pride
and japanese myopia cannot be too far
away
the u.s japan security treaty today is
an anachronism left over from the cold
war
when during the cold war japan was used
as a launching pad for american troops
ships and aircraft japan had no choice
no voice in the matter
during the korean war japan was still
under american occupation
uh during the vietnam war okinawa was
still under american occupation
today the japanese diet would have to
approve any u.s military action
emanating from its soil and it's not
likely despite the security treaty's
nebulous assurances or the new security
guidelines
that japan would ever countenance the
us's launching airstrikes against either
north korea or china from its okinawan
or mainland bases
only washington so-called strategists
totally ignorant of east asian history
in the 20th century can seriously
believe that japanese facilities can
today be used for american wars against
japan's foreign colony korea or against
japan's main legacy of war crimes and
crimes against humanity namely china
the equivalent would be to reopen the
vietnam war
with more american napalming of
vietnamese civilians and with ultimately
the same outcome but on a greater scale
world politics in the 21st century will
in all likelihood be driven primarily by
blowback from the second half of the
20th century that is from the unintended
consequences of the cold war and the
crucial american decision to maintain a
cold war posture in a post-cold war
world
the united states likes to think of
itself as the winner of the cold war
in all probability to those looking back
a blowback century hence neither side
will appear to have won particularly if
the united states maintains its present
imperial course thank you very much
[Applause]
right
thank you chalmers uh you delivered uh i
promised the provocative set of remarks
and we did i've invited jacob howebrain
many of you know jacob is one of uh
washington's most important uh younger
uh public policy entrepreneurs in the
field of foreign affairs jacob worked at
national interest and was recently a
senior editor at the new republic is now
a regular uh
columnist in uh
a an online magazine entitled titled
politicalwag.com but uh also the suicide
in germany and his articles and material
frequently appear in the new york times
and the wall street journal jacob
it's not without some trepidation that i
follow in chalmers's footsteps
to the best of my knowledge
no human being has been able to upstage
chalmers the only time that the
limelight was stolen from him came a few
years ago when japanese television came
to do a story on him
at his home in la jolla
and
immediately noticed that he had two cats
both of which were named after leading
japanese bureaucracies meaty and moff
and that was the end of chalmers and the
program focused solely
on his on these two creatures
this morning in the washington post
there was a column by robert kagan
sketching out a diametrically opposed
view of the united states than the one
that we just heard from chalmers
the one formulated by kagan is
is a view that
a faction in the republican party is
trying to push that far from being
reckless and bloated
and overconfident
american foreign is paralyzed by
indecision and is squandering a unique
opportunity
to impose american values around the
globe
given the
the
disparity between these two views i
myself would like to throw in a smidgen
of caution if i may
to chalmers his speech which was
delivered with his usual vigor energy
and brio it reminds me a little bit of a
comment a historian once made about
winston churchill's memoirs which was
that they were totally convincing which
is what why they should be treated with
caution
i think chalmers scores a number of
points about american foreign policy
during the cold war there's no doubt
that as he shows in his book in
guatemala
in okinawa which if you visit has
essentially
been turned into an american strip mall
that
american foreign policy during the cold
war
is
far from be from being irreproachable
but is it really the case
that we are experiencing blow blowback
today
if you look at the new york times the
other day
their lead story suggests that europeans
are starting to bridle at what they view
as american cultural values
fitting quite neatly the scenarios
sketched out by chalmers in fact the
leading german weekly deep site
recently had
a cover line which read the new battle
with the united states they were
referring to the struggle over the head
of the international monetary fund which
the germans finally managed to push
through
but the european
reaction
to the united states was that a bully is
throwing its weight around
but
if we look
at chalmers's main example of japan
what i would like to ask him is
if you look at the japanese reaction to
the united states
if anything during my brief stay there
it was
that there is a recoil against the
united states
and that the japanese are not behaving
as the
loyal surfs that chalmers has described
that in fact it's precisely the japanese
who are trying to resist
the introduction of american-style
capitalism into east asia so i'd be
curious to see how he reconciles that
with his diagnosis
i also think that chalmers
who has given us a structural view of
american foreign policy which does have
a long history it's it's not a unique
analysis though chalmers has essentially
updated it which is to look at the
united states as an empire there's no
doubt that the united states now is more
powerful than it ever has been in its
history
and it has more obligations than it has
ever had in its histories especially if
you look at the expansion of nato
eastward which chalmers
did not mention in his talk
but
is he ascribing too much omniscient to
american policymakers if you look at the
way the united states pursued its policy
towards china for example it seems to me
that is characterized by zigzags there
is no coherent policy
if we look at europe the united states
was dragged into bosnia dragged into
kosovo again it's not as though american
foreign policymakers
were sitting up there and plotting how
to expand the american empire
another point that i would make is
chalmers
points to the inherent bureaucratic
nature of the pentagon which is to
maximize its power
and obtain as much money as it can from
congressional committees but is the
united states military really interested
in fighting my impression is no that
it's become a fat slovenly bureaucracy
quite
uh in many ways fitting
the republican
descriptions of american welfare
agencies in the 1970s
finally i would
bride a little bit at chalmers's
equation of west and
of east germany and japan i think the
more fitting
comparison would be actually to west
germany
that during the cold war at least
west germany while not being quite as
subservient as japan
does share many of the characteristics
that
japan does of elites
carrying out policies
of a largely docile population
of extremely tight networks between
business
the military
and politicians
that is starting to crumble today in
germany
and i suspect that under the pressures
of globalization it's also cracking up
in japan
finally
i would say that with chalmers is bold
talk which is refreshing and finally
someone has uh
made the case as it were
with real conviction
and authority
we will know in the coming years whether
chalmers was wrong or right either he is
a prophet or he is king canoe
commanding the wage to roll back
thank you jacob
uh
for the audience we have time for for
some questions now and i also want to
mention for our c-span viewers as well
and any of those in the audience that if
you'd like to have a copy of chalmers
remarks i would be happy to email those
to you those in c-span world can
contact us through the web through
www.newamerica.net
and we'd be happy to send you his
comments if you want to debate chalmers
or applaud him or criticize him further
chalmers would you take some questions
and while we're opening the floor we're
going to have someone bring a microphone
around as well but let me while we're
getting ready uh i guess we're not going
to do that i will be repeating the
questions so that people can hear them
but the the uh the question i want to
begin with is
this is a new
position for you uh you were a spear
carrier for the empire for a long time
part of your resume that i didn't read
was that you were an advisor to the cia
for a great period of time uh and uh you
were part of the system what
significantly changed to create this
sort of dramatic convulsion
of a book that you produced
thank you for the opportunity to deal
with obviously what many of the
reviewers are saying uh
john mitchell
john maynard keynes once uh made the
remark that uh
when he was accused of inconsistency
that when i get new information i
changed my position and that he turned
to his interlocutor and said and what
sir do you do with new information uh
the the chief new information that i've
received obviously is that the united
states is maintaining cold war
patterns cold war
stances the cold war apparatus when
there is nothing that justifies it that
is with the disappearance of the ussr
there is no conceivable threat that is
anywhere even commensurate with the
expenditure of of wealth and uh
uh and uh deployments that we are making
today the uh but you ask what uh what
caused this i think what caused it
concretely i've spent my life working on
japan i first arrived there in 1953 uh i
had never been in okinawa um
except really tangentially when i was in
the navy during the korean war i took
the ship into what was then called
buckner bay and dropped anchor
other officers went ashore i decided to
go swimming in the glorious water around
the ship and never actually touched land
so when governor otto once asked me had
you ever been in okinawa i said i've
swum here but i've never actually
touched the place
the
on september 4th 1995 as many of you
know two marines and a sailor based at
uh camp hanson in keene village central
okinawa kidnapped and raped a 12 year
old girl
this was bad enough it was not unusual
the occurrence of rapes is two a month
for the last 10 years in okinawa this
was not this was not uh that is say this
was bad enough but it's what happened in
the five years since then uh the
the fact that the american government
has chosen to see this incident which
produced the greatest demonstration
against the united states since the
security treaty riots of 1960 uh that is
that gino won 85 000 people in october
1995 organized by
the women's coalition the okinawan women
against military violence uh
ask for amelioration of the their
circumstances 1.3 million okinawans live
on an island smaller than kauai in the
philippine islands with 39 american
military bases today there were 42 at
the time of the rape
the
uh
the uh it is what's happened let me just
say also then after that um in february
of 1996 governor ota former professor
who this was the governor of okinawa
until he was defeated by the united
states and japan in
through really
tactics that would have made clement
gottwald feel very much at home
in uh
in 1998 he invited me to naha to give a
speech
uh to say i was shocked is to put it
mildly i would say that it takes about a
half hour in okinawa to detect that
there is no strategy behind these
deployments they are simply been there
since the battle of okinawa since 1945
the troops are comfortable i'm not
anti-marine i'm a graduate of assault
boat school camp pendleton
but the third marine division should
have been demobilized years ago it's
worthless as
both secretary defense carlucci and
and aspen uh so chose at one time to try
and get rid of it uh it's under strength
stretched out has no armor
it has no sealift capacity in case of a
serious crisis it would be isolated
it's uh
it is uh it's that is to say the marines
are still in okinawa because the
officers clubs because of the uh of the
golf courses because of the swimming
pools they're there for exactly the same
reasons the soviet troops did not want
to leave east germany they were
comfortable they lived better than they
would live where they came from
we could easily train young marines at
pendleton or 29 palms infinitely more
effectively than in a place as
overcrowded as okinawa and we've asked
is of course this is why the security
treaty works so comfortably for the
japanese
if these bases were located in kanagawa
prefecture if they were located anywhere
near yokohama they'd have been closed 25
years ago there's some political clout
there but so long as they can keep them
in a place that is essentially japan's
puerto rico that is okinawa is a
discriminated against territory it was
an independent kingdom until the uh
the late 19th century when it was
annexed by japan they have a distinct
culture they're much closer to china in
uh in the past uh they've been uh it's a
dumping ground for the uh
for the uh
the security treaty and it keeps them
out that is it doesn't bother the
japanese government so long as they're
there in okinawa it was that that above
all caused me to uh uh change my mind
but it was then particularly what's
happened in the five years since i mean
we've promised to close marine corps air
station futama located right in the
center of ginawan city that is to say
you can just count
i mean that is the people who teach
there have to stop their classes three
times an hour as the unbelievable racket
of the airplanes taking off the marines
acknowledged this they they stopped
helicopter flights uh so that the
students of you know high school could
take their college entrance exams
testifying they knew full wealth and on
any other day they couldn't hear
themselves think uh that is to say if
you're uh
we promised to return futenma we have
not we were dissimulating uh we in fact
the small prince said they've got to
build another airfield the 40th base
somewhere else in okinawa to serve our
interests
it's and there are many other things
like this that i could cite but that's
basically it uh it caused me
over the last five years to rethink
the security treaty to rethink the role
of the united states in east asia uh and
uh
to produce a different perspective on
the cold war than the one that i held in
the past
go ahead um i wonder if you could
explain a little bit further what you
consider to be the root causes of the
problem now the problem as i understand
it listening to you
is that the united states suffers from a
disease
it's called empireitis and it's a
disease that extends beyond any
particular administration
blowback is symptomatic of this disease
because the costs involve outweigh the
benefits of any action and it's endemic
okay so the question that i have is what
is it that makes it endemic that allows
a post-cold war administration like the
clinton administration which vows
allegiance to multilateralism to be more
caring to distancing yourself from the
very administration to adapt as you seem
to put it the same type of policies is
there something deficient within the
american psyche is it callous disregard
for people in okinawa and elsewhere or
is it just incompetence and inefficiency
so that um you know the americans
military wants to continue business as
usual even though there's no reason let
me repeat very quickly good question now
the question uh for the audience is
what what is
makes it endemic and and really systemic
within an administration today that very
much upon its coming to power wanted to
distance itself from the sort of bush
reagan era uh it's the the sort of
trappings of empire but yet uh we still
seem to be very much uh stuck in that
same mode what why why is that that uh
so rigid and and there the clinton
administration has actually used
military force more than any
administration since franklin roosevelt
despite their potentiations
but
it's a cliche of international relations
teaching to say no empire ever
voluntarily gave up
i can think of one that i think came
fairly close to doing that and that is
the ussr
under
gorbachev in which it does seem to me if
gorbachev didn't himself do it we
probably are very possibly uh
alive today because of uh of uh zakharov
and elena bonner who uh once they were
released from house arrest and work he
did explain to the politburo that star
wars was worthless easily defeated
uh and that the americans this was
he called it a maginot line in space
and and indicated easily how it could be
destroyed
but that why do we persist
i don't know the answer i mean it would
be a complex answer vested interest
hubris
the loss of prudence that is uh
aron i don't particularly i mean i think
i cite our own only because as a french
intellectual who was a defender of the
american role in the cold war and
perhaps the most passionate analysis
made by an independent figure
at the same time i'd have to say raymond
aron knew nothing about east asia
simply nothing he's out of his depth and
his attempts to
transfer uh
to uh uh to uh
uh that uh part of the world where we're
transferred the same analysis were
disastrous but he ends the imperial
republic by speaking of uh the need for
prudence
um the soviet union
so long as it existed imposed on us a
degree of prudence we were very much
aware that a mistake on our part would
be exploited just as we exploited their
numerous mistakes uh over the years
with the end of the cold war we seem to
have come up with such unimaginably
insane ideas as trying regardless of
culture or history to impose our
economic system on every other
seemingly capitalist system around the
world with disastrous results and it
strikes me as
as of passing interest that the american
establishment press wonders why there
were demonstrations in seattle or
demonstrations in washington dc this
week or
continuous discussions about that it is
amazing that the international monetary
fund should ever have come to the
attention of the public since it's
almost perfectly created front
organization as we used to say in the
old days that is it is a
surrogate of american power controlled
by the us treasury but formerly an
international organization therefore
beyond congressional oversight uh with a
with the figurehead european to headed
the netherlands has more votes in the
international monetary fund than either
china or india the investors of vasanar
carry greater weight
but so i don't know precisely why we
persist but i believe
uh in part it is as you say
indifference lack of information um
that
it does seem to me in fact precisely
what i'm trying to do
is to issue a warning that you reap what
you sow and a lot is being sown right
now
by
uh
by people in the name of by the
government in the name of the american
people the american people don't know
what is actually being done and i think
it will come back to haunt them
yes
david fitzgerald yes i have a question
in regards to
korea but
you mentioned earlier that you thought
that korea was a prime example at least
in the early 45 to 70 of american
imperialism in east asia
international relations is also not a
clear break from one
stage to another
one has to deal with it every day
situations change over time and rather
slow periods
and are not easy to calculate i'm
wondering if perhaps some of the
descriptions you're using are perhaps
more suitable to an earlier period and
we're we're not really looking at some
of the changes that are happening at
least in the past decade uh
you're describing this more or less a
mindless reaction uh to
cold war
establishment to
a new structures but
if you take korea since 1987 where
they're in
just taiwan now since uh last month
there's been new developments but the us
commitments and u.s role
has also changed over time although
there hasn't been any
major or dramatic changes on our part
david raises a good point and i'm going
to piggyback on it the point that he
raises is basically focusing on korea
particularly since 1987 you see profound
and dramatic changes there perhaps not
changes on the u.s side of the equation
but very much changes on the other side
i'd also say in japan and this is one
thing that you and i may
disagree on if you look at what prime
minister obuchi did
uh i i think that william phaff in a in
a case in germany in the international
herald tribune last week had a wonderful
line that said that
uh the united states
uh was very content as long as its
sovereignty uh dominated that the the
the sovereignty of its ally was
diminished in comparison to american
sovereignty and issues and in the case
of japan what obuchi did which i think
is real tribute to him is that he began
to coax out i think a healthy
uh sense of national sense of self in
japan you had the restoration of of what
everybody knew was de facto the
restoration of the flag of an anthem uh
you had a debate begin in the national
diet about decreasing for the first time
host nation support that the japanese
contributed to u.s forces and what was
most remarkable is july of this year
okinawa
this point of great controversy is going
to be host for the g8 meeting and you're
going to have at least seven of those
leaders if not bill clinton who i
understand is going to be helicoptered
from base to base and never be able to
step outside that but the rest of them
are going to drive by 39 military
installations and the rest of the world
will see what's going on there this had
to be i think a brilliant sleight of
hand by obuchi and i think like david
raised is at least some recognition or
some manifestation of change that we may
not have i'd like you to comment on
those
americans are change mongers they love
it they believe they see it occurring
all the time it is the most routine of
of uh stories for the foreign correspond
foreign affairs correspondent for the
new york times is to declare from
the reaches of the imperial hotel tokyo
that fundamental social change is
occurring in japan during my visit uh
the
uh the thing that i would like to stress
is that though these societies have
enormous tensions certainly korea and
japan
the
the kind of change that is needed is not
occurring but i'm delighted that you
raise the korean case because it seems
to me precisely the place where one
wants to stress
we did not intervene in the korean war
if you want to see it in our official
history we did not intervene in the
korean war because of a korean civil war
we intervened because of china and
russia now what has happened in the
1990s is that the regime we were
defending now has extremely friendly and
close diplomatic and trading relations
with both china and russia
our authority klauswitz tells us that
there is no excuse ever for not
maintaining uh diplomatic relations that
there he says at one point even during
hostilities you should have diplomatic
relations we and the japanese are the
ones who do not have diplomatic
relations with pyongyang that in fact we
have had this that is what has really
also happened during the 1990 i mean i
agree with you that kim daejeong is a
he's lucky to be alive and it's it's a
miracle that he's president uh that's
what's happened in taiwan is the
greatest ultimate source of confidence
that the same thing will ultimately
happen in mainland china since the women
don came from precisely the same kind of
leninist background of the chinese
communist party and that
the chief difference is that democracy
in taiwan has a distinct element of
decolonization to it too uh that in the
sense of the taiwanese speaking their
mind against the world of the
of the old woman exiles but that
we have i mean that is to say the
current chairman of the house foreign
affairs committee has regularly told us
that north korea has the capacity to
nuke seattle
i thought it was wonderful when the
federation of american scientists rented
their own satellite and flew it over the
launch site and took pictures of this
crummy it looks like an old oil derrick
sitting out there in the middle of
nowhere the north koreans have tested in
the 1994 missile or 19 totally four
missiles two in the 1990s
the
they had the desired effect from our
point of view of signing the japanese on
to something that probably doesn't work
but really is expensive the theater
missile defense which was one of the
things that we're in business to do
we've had inc i mean that is to say
decide the evidence on the other side
the con the systematic release of false
intelligence from the defense
intelligence agency telling us about
underground nuclear plants which then
the north koreans in return for food aid
invited us to come and look at and it
turns out to be empty caverns and and
things like that
an authority on this right here is
sitting here don oberdorfer on uh whose
chapter in his book on the the nuclear
issue in north korea is as good as you
can find
north korea is a failed communist regime
no longer viable after the ussr and
china changed their policies with no oil
facing a country that's twice as large
and 25 times richer the dod declared 10
years ago that south korea could defend
itself against anything except a nuclear
threat
and that was
said that at the time when the nuclear
threat might have come from
uh from russia
that i would have to say that we've been
remarkably slow
in
adjusting to
uh the changes that have occurred and
that
that
the north koreans have given us a
virtuosic display of how to play an
extremely weak hand
against a muscle-bound and stupid
superpower
and that they've done a good job of it
they've kept us off balance
causes to pay attention things of that
sort
but that
still the situation is essentially
unchanged there are still 37 000 troops
sitting on the dmz
whose sole purpose is to take casualties
in the open days of the war to ensure
that the u.s congress will honor the
security treaty
so you're only issuing a a a warning
here clearly um you have in mind the
changes that are either possible or at
least at least desirable and
two fundamental possibilities i've seen
there are no doubt more or that we re we
reorient u.s foreign policy to help try
to create a world where the interests of
great and small powers alike
are in fundamental harmony
so we can sort of leave each other alone
and coexist and trade freely back and
forth or
we try to reorient u.s foreign policy to
strengthen our ability to deal
effectively with a world that's still
going to be very challenging and where
in fact the interests of great and small
powers do periodically uh
collide and it wasn't quite clear to me
what you'd like to see
i will just be brief uh alan thompson's
question is really what then should we
do
[Applause]
it's uh always a fair question um the uh
let me go back again and and say that
indeed i believe our priorities are
wrong that uh the greatest defense of
our deployments is the danger of
instability the international system is
invariably and structurally always from
thucydides on unstable the issue
the issue is not effort in stability it
is the effect of the instability on your
own country and and what difference does
it make to you
if something is going on in this or that
that part of the world
that certainly
the issue of china has been raised here
i was early in my career i was chairman
of the center for chinese studies at
berkeley i'm still essentially primarily
a china specialist it seems to me
unequivocally
the news from china is good compared
with what it used to be china is today
essentially pursuing a commercial policy
to achieve
the uh the things that brought the party
to power
i believe we have our priorities
precisely wrong i believe that we are we
emphasize a military threat from china
that is largely non-existent and we
ignore an economic threat from china
that is overpowering that is the chinese
have the capacity ultimately to bankrupt
us if they if they are allowed to pursue
the same kinds of policies that uh our
satellites elsewhere in east asia
pursued during the cold war but that
instead we uh we demonize china
militarily and uh and wish to put them
in the wto uh on the on the other hand
and this strike me as uh
as wrong headed uh as for the
world of the future
obviously one could spend a great deal
of time and produce a laundry list of
things that we ought to do but that it
seems to me we must restore in the
united states a much greater uh panoply
of tools in international relations than
we have today we pioneered the use of
foreign aid today it's virtually dried
up we can't we don't pay our you in dues
even uh our diplomacy is scandalous uh
scandalously bad and normally
incompetent uh the
uh that it's there are too many centers
of foreign policy we do not attempt to
make ourselves a model
any longer for the rest of the world
rather than hectoring them uh we're
clearly uh insecure
about the values we think we are
foisting on to onto others
indeed the costs of
just mentioned to you a new book knowing
your interest
one of the major
historians of black america judith stein
at the ccny has a new book out on the
costs of black steel workers in
pittsburgh and birmingham alabama of
precisely the u.s empire that is and the
ease i mean she quotes marvelously from
paul voker on how
we didn't care
these were costs uh that we wanted we
want to build steel industries in other
countries uh and that we would move on
to financing them uh the uh
that is to say it's always put in terms
of protectionism uh isolationism or
other things that are that are simply
irrelevant but that
clearly it also it seems to me that in a
presidential debate we need or
presidential year we need an infinitely
greater discussion of foreign policy
that my impression is that the american
public
is ill-informed and indifferent to what
happens abroad and no longer care what
foreigners think of our think of us
this is a line
to remember the declaration of
independence which speaks of having a
the uh the uh decent respect for for
mankind of mankind we seem indifferent
to that today
it's just an ingrain who takes praise
and then turns around and i knew you
would but
you've been doing it since i've known
you so it's only fair
i mean i think a lot of what you said i
certainly agree with the need to rethink
what we're doing i certainly agree with
your final remarks about american
diplomacy needs to be
much more vigorous
but i don't i don't see i don't
recognize the world that you painted in
your lecture
to compare the united states and east
asia with the soviet union and eastern
europe seems to me absolutely ludicrous
the eastern europeans dried up and
had a terrible life the people in east
asia
most of them for most of the time
in the cold war and post-cold war years
except for the one year of 1997 have
been doing splendidly
and if you look at the people in korea
the people in japan the people certainly
in china since deng xiaoping
uh
their lives are getting
better the japanese it's true their
economy is flat
but the individual japanese is not
living
such a terrible life at all
i think the united states uh
hasn't done terribly i think it's done
fairly well as great nations are dealing
with other nations and i don't see it in
any way comparable with what happened in
eastern europe
don's question is uh
chow what world are you looking at uh as
as don orbidorfer sees it he sees a very
different case in which the united
states seem to do fairly well and
particularly on economic terms uh the
the the quality of life enjoyed by those
within the american superstructure uh uh
seemed to be remarkably better um uh
than that in which the in within the
soviet system
chalmers
obviously i don't want to be
misunderstood on on eastern europe there
is no question that the struggle was
democracy versus totalitarianism the
exodus of every major
uh artist who could leave the ussr if
they could do it do to our side has been
a brilliant testimony not necessarily to
our side western europe uh to paris is
where uh uh
uh most of them went first of all uh but
that it was
that is to say there is no doubt as one
thinks back
at that scene in uh 1949 when dimitri
shostakovich visiting this country was
asked if he really did sustain the views
he had printed of the music of igor
stravinsky in pravda
and he looked at the floor and said yes
i do and then writes in his memoirs had
i not said that i would have been shot
uh that that this is i mean of course i
agree on that those were not the issues
in east asia the issues there as i mean
as much as i admire your book on korea
you begin with 1950.
you don't really want to talk about
cheju or or or that is or the kinds of
things that we did in order to establish
sigmundry in power once we decided to do
so
as for the economic achievements of east
asia i would have to say that they're
close to indigestible in this country
that is i believe historians will record
that ultimately the most significant
thing that happened during the cold war
and it happened in an extremely stealthy
way was the enrichment of east asia
that we
uh persisted in believing for years that
it never was of any importance to us
that our economy was overwhelmingly
larger there are of course a great many
people in east asia that believe that
what happened in 1997 was indeed the
empire strikes back getting very very
irritated at the wealth of east asia
that it occurred at our expense because
of the policies we offered in order to
maintain uh our
uh our
uh empire there
i have no doubt that you're right that
the lives of individual uh koreans
japanese
uh
indonesians prior to 1997. i mean again
it's it's it's just criminal what
happened there people were literally
starving to death when
uh general suharto replaced sukarno uh
by the 1990s you had levels of living
that were really very very comfortable
in in java and they were destroyed by
arrogant fools from the international
monetary fund who turned a financial
crisis into an economic disaster and
they didn't know what country they were
in i mean they quite literally didn't
know
anything about the way the indonesian
economy worked they didn't know that
suharto was subsidizing
food and fuel the moment they ordered
those subsidies stopped you produced
instantaneous uh instability in a city
of 10 million like jakarta
but that again i that is to say
i would also not want to think that we
were responsible for the material
well-being of east asia i believe that
it happened
uh over and against that is they were
not copying us they were in fact taking
advantage of us that um
as any every time that i talked with
my former informants at the ministry of
international trade industry in japan
about reform
they always say to me don't talk to me
about reform it's our country we know
more about reform than you do but you
should understand
we go into meetings with people your age
people from the party
who say to us we profited more from the
cold war than any other nation
the americans still enjoying playing
cold war they couldn't after all afford
the gulf war we put up the 13 billion
dollars that that paid for it and the
goddamn kuwaitis didn't even put our
name on the stamp uh but that that they
issued uh but that uh baker and brady
did come and uh and get the money out of
the gym in fact the pentagon once said
we even made a few bucks off of uh off
of the gulf war uh but that uh the
the argument is uh so long as the
americans continue to want to play cold
war we should go along with them it uh
it serves our interest to do so uh
i don't believe this is an argument i
think it's an argument for drift waiting
for the crisis that ultimately will
destroy this system just as
uh the soviet system was itself
destroyed stanley hoffman once said to
me that he'd attended a conference of
virtually every uh prominent german
historian on earth a month before the
wall came down and i know one of them
had a clue that anything was going on
the central intelligence agency devoted
the 1980s to overstating the soviet
economy uh in an absurd manner including
the strength of the soviet navy and
things like that they're supposed to be
good at uh and not noticing it was
collapsing on them
so that i'd have to say
of course you're right about the
economic achievements in east asia and
the level of well-being that is clearly
enjoyed
uh including in mainland china it's one
of the most stimulating things about
shanghai today
but that uh that's not what we're
talking about what we're really talking
about is our claim
to have spread our ideals where in fact
what we are known for in east asia are
military dictatorships that were
ultimately overcome against our will
most notably in south korea
let me take the last question
thank you
advocacy i agreed with most of what you
had to say i just have two questions
perhaps quibbles uh with your some of
your books on trade the first is i think
perhaps you misread the demonstrations
in seattle which you referred to several
times
i don't think they were so much
anti-interventionist
as in many instances proposing new forms
of intervention seconded by the
president uh for labor and environmental
standards uh as conditionalities to
trade uh enforced by sanctions um which
much to the resentment of the developing
countries in particular
as as intervention in their internal
affairs
second
question by actually the statement but i
suppose you disagree with me
the the second uh
more formal question is your remarks
that japan was engaged in uh predatory
trade use the word predatory it's been
used before in terms of dumping and
other forms of policies
presumably they are selling at
sub-competitive prices in order to
hollow out u.s industries or expression
there whereupon they will
use their monopoly to charge supra
competitive prices uh in order to
make up for their losses and then gain
the monopoly profits that all
monopolists seek
how is that possible when south koreans
and and brazilians can make cars and
steel and all that
two quick quibbles uh one uh defining
seattle is really a batter battle over
label labor and environmental standards
uh and asking for comments on that front
uh second comment really deals with
japanese
strategic i would put it strategic trade
and sort of looking back particularly at
the 60s and 70s maybe early 80s of the
strategy by which
you would
see dumping
of certain strategic industries in in
third countries the uh financing of that
in japan's domestic market as a way to
sort of put uh out of business uh
major multinationals or companies in
other countries how is that sustainable
in the global system where there's so
much over capacity i'll say over
capacity today in such a competitive
environment in the global economy
on your first point i stipulate you're
right
that is even if the president seems
likely to have come to it uh the but
nonetheless of course the the danger in
these economic affairs since 1997 has
been a collapse of global demand and
structural recession uh one of the ways
clearly to deal with that is to enlarge
demand and enlarging demand means
enlarging
putting more
purchasing power in the hands of poor
people
and i
believe that this is one of the main
things that brings
labor and others into these issues and i
i strongly support them but certainly
it's more complex than i i simply uh uh
suggested and you're absolutely right
that many third world countries dislike
this interventionism one of the few
places that the
big business and the chinese communist
party are completely agreed upon is they
do not want labor unions in china uh and
uh uh and for uh different reasons but
we but we full well understand them that
is uh we uh the
americans love to say they want the rule
of law
they love investing in china precisely
because there isn't any uh and uh that's
that's one of the great attractions of
the place and the party keeps it that
way for them um on the other issue what
i'm talking about is industrial policy
sango
i'm talking about the use of the
government
to um
uh
in some ways that is just put it this
way
you know economists love a four-fold box
and i'm not going to try and draw one on
this beautiful painting but if you take
one
take a fourfold box and use two old
marxist as well as adam smith terms
ownership and control if in one box
ownership and control are both in state
hands
that's stalinism
it's extremely effective in a war type
economy it is extremely inefficient it
misallocates resources and these
ultimately begin to show up
if you move to a second box that we
would call
state ownership but private control
that's what you begin to see in china
that's what you see in
countries that are trying to overcome
the rigidities of a stalinist system by
devolving economic decision making to
the level of the of the household or the
factory or something of this sort and it
mildly increases efficiency it does not
ever produce entrepreneurship in the
sense that schumpeter defined it for us
uh the japanese
the true reason why the japanese should
have received a nobel prize in economics
from the reich's bank of sweden rather
than professors at the university of
chicago is to reverse these two orders
to produce a system in which you have
private ownership but state control that
is to say what you have in japan taiwan
you have private ownership it is genuine
private ownership inheritable
defensively legal it's not like private
ownership in the bronx uh it is real
it's it's a real right
it's worth something and your family
finds it worth something the state says
if you will get wealthy you can get very
wealthy making semiconductors or
whatever else we feel we wish that that
is we wish the industrial industrial
structure we used to produce if you want
to try and get wealthy making yachts or
porno movies we will make life miserable
for you we will discriminate against you
we will expropriate you we will put you
out of business uh and then of course
the fourth box is private ownership and
private control
that's the united states which produces
neoclassical economics the the physics
of where the thing is going without
anybody being in charge uh that is i
mean which rock it's going to hit which
digit will roll through
et cetera
the
my argument is that the united states
systematically refused to recognize what
japan was doing as it began
targeting industries that
the seven volume study made of the
reference economies in the early 1960s
by the ministry of international trade
industry the united states and germany
is still if you read japanese the best
single analyses of these two economies
ever written in any language the
japanese did their homework they uh they
truly did understand our society that uh
so that i'm not arguing for a case of
dumping
or any of the things that come from
business school economics i'm arguing
that japan used economic and growth
growth
to to enrich the power of japan not of
individual japanese uh and in that sense
it is much closer to the world of
the so-called german historical school
of uh of uh franz of
friedrich list rather than adam smith
perhaps the most
famous academic
innovator in the world of producing
japanese industrial policy the late
professor hiromi arisawa in a meeting i
had with uh
with professor arisawa once as i walked
into the room uh he said to me professor
johnson i have two things to say to you
i'm a non-communist marxist and i had
more influence than all of those
american trained economists ever thought
of having
when he says non-communist marxist he
means he's interested not in efficiency
but in who won the war
that is to say the test of economic
activities is efficiency the test of
military activities is who won
and that's what the japanese have been
engaged in
chalmers thank you very much
uh three quick three quick points uh i
know the room is hot and i invite all of
you to join us uh for refreshments out
tanaka here who in fact will be talking
about some of these issues nobody
tanaka's the minister in the japanese
embassy for metis who's talking about uh
can't japan have a new economy too uh
which will be very interesting invite
you all back and third i would share
with you something al gore vice
president al gore candidate hasn't
really addressed the military and
security issues that i think are before
us in july but george bush has in a very
interesting way and i it would be an
interesting test
both secretary perry uh with the
assistance of joe nye as revolver who
many of us know
um became very committed to this notion
of a hundred thousand troops both in
europe and a hundred thousand troops in
asia
um
bill uh
bill cohen secretary cohen perry's
successor uh i think made an incredible
mistake uh because as the quadrennial
defense review unrolled and as he spoke
about the quadrennial defense review
which was a review of sort of uh
contingencies resources american
strategy he would go around saying we
subjected everything to
scrutiny and to recalculation and
reconsideration with one exception asia
will remain the same which of course is
the red flag that this is the achilles
heel this is on record it's on the
pentagon website but interestingly
george w bush though
i can uh constrain my enthusiasm for
either candidate uh nonetheless george
bush has come out and said that he won't
make that mistake that in fact
everything will be subjected to that
kind of review and this will be an
interesting time ahead chalmers thank
you very much for your provocative and
thoughtful comments and thank all of you
chalmers johnson is president of the
japan policy research institute and
professor emeritus of the university of
california san diego his previous books
have focused on japan and asia
metropolitan in his new book the sorrows
of empire this talk from the los angeles
public library is an hour
[Applause]
[Music]
well thank you louise and thanks to the
library foundation and thanks to you for
all coming out on a rainy night
to see an extraordinary man i know that
you will not be disappointed by this
this performance this evening
i
have since i started doing radio
broadcast in 1992 i've probably
conducted about
10 or 12 000 interviews something along
those lines because every program has a
lot of interviews on it
and uh we do everything by phone
uh those who are repeaters i get to know
on a sort of telephone basis chalmers
johnson is one of those and so it's a
real privilege and pleasure for me to
have met him tonight for the first time
and
and to be here even though we have
talked together many times on the radio
and then off the radio as well but again
only by
phone one of the problems we have with
uh chalmers is that on our program we
try to balance
each each
broadcast with the people who have
different points of view about whatever
the topic of the day
may be
and we try to balance them in in every
way and it's very difficult to find
somebody to balance with chalmers
[Laughter]
by that i mean that
a person who is uh so relentlessly
logical so wonderfully persuasive in the
way he argues so articulate
and so well informed so fortunately we
didn't have to balance him today i don't
have to argue with him i'm just going to
ask him questions
but i'm delighted to be able to do it
the latest book of course is the sorrows
of empire
and the empire involved needless to say
is the empire of the united states which
he argues has been brought into
existence
and operated without the
real awareness or understanding of the
american people who nonetheless
are the ones who are
supporting it
as you can imagine it's not a book
that's full of a lot of laughs
and in fact in the prologue he says
this is not an optimistic report
and i think that may be the only
understatement in 400 pages of material
in the sorrows of empire he says later
that i fear that
we will lose our country
and then apologizes lest that be an
overstatement but says he thinks he will
be forgiven by future generations if it
is an overstatement because they'll be
so glad that he was wrong
so i must say that i hope you're wrong
but nonetheless uh the arguments are
persuasive and are interesting and uh
let us get to them but let me begin this
way i don't know uh if people know your
background well
and it's important i think to what you
have written
particularly given the fact that the the
military and the cia are both uh
instruments of the empire that genomers
describes
and he has been in both the military and
the cia the cia at least as an advisor
and i think it's his experiences there
that uh have had a lot to do with the
ideas that have now evolved into the
book the sorrows of empire so let's
begin there tell us a bit about your
experience in the military about your
experience with the cia and how they
were formative to what we see in the
book
warren it's a great pleasure to put name
and face together it really is to uh
have a chance to
appear here in the los angeles public
library in this forum uh yes i was in
the navy uh in the korean war i was the
operations officer on a rust bucket uh
the uh lst 883 um hauling marines around
korea and places like that this was
important to me because it was my first
introduction to east asian civilization
i began studying japanese
at the naval base in yokosuka i returned
to berkeley and studied chinese uh and
uh spent my life working on the politics
of china japan
i was a cold warrior i did believe that
the
soviet union was a genuine menace
uh and in 1967 i was then the chairman
of the center for chinese studies at the
university of california berkeley i was
recruited by richard helms then the
director of cia soon to be indicted for
lying to congress over uh the uh
overthrow of salvador andy in
in uh chile uh he claimed that we had
nothing to do with it of course we had
everything to do with it
the uh
i was uh
i was in the office of national
estimates which are now in the news
again uh they're extremely highly
classified papers that go to the
president they're classified primarily
because they are so unbelievably bae now
it would be an embarrassment to the uh
to the american public to realize the
quality of uh this is this is what
passes for strategic thought in the oval
office uh but uh uh nonetheless it was
uh certainly it was a formative
experience i
one just one anecdote from those days i
do remember that as the
as uh daniel ilber ellsberg's pentagon
papers began to be published in the new
york times there was literally cheering
in the halls of langley
as uh the people who had worked on
vietnam said finally we no longer look
like such a
group of fools we've been saying for a
long time that the war was unwinnable
and we had enormous respect for ellsberg
he was as we used to say one of us he
was a marine officer he had served in
vietnam he had a phd in economics from
harvard he was a rand corporation
character my god it was easy to give him
a security clearance uh the and uh i
just had a pleasant conversation with
him not too long ago and he was saying
that he wished he'd acted earlier but
what you're wondering is well what many
people say to me things like
when did you stop being a bloodlusting
fascist hyena i know
you said that
that wasn't his question but uh just to
put it very briefly there were two
certainly formative influences one uh
analytical and the other quite concrete
with the collapse of the soviet union in
1991 i believe that we should have seen
a much greater peace dividend a
withdrawal from our huge deployments
around the world the menace of the
soviet union was gone the cold war was
clearly over russia is a much smaller
country than the former soviet union
used to be instead our government moved
at once even before saddam hussein's
invasion of kuwait
moved at once to try and find
replacement enemies and to shore up the
cold war structures in
latin america and east asia
i believe this posed a major analytic
question was the cold war a cover for
something more fundamental for an
american imperial project that probably
went back to world war ii in which we
used anti-communism as a cover for
essentially imperialist activities it
was extremely convenient to us in latin
america
we've used fidel castro for years to
cover what were in fact
activities undertaken for the sake of
the united fruit company or of of
anaconda copper company or something of
that sort
so that i set out to investigate that
the
concrete experience was a visit to
okinawa in 1996. this is the
southernmost japanese uh province
prefecture it's the poorest prefecture
in japan it has 38 american military
bases located on an island smaller than
kauai in the hawaiian islands
it is uh the japanese equivalent of
puerto rico it has been
seized by the japanese empire into the
19th century
discriminated against ever since and
essentially used today as a dumping
ground for american troops they'd like
to
maintain
the japanese american security treaty
but they don't want the third marine
division located anywhere close to them
on september 4th 1995 an extremely
serious incident occurred two marines
and a sailor from camp hanson a big ugly
base in the middle of okinawa had
abducted beaten and raped a 12 year old
girl it produced the
largest demonstrations against the
united states since uh the
uh security treaty was signed
um i was invited by the governor of
okinawa to come to okinawa in february
1996 to talk to his staff about this
incident and i did so and i was truly
shocked by what i saw by the
uh
as well as the fact that the uh then
the commandant of american forces in
east asia was general richard myers he
is today of course chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff he took the standard
routine
way of dealing with these issues to say
well this is an exceptional tragic
incident uh three bad apples but in no
way typical of our troops uh my research
including research published just quite
recently
has demonstrated that the rate of
sexually violent crimes leading to court
martial in okinawa has for 50 years
averaged at two a month uh there was
nothing the only thing exceptional about
the rape of 1995 was that they raped a
child uh instead of uh of a mature woman
who very often they depend upon the fact
that she would be so humiliated she
wouldn't come forward anyway
my first reaction was that okinawa must
be exceptional that this place is just
not nobody's paid attention to it the
military is extremely skilled in public
relations the press never goes down
there the japanese don't encourage you
to go down there
after i began to investigate our big
american military enclaves in
the persian gulf in diego garcia in
south korea in japan in
germany england italy uh i discovered
that
okinawa was not exceptional it was
typical that is around what americans
don't appreciate is that foreigners
commonly
the americans they see
are not representatives of our popular
culture or of our movies or whatever
else that we're sometimes proud of what
they see are 18 to 24 year old young men
usually in
the special forces in well over 130
countries around the world and uh these
people live with
continuous sexual violence
noise pollution uh
environmental pollution bar brawls
drunk driving uh one thing after another
i would simply conclude by saying there
are no foreign troops based in the
united states so unless you have lived
next door to one of these bases abroad
you don't know anything about what goes
on with it next to them
i'm not in a position to argue with you
of course and or dispute your research
but what reason does the military give
for having these bases in so many
countries around the world they don't
actually give a reason the base
structure report published each year by
the department of defense lists at the
time of this book 2002
725 military bases located in other
people's countries that's believe me
considerably more than we need for any
conceivable strategic purpose 725 is
also just the official number
they leave out all the secret bases the
espionage bases the bases in england
that are disguised as royal air force
bases the three bases in israel that are
highly secret uh they never mentioned
the bases in uzbekistan kyrgyzstan
camp bond steel and kosovo uh they don't
mention uh the four bases being built as
we talk in iraq or
uh places like that the uh
this these bases came into being in the
course of fighting one or another of our
various wars we almost never give one up
when the war is over we start then
finding new uses for it new
uh the only time we give them up is
after we lost a war after vietnam we did
lose our bases in in spain in greece and
in the philippines simply because they
decided it their governments that it
wasn't so useful to be allied
or to be tolerant of
of the american bases but the
justification is essentially strategic
needs
in uh without ever saying so in so many
words to maintain american hegemony over
the globe
american hegemony or stability in
various parts of the world what's the
difference stability is an odd term i
know they love it that's the kind of
word they they started to use uh when
they were looking for a replacement for
the soviet union
teachers of international relations say
by the very nature of the international
system it is unstable the issue was
never stability the issue is whether the
stability is of any importance to our
country the instability where it may or
may not occur so they claim that they're
also maintaining
stability but at the same time i mean
for example secretary rumsfeld was just
recently in okinawa and said to the
governor that the bases there were
justified by the stability that we had
brought to the area without over 50
years without ever mentioning either the
korean or vietnamese wars that had
occurred throughout this period in which
uh
okinawa was a major launching area uh
for these things or all the other
numerous smaller incidents like east
timor or or whatever else it's not clear
if that in any sense our extremely
high-tech military brings stability to
anything it may very well produce the
opposite and it certainly produces
anti-americanism
are we not protecting regimes that are
allied with us for various purposes
the military actually prefers regimes
that are not democratic uh that is
they're in fact one of the specific
justifications today for the removal of
the bases from germany into places poor
former communist countries like romania
and bulgaria is that
the germans demand much higher standards
of environmental protection than they do
and the military has said in so many
words we can be dirty in these countries
the status of forces agreements that we
impose on all countries exempt us from
ever cleaning up the messes that we that
we make in some cases we are dealing
with allies but
let's take kyrgyzstan and uzbekistan
part of the military petroleum complex
and our attempts to bring
the oil of the caspian basin under our
control we've built military bases there
one of them is called the
the captain peter j gunsi junior air
force base peter j gunty is the highest
ranking fireman in the new york fire
department who lost his life on
9 11.
the russians have now just built a new
base 40 miles away it's the first
military base
russia has built since the collapse of
the soviet union they're clearly trying
to
to
balance us the governments of kyrgyzstan
and uzbekistan are probably as
right-wing authoritarian old
apparatchiks left over from the soviet
union as you could find i mean that is
our president loves to go out of this
he's been quoted by bob woodward of the
western post how he loathes kim jong-il
of north korea uh these two guys make
kim jong-il look like a fairly decent
neighbor uh the uh and they've both been
welcomed to the uh uh to the oval office
it always reminds me that when he said
he loathed kim jong-il of north korea i
always crossed my mind george bush and
kim jong-il do have one thing in common
neither of them would be where they are
without their daddies
neither of them could conceivably have
risen above
gas station attendant uh with
you know without without that uh but uh
no it's it's not at all clear that the
united that is the united states has an
almost impeccable record in east asia of
sponsoring anti-democratic regimes of
bringing military officers to power uh
that one of our greatest allies on earth
today is
general pervez musharraf of pakistan who
after all came to power in the clinton
administration through a
military overthrow of a democratically
elected government we have uh we have
laws that are supposed to keep us from
participating with such people so that
yes you may say that we are in a certain
sense protecting our allies and it did
make sense at one time during the cold
war when we were
a status quo power attempting to build
an edifice of legality of international
law of the united nations uh the use of
foreign aid in
uh as a tool of of diplomacy something
we pioneered
but uh and we were doing this against
the revisionist powers the powers that
were trying to change the world like
nazi germany or imperial japan or
uh mao's china or uh the soviet union
today i think you would have to say that
we are without question the most
revisionist of revisionist powers we we
openly proclaim we are the new rome we
are beyond good and evil we are beyond
the need for friends we are beyond the
need for the united nations uh paul
wolfowitz that is the assistant
secretary defense uh virtually uses the
old roman phrase we do do not care
whether they love us so long as they
fear us uh this is uh so that's in in
that sense i find it uh
stretching a point to say that we are
doing this for the benefit of anyone
else
you've um
excoriated and made fun of the current
president but uh obviously you think
this goes back to previous
administrations as well when did it go
wrong or when did things go wrong
according to your question
uh i mean precisely i'm this book is not
particularly an anti-bush book i mean i
wouldn't want to kid you if this is in
the chinese calendar the year of the
monkey and i'd vote for a monkey to uh
uh
to
to to uh to replace the current
government uh but uh the uh want to say
chalmers johnson's views are his and not
those of the management absolutely
necessarily we have a free exchange of
ideas in the los angeles public library
uh but that um
i think
the critical mistake i believe mistake
in the in the talleyrand sense of
fundamental irrev irreparable strategic
error
uh was in 1991 with the collapse of the
soviet union and bear in mind it
happened rapidly we didn't anticipate it
the cia radically overestimated the size
of the soviet economy in the 1980s uh i
mean if if we were having this
conversation in 1985 and i had said to
you five years from now the soviet union
will disappear
you would have thought this guy's
inhaling too deeply on something grown
around the berkeley campus i mean this
is not a this is this is not a reliable
commentator well it's gone
it it came apart for forces that are
also influencing us in this country
today too that is in 1991 we concluded
wrongly that we had won the cold war
we simply didn't lose it as badly as
they did because we were richer than
they were and it took us longer to do so
we had absolutely nothing we did had
anything to do with the collapse of the
soviet union least of all reagan star
wars we know that in detail gorbachev
brought soccer off into the politburo to
describe how to defeat an anti-ballistic
ballistic missile defense and he gave a
brilliant exposition and they spent not
a ruble on it uh the uh
this was an error we concluded now
in virtually the words of paul wolfowitz
in the original draft of what is now
today the national security document but
of september 2002 but that was first
written in the last years of the first
bush administration that
our policy now is to maintain absolute
dominance over the world militarily
ultimately from bases in outer space
that and this is to keep under control
everyone that is not enemies
every source of power including allies
that might ultimately compete with this
this i think is a kind of hubris a kind
of arrogance a kind of
of unreality that uh
begins to uh well it separates us away
from the rest of the world we do we like
many people in washington at least in
the pentagon do like this phrase the new
rome we're beginning to behave like the
roman empire and with the uh i mentioned
this simply of course the roman empire
it took 300 years to fall the uh
collapse of empires is now starting to
come sort of with the speed of fedex the
uh uh the the thousand-year reich lasted
uh 12 years uh from 1933 to to the sack
of berlin in 1945 by uh the red army uh
the soviet union's empire fell apart
between 1989 and 1991
ours is
may well be beyond the rubicon already
as it is in terms of imperial uh
overstretch
but uh
i think this is when we started to go
wrong was when we concluded that uh
wrongly that we had won the cold war and
were therefore
no longer
there were no longer
challenges or threats to us from the
rest of the world in any military sense
you just used the term overstretch what
about the fact that many in the military
apparently now
uh are very concerned that we are
overstretched in terms of our military
capability and
not likely to be able to do much about
it with a volunteer army and reserves
now
being used up it's my understanding
there are a lot of people in the
pentagon very very concerned about that
who feel that the war in iraq was a
poorly uh was a misjudged effort no
question about that i mean it is one of
the great restraints on our empire that
now is starting to show up where do we
get the cannon fodder uh the uh
it's not been an obligation of
citizenship to defend the country since
1973 it is a career choice uh it is not
those of you who are veterans of world
war ii or korea or vietnam simply
wouldn't recognize life in the armed
forces today it's a
uh you don't do kp anymore you don't
clean latrines that's all farmed out to
companies like kellogg brown and root
subsidiary of cheney's halliburton uh
very lucratively uh because you've got
to make life in the armed forces
attractive it starts to develop a
uh that moreover people join the
military today largely because uh or in
many cases they do so to escape one
another dead end of our society that's
why
uh african americans are twice as well
represented in the army as they are in
the society as a whole fifty percent of
the women in the armed forces are
national minorities uh i thought it was
uh
telling when uh pfc jessica lynch was
wounded at nazarea and the press asked
her why'd she join the army just i
couldn't get a job at walmart in
palestine west virginia i uh it was a it
was my way out
i joined the army to get out of
palestine west virginia
the
important point she didn't expect to be
shot
and most of the people being
joining the army do not expect to be
shot at
and that is one of the great restraints
we have on the armed forces right now is
we will see in a very short period of
time whether you can continue to attract
sufficient numbers of people into the
armed forces to fulfill our imperial uh
plans uh or whether we have to go to
something very politically loaded like a
draft or uh probably in the back of most
of the planners mines is a traditional
imperialist strategy start looking for
foreign
cannon fodder sepoys uh uh we did you
did that in vietnam with mountain yards
and uh
and humong people and things like that
uh we're certainly trying it today
attract trying to attract uh alleged
coalition partners like uh the japanese
or the uh or the dutch or the poles or
whatever to send troops to uh uh to uh
uh uh iraq it is of course the danger in
that strategy is are they loyal i mean
when we use the word seboys well that
was a sepoy rebellion of 1857 in india
most of the british army and india were
made up of indian troops and when they
revolted it became it's well known in
indian history the first movement of
liberation of india from british
imperialism but it's a major constraint
of whether we will run out of uh
the manpower and woman power today to uh
to staff the empire uh and it as well as
the fact that it's unimaginably
expensive
when other countries are willing to send
troops to whatever for whatever purpose
to iraq or anyplace else where we have
uh where we are engaged
uh isn't that an indication of
international support
for whatever it is that is being done
doesn't it validate the policy as is so
often argued if we could only get the
u.n to be more involved with
iraq have
have troops from other countries as the
democratic candidates have been
advocating
then we'll have a kind of validity and
an acceptance uh in that part of the
world that we simply don't know well
that's what the
the white house would like you to
believe and says it on the uh on the
evening news owned by the entertainment
conglomerates uh the but the truth the
matter is people cooperate with us
because of the threat of retaliation
because of the fear that a country as
powerful as ours is with vast uh i mean
the major international economic
institutions the world bank the uh
uh
world trade organization and the
international monetary fund uh as the
demonstrators in seattle in november
1999 demonstrated showed to the rest of
the world these are among the most
anti-democratic not undemocratic
anti-democratic institutions that exist
on earth and they're completely under
the thumb of
of the u.s treasury
they can be used if need be
to uh
even just the threat of their being used
is enough to cause most countries to uh
to uh
come along with us the thing that is
astonishing to me today is that
two
such powerful countries as france and
germany should have decided to stand
aloof
that countries that could have avoided
uh our might make might makes right
adventure in in iraq
uh uh
japan uh britain uh
australia uh they've uh
actually are isolating themselves badly
i mean one of the results of what's
happened in iraq is that britain simply
will never for decades have influence on
the continent again they're not trusted
any longer uh you could get rid of tony
blair but uh uh indeed it's stuck around
the world that blair is bush's poodle
and koizumi is his cocker spaniel uh
that uh
that they these people uh
understand
the the uh the nature of power in the
world at the same time
there is growing inevitably because of
the openness of the administration in
its dropping of its mask and what it
wants to do compared with the world of
bill clinton where he protected himself
by by putting it under globalization or
humanitarian intervention or some other
rubric that suggested it wasn't simply
american policy to maintain hegemony
over the world but that uh now we have
this this uh uh
situation of openness that has started
to lead to
i mean
a year ago in february of 2003 10
million people in every democracy on
earth demonstrated against the bush
administration the war in iraq and for
democracy four hundred thousand in new
york two million in london the largest
demonstration in british history a
million each in berlin madrid uh rome uh
those people haven't gone away
they're uh
their their organization today is
virtually a uh a guarantee
of uh
uh it's as if a new superpower were
rising to thwart the ambitions of the
united states
i recommend to all of you that you read
arundhati roy's brilliant speech to the
uh the world social forum that just
closed in bombay she calls her speech do
the turkeys enjoy thanksgiving
what she's basically talking about is
that peculiar american uh
custom now of the president sparing a
single turkey
for a happy life in a virginia farm and
while we eat the rest of them
and she regards this as a metaphor for
america's attitudes towards the third
world but uh she ends her speech i mean
it is the winner of the booker prize and
she she fascinates me because she says
things nobody else ever says and the
moment she says it they become common
knowledge but she ends by saying i'm
tired of demonstrating i want a boycott
i can cease people on everywhere they
are everything they produce everything
that happens a boycott starting that
just starts off with 10 million people
is is a restraint on
on a country like ours so that it's not
as though
i mean maybe we are the new rome but our
decline has
started fairly rapidly you talked about
the clinton administration and uh said
that it had been shielded in certain
ways that president clinton shielded
himself from what's essentially the same
kind of thing that the bush
administration is doing what about the
balkans and kosovo why on earth would we
want to uh be concerned about that part
of the world what interests do we have
there
it's a wonderful question delighted to
answer it
that is to say bill clinton said we'd
only be there for six months the current
president uh uh campaigned on the idea
that we shouldn't be there at all that
what is this uh peacekeeping operation
to protect the uh kosovar albanians from
serbs
well
there's a base there called camp bond
steel it's not listed in the base
structure report the army proudly says
there are only two things two man-made
objects you can see from outer space the
great wall of china and camp bond steel
it is it was built in 1999 the richest
base we've built since the vietnam war
was built by kellogg brown and root of
of halliburton uh it lies directly
athwart
the proposed uh
pipeline across the balkans that kellogg
brown and root have already also
surveyed that is the plan we had a coup
d'etat just a few weeks ago in
in georgia to make sure that we have a
friendly government there as we begin to
extract oil from the caspian sea
move it through georgia to the black sea
across the black sea to bulgaria and
then across the balkans uh to
the adriatic coast in albania
avoiding uh the bosporus and dardanelles
that are too narrow they limit ships to
150 000 tons going through there uh the
uh camp monster lies directly thwart
this uh uh this uh uh uh pipeline and is
part of of what
we call the military petroleum complex
much of our i mean today
we are motivated to maintain our
profligate use of uh of fossil fuels and
have refused to uh to conserve in any
way even though we've had the technology
for some time to eliminate entirely our
dependence on on persian gulf oil the uh
the symbol of the united states after 9
11 in europe became
some sort of
youthful lout uh driving a uh chevrolet
suburban down the uh down the freeways
with a uh american flag attached to his
antenna the uh i think the suburban gets
about 11 miles to gallon uh its sales
doubled in the years after uh 911
extremely profitable product for uh
general motors
it's a choice
we use more petroleum than anybody else
does we also think that we can
exercise control over potential
sources of power in the future such as
china grew at 9.1 percent last year it
is easily
the fastest growing large economy on
earth today uh that we could use oil to
uh to control them in the future
so that
that is we're looking at the whole
southern eurasian world opened up by the
collapse of the soviet union from the
balkans to china
as it stands right now with our
positions in iraq and afghanistan as
well as in central asia we have
uh only iran stands in the way uh that's
therefore it's not accidental that it
appears on the
the uh axis of evil uh i've actually
traveled in this part of the world i
swum in the caspian sea it has a
distinctly oily smell to it uh the uh
when i did it it was it was back in
brezhnev's days uh it was better known
for sturgeon and caviar
but
baker botts the firm of
the great republican secretary of state
jim baker has a a law office in baku
azerbaijan there's not too much legal
business to do in baku i mean
there's not too many
i mean that is the american ambassador
to kazakhstan very pleasant extremely
well-educated woman drove her car around
the capital of kazakhstan with a bumper
strip on it that said happy is happiness
is twin pipelines uh she was thinking
thinking of the pipelines across
afghanistan from tajikistan uh to for
the union oil company uh
to uh uh uh
the arabian sea in uh in pakistan it's
uh
we're in the balkans for uh
oil politics
not to save kosovars
what would you say to an american who
said okay um if in fact we have this
kind of hegemony over the rest of the
world if we can exert this kind of power
if we can engineer acoustic in georgia
or anyplace else
and
feed ourselves and uh and our way of
living at the same time and and
uh do so without um a fear of attack
by anybody why shouldn't we
sit back and enjoy it yes uh
well
this is
the reason i've tried that i've written
this book
it's a sequel to a book that i published
in the year 2000 called blowback the
costs and consequences of american
empire blowback is a cia term it
it means retaliation obviously it first
was used in the after action report on
the overthrow of mosaddegh in iran in
1953 for the sake of the british
petroleum company we
accused him of being a communist the
pope would probably fit that uh category
more accurately than mohamed mosadek
did we brought the shah to power
notoriously but that the uh
i conclude by
what i'm trying to do in this book is to
lay out a vast amount of information in
what i hope is a readable manner
that i'm reasonably certain americans
don't have and they desperately need to
have it they need to know about the base
world they need to know about the
interests there they need to understand
what george washington was talking about
in his farewell address when he warned
against the influence of standing armies
uh what dwight eisenhower was
was talking about in his farewell
address in
1961 when he invented the phrase
military industrial complex he meant to
say military industrial congressional
complex we know from his papers but was
warned off from uh from uh doing that
the
uh
we may have already passed
across the rubicon it may be
irreversible uh a genuine american hero
like senator robert byrd from west
virginia continues to give these
impassioned and intelligent and informed
speeches knowledgeable of american
history
in empty uh in empty senate chambers
he's our cicero uh the uh uh
he he i think will by our society just
be ignored as an old man from a poor
state cicero ended up with his head in
both hands nailed to the forum wall by
the yan the then boy emperor octavian
soon to become the god augustus caesar
the uh and to institute uh military
dictatorship my four sorrows that i end
with and why i i
i stress this were are perpetual war
the president and the vice president
have identified between 50 and 60
countries they would like to do
uh regime change in using our military
uh secondly the losses they've done that
publicly yes they've done that publicly
yes
it was uh that
cheney first said 50 and then in the
west point speech
bush raised him to 60.
the
um
the second is the loss of the republic
uh it is the irreversible damage to the
constitution i mean the most important
author of the constitution james madison
wrote under the name publius used
referring to our roman antecedents uh in
the federalist papers that the single
most important article in the
constitution was the one that gave the
power to declare war exclusively to the
elected representatives the people never
under any circumstances should it be
entrusted to a single man
uh
the responsibility was too great in
october of 2002 our congress gave that
power to a single man on his say-so when
he felt like it including the use of
nuclear weapons if he cares to do so and
it helps sell the congress by doing by
creating a false
uh
national intelligence estimate on iraq
in the same month that was passed to
congress essentially
uh a national intelligence estimate in
which the cia was ordered to find the
evidence to back up the speeches that
vice president cheney has already given
now uh the
as we talk articles four and six of the
bill of rights are dead letters you do
not have uh uh as i say the president
has invented a new category known as and
i'm not kidding you and i'm not being
sarcastic it is known as bad guy
and if if the president declares you a
bad guy
he even though you're a native born
citizen he can throw you in a naval brig
in charleston south carolina and keep
you there uh we're about soon to find in
the next few months uh
whether or not the supreme court that
appointed this president would care to
address these issues uh but uh
the
these are the i mean we're talking about
very serious incidents here the third
of my sorrows of empire is
disinformation it is lying to the public
by the government probably the most
serious example we've had it goes on
every day with weapons of mass
destruction so-called what was february
5th last year the secretary of state
colin powell in the u.n security council
uh with the director of central
intelligence sitting like a potted plant
behind him
so that he's his face appeared in any
television picture allegedly providing
very similitude uh trying to recreate
the scene in the security council when
uh adelaide stephenson came in with the
youtube pictures of the uh
russian uh missiles in uh in cuba uh
precipitating the cuban missile crisis
when we
offered our evidence to the world we now
know that everything colin powell said
that day was a lie and he had ample
reason to know it was that it was
manufactured and wrong there is not
a serious informed statesman on earth
today that would believe a word said by
the secretary of state of the united
states he's lost all credibility but
this is the cost of
this kind of thing but fourth and
perhaps most obvious that we face is
bankruptcy uh you uh
we simply uh when you have spending a
half trillion dollars a year on the
military four hundred thousand four
hundred billion dollar defense budget
leaving aside iraq and afghanistan plus
at least another 20 billion uh in the
department of energy for atomic energy
it comes out about a half trillion
dollars a year we can't afford that
we're not funding it uh it is we're
going deeply into debt
uh
as uh herbert stein when he was a
republican chairman of the council of
economic advisers once put it things
that can't go on forever don't uh and
that's that's what's happening you just
simply i mean even if the american
public is willing to kiss off their
constitution uh the uh
the economic crisis is likely to catch
up with this anyway i've seen it
reported that uh despite the vast sums
that you mentioned the defense spending
at the moment is only about five percent
of gnp which is roughly what it was
during the reagan years hasn't gone up
that much it's actually it fluctuates
and i try to discuss it in some ways
that is there's been four great peaks of
defense spending one is right now uh but
generally it never goes below a a cold
war norm uh of
approximately 350 billion dollars a year
uh and
it is an argument question can we afford
this
level of expenditure we don't
manufacture much in america anymore we
are in our 25th month of recovery that
has produced almost no jobs it's
unprecedented in american economic
history uh we have
uh that is the new uh a group of 20 that
emerged at the uh world trade
organization uh meeting in uh in cancun
in the mexican resort town
uh last autumn uh which is opposing us
directly opposing our uh economic
policies for the rest of the world the
my
argument is that i don't think we can
just afford anything
that
the
one of the reasons i say this is because
precisely the precedent of what happened
to the soviet union the soviet union
collapsed for three basic reasons
because of
extreme ideological rigidity in their
domestic economic institutions making it
very hard to reform them this the
influence the power of stalinism uh even
though the many people in the leadership
were aware that it no longer made any
sense do we have that in america well
that's what enron
what the looting of pension funds what
the uh what martha stewart uh what uh uh
corruption in the mutual fund industry
uh the distrust of the new york stock
exchange that's what's all that's what
that's all about that we chose the same
thing the second thing that brought down
the soviet union was imperial
overstretch that is the they simply
couldn't continue to afford to meet us
everywhere on earth well what is
imperial overstretch i'd say 725
military bases in other people's
countries is about as good a definition
of of imperial overstretch as i could
think of and finally inability to reform
you see as a professor of international
relations we usually argue that no
empire ever gives up
voluntarily i can think of one exception
to it one case that came pretty close to
being an empire that gave up voluntarily
and that was the soviet union under
mikhail gorbachev he made the decision
that russia would be better off with
friendly relations with france and
germany than with these crummy east
european satellites that they'd kept
since uh
since 1945 and therefore he did not use
the red army against uh the protesters
who in november 1989
breached the berlin wall
but my point is
gorbachev was then stopped
cold by vested interests in the soviet
system he couldn't get around it now do
i think those vested interests exist in
the united states well to ask the
question is to answer it that is the
military-industrial complex that uh that
eisenhower uh warned us against the
huge i mean it is among the best ways to
get rich in america if you're a
politically
well-connected capitalist is in the arms
industry is in the service of the armed
forces uh the uh
of the 57 billion dollars just
appropriated for uh iraq a good third of
it is going into private hands to
maintain the uh
the armed forces in uh
in the field uh the private military
companies today do uh everything but
pull the trigger uh and uh
so that
uh
my argument is that it's
it's that is we have to be careful about
whether we can afford these things just
endlessly uh indefinitely i think
history suggests to us that we can't uh
it it reminds me once that uh
paul kennedy who wrote the important
book called the horizon decline of great
powers
he uh he once said as he was traveling
he's a professor at yale but an
englishman uh that
in traveling in america people used to
stand up and say to him professor
kennedy are you are you really saying
that the decline of the united states is
inevitable and he said no i'm not saying
that it's just simply i can't think of
the evidence for the opposite point of
view i mean
i can't think of what body of evidence
you care to offer a halfway intelligent
person that the united states goes on
forever like it was apollo or something
as you said in the prologue this is not
an optimistic
report uh there are a lot of questions
that i would like to ask but i'm sure
there are questions that you would like
to ask and let me give you an
opportunity to do that yes the lady with
the white black and white sweater
if you're correct the result of the end
of empire is it just we the united
states
ends up not having its
736 spaces around the world
or the secret ones and comes back to the
united states and
starts acting
like
a democratic
uh country
or
what
did everybody hear that question the uh
what happens
how how does it end
will it be a happy end i guess is is
really uh the question that's being
asked soft landing i think they often
say and things like uh
history would suggest to us that they
are not soft landings that they come out
rather badly uh the uh
that is what one would advocate this is
i mean senator byrd in his heart
obviously believes and says so that the
american public when finally fully
informed will reassert their
democratic uh control and re-establish
their republic revolt against the people
who have been cheating them i'm not at
all certain that that's true or they can
even possibly get the information to do
so given the control of the media and uh
and things like that uh that uh those of
us who are opposed to the war party well
we have on our side the internet uh the
uh
the nation magazine paul krugman a few
others uh but uh and that's one of the
things that makes the difference is that
we're reading things like antiwar.com
every morning it's a gazette of
information around the world on on where
these things uh uh sit but how
would it that is to say what we're
advocating is a return to constitutional
foreign policy a return to a
reinvigoration of the congress as
genuine representatives of the people
this might require an almost total
recasting of the states in this country
because of our electoral districts
simply are incoherent today uh the uh in
terms of of the population and the needs
of the uh of the country uh the uh it
would mean a reliance on uh the
demonstration effects of the united
states we used to hold ourselves up as a
model for the rest of the world it would
certainly mean a return to that line in
the declaration of independence that
says we have we seek the good respect of
the rest of mankind we don't seem to do
that any longer
and things like that that are common
knowledge and fairly sensible and that
certainly a reliance on trade as a form
of mutually beneficial activity not a
way to screw mexican farmers uh which is
what it is pretty much today
the uh
but how it actually will end i think is
uh
that history would tell us it's much
more likely to end in a severe crack up
uh as the
justice did for example in the case of
the soviet union uh as we uh uh waste
our resources in uh in the military
certainly one of the things that would
require is one of my criticisms of
of the democratic party at the present
time i appreciate howard dean's raising
of these issues because i do believe
that the constitution was the issue but
no democrat has yet even begun to set
out for us what we need in the way of
the military to
protect the country uh to that is
militarism is not the same thing as
national defense no one opposes national
defense militarism is
is the uh glorification of profiting
from the military as a way of life and
it is
i mean right now the amount of money
spent by the united states on foreign
affairs 93 of it is spent by the
pentagon seven percent by the state
department that's where our priorities
are at the present time it would mean an
altering of those priorities it would
mean
uh the kind of demobilization that the
united states experienced very rapidly
after world war ii a reorientation of
the society to civilian pursuits
do i think that's possible i i doubt it
i mean so often when questions like
yours get asked to me by somebody who
says well what do you think you should
we should do
uh my wife says you must say something
other than this but i have on one or two
occasions said uh
if you've got a little money ahead think
about a condo in vancouver
i mean
i
think about your escape route uh is is
what is what is
is my my most serious advice uh the uh
and and look around and see if you have
the ability of acquiring any other kind
of passport a second passport is
occasionally quite useful thing in this
world of of it i mean
greece is one of the most anti-american
countries on earth they remember the
greek kernels we put them in power
between 1967 and 1973 probably the most
odious regime created by either side in
the cold war if you're thinking of going
to the olympic games in greece brought
back to greece
this coming summer and you've got a
french passport or a brazilian passport
it would be just elementary prudence to
use it
they may not have the the stadiums ready
by the time the olympics are held yes up
in the back go ahead
these three secret faces we have in
israel what are they for do the
americans who are uniforms what are we
use them for the questions about the
secret bases allegedly in uh israel what
are they for and uh are the american
soldiers there dressed in uh in uniforms
we're not sure uh these have been
reported
uh but much where have they been
reported in things like the london
review of books with details i mean we
get
uh we get information on the secret
bases in england from a very
interest interesting woman i'd like to
offer her some credit here lindis percy
of the committee for nuclear disarmament
she spends her time breaking into
american military bases she is charged
to demonstrate what goes on there she is
then invariably charged with criminal
trespass and as she goes to court the
u.s embassy drops all charges because uh
to pursue the case gives her a chance to
say what she found she was last seen
brilliantly
nailing or attaching of an american flag
upside down to the gates of uh
buckingham palace during the visit of
the boy emperor uh this this uh
this this past autumn what's your what's
your evidence though for the bases in uh
israel journalists who know a good deal
about what these bases look like they're
undercover
for maintaining uh peace on the egyptian
border in the negev
but uh the entire uh flight uh
the aircraft off the uss eisenhower were
flown off into a base in in israel
they're widely discussed in haaretz in
uh in jerusalem uh the uh or actually
it's in the papers in tel aviv uh the uh
but that i don't know much more than
that uh except that they're there uh
that they are
uh included in our plans the global
security organization tries to track
them uh but every bit of information you
get is from
other than official sources
yes sir um
and the you know dynamic with the
military
you've got me thinking when you talk
about how we our people refuse to
implement any form of conservation and i
guess this is really a chicken and egg
kind of question
which is justifying which is the
military present their presence to to um
uh support our oil consumption or is it
really vice versa
well i don't think i heard that one yeah
i'm sorry
which military occupation are you
talking about
he says
that's the case or whether or not we're
using a massive consumption to justify
the extension of empire is i say okay
everybody
got that one go ahead
i think it's a perfectly good question
and it's a it's a thing you'd have to
argue i mean it would run one way or
i mean it could run both ways that
indeed our consumption of
of
fossil fuels turns into something called
our way of life and uh and if that's
what we that is our way of life then
that's what our army is supposed to
defend at the same time uh the uh
military uh often finds that it wishes
to control i mean resource diplomacy is
as old an issue in international
relations as one could find and they're
controlling a valuable resource my
reason for raising uh
the issue of conservation we know how to
deal with terrorist incidents
the
we have a great deal of experience in
this area and it's not mysterious you do
not use high-tech military to go in and
kick down doors and and and holler peace
and freedom uh in english to a group of
arabic speakers uh the uh uh that's what
the terrorists anticipate is a military
overreaction that will make the
situation worse and it's arguably worse
that is between
1993 and 2001 including 911 al-qaeda
carried out five major bombings
worldwide
since that time in two years down to and
including the suicide attacks in
istanbul against the hsbc bank and
against the british consulate they
successfully carried out 17. uh in the
the the cold hard slog long hard slog
memo of secretary rumsfeld last october
he said we don't have a a metric he
means measure we don't have a measure
for whether we're winning or losing uh
the war on terrorism we certainly do
have a measure we're losing it uh that
we've played directly into their hands
but i raised this to say the only way to
go about it is to separate
the activists from their passive
supporters so that they the passive
supporters will then supply you with
information on who the terrorists are so
they can be apprehended arrested and
brought to trial the only way you can
separate them from
these uh active supporters separate
their passive uh populations is by
responding to their
legitimate grievances by alteration of
your foreign policy i believe that after
9 11 had we instantaneously done three
things withdrawn our troops from saudi
arabia that never should have been put
there in 1991 anyway and which we did
take them out the moment we had defeated
uh baghdad
uh it would have made a difference that
we should have also recognized that as a
matter of national policy we in the
united states stand for the ultimate
security of israel but that the policies
of the sharon government against the
palestinians are actually made it
impossible to have us trusted in any
islamic country on earth and in fact are
adding very greatly to the long-range
dangers to israel i believe that we
should have stopped the three billion
dollars of pentagon money per annum to
israel
until they withdrew from
the occupied territories in the west
bank i mean israel is not a small
country it has the largest fleet of
s-16s on earth other than the united
states it is an atomic power
it is easily the most powerful country
in
in the middle east uh i believe this
would have made a difference and then
third had we
then begun to
eliminate the leverage of the oil
countries like saudi arabia and iraq and
iran on us by
freeing ourselves from the dependence on
on petroleum
for our
automotive industry
this would have
had added an element of credibility to
what we were doing i believe had we done
these three things al qaeda would be of
interest primarily to chiefs of police
today uh we and we would be well on our
way toward rounding them up the french
and the germans have already and the and
the spaniards have done a wonderful job
of rounding up these activists in
western europe already
over here yes sir
that is the point
where the supply of oil will no longer
meet the demand
and that the price will become
uncontrollable with devastating effects
on food production and many other things
if you have any comments on that
gentleman's asking what happens when we
run out of oil basically
when we run out of cheap oil
you're absolutely right it's not rocket
science to say that that's what's
happening it's why uh toyota is is
working day and night on a
post-petroleum automobile uh whereas we
are not uh the uh it is why we have to
face the fact that though iraq was
attractive to us because it has the
second largest oil reserves on earth
still the largest on earth are those in
saudi arabia and our policies there are
virtually asking for an anti-american
revolution against the house of fod
and i mean that is to say the thing that
has ruined our middle eastern policy
it was built on two pillars our
relations with saudi arabia our
relations with iran the iranian pillar
fell in 1979
when the shah was overthrown because of
our history of of interfering in
in iranian politics uh the uh we are now
worried that this could happen in saudi
arabia but as you just
made the case saudi arabia
has its reserves are so large that
you a country that uses as much oil as
we do can't do without it and they're
the only country on earth that can
produce uh petroleum at a relatively
cheap price and still uh make it
economical as distinct from exporting
oil from say the caspian basin where the
caspian sea is totally landlocked uh
it's so it's you've got
really difficult chores of getting it
out and taking it through places like
chechnya dagestan or or uh
kurdistan turkey are are places with
just wildly open to sabotage so that
yes of course i regard it as a
short-term and not very well thought
through
uh to think that you can perpetuate our
our extra elaborate use of fossil fuels
uh indefinitely also
in order to do that we had to simply
ignore the growing evidence of global
warming withdrawn from the international
efforts to control uh
uh greenhouse gases uh which has uh
again it's not just that this was a
mistake it also conveyed to the rest of
the world that the united states had
abandoned its
historic efforts which for which i think
we ought to be enormously proud since
world war ii to build an edifice of
international law
of the united nations of organizations
like the international criminal court
which we signed the original treaty uh
and then we have now denounced it uh the
uh that uh the kyoto protocol was not
perfect without question but we then
just announced it and walked away from
it the other industrial nations spent
their times trying to modify it in such
a way that it made it a little bit
easier on
the advanced industrial uh countries and
then have tried to put it into effect
it's
our
pulling out of that
conveys that we're simply no longer a
good citizen we're not cooperative and
i'm sorry to say there will be an awful
lot of people on the world around the
world who when the american empire goes
down they will feel as bad about it as
they did when the soviet empire went
down
i think we have time for just one more
question yes right here
from both sides of the island congress
and the media
putting his sins out there and having
him pay
is it possible that george bush will
come to the same kind of situation or
has the conglomeration of the media made
that kind of situation impossible
and for example would daniel ellsberg be
able to get the pentagon papers out
today
question is uh would given the fate of
richard nixon who was elected
overwhelmingly in the re-elected in 1972
only to resign shortly thereafter could
the same kind of thing happen to the
current president uh the only prophet
who was ever any good was cassandra
she was uh
she has a wonderful record uh
beware of greeks bearing gifts uh and
there was something in that horse uh
that uh
that you that you should pay attention
to i am obviously not as as
clear-sighted as as cassandra i don't
know the answer to that question uh but
i am
inclined to argue that the fate of
individuals is less important here than
the fate of of institutions
of uh a re-education of americans to
their democratic heritage
to the understanding of what it means
when
uh
our original founding fathers said that
the price of liberty is eternally
eternal vigilance this
during the 1990s when we were spending
our time trying to impeach a present
resident because of an alleged
love affair uh that should only event of
interest probably to his wife uh the uh
that uh we are beginning to
i mean what does worry me is the thought
that the views of a lot of people on 9
11 around the world the americans had it
coming
that we are
asking for it that we are we are
displaying hubris arrogance pride
nemesis
is the god event goddess of vengeance of
the retribution of
people who behave as we do i end my book
by saying i have the distinct feeling
that nemesis is waiting impatiently for
her meeting with us
we are going to leave it at that the
sorrows of empire chalmers johnson he'll
be signing books
outside thanks to the library foundation
and all of you for being here tonight
let me thank warren only too it's a
great pleasure to meet you
chalmers johnson is author of peasant
nationalism and communist power and blow
back the costs and con 9-0 if you oppose
the war and 202-585-3891
if you support the war and we're going
to have chalmers johnson with us in just
a few moments so you can start dialing
now if you have a question or comment
about the war for chalmers johnson who
is the author of blowback and the author
of the sorrows of empire
well we're just outside of haynes
auditorium in the quad area on the
campus of ucla this is where the ninth
annual la times festival of books is
happening and we are we'll tell you a
little bit about haynes haynes is the uh
was named for a political science
professor who taught here in 1925 to
1948 who was a specialist on the supreme
court he wrote about six volumes work on
the supreme court that's where we are
live today now we're out on the quad and
we're going to come over here and talk
to chalmers johnson a little bit about
the war
and uh would tell you also that our live
coverage is going to be continuing uh
for the rest of the afternoon
and mr johnson is joining us chalmers
johnson hello great to see you nice to
see you pleasure
in your book well first of all tell us
you've been listening to this panel in
your earpiece yes tell me what you
thought of it oh it was a good panel i'm
particularly impressed by the
willingness of people to discuss frankly
christian fascism
tell me about what your thoughts are on
what you call christian fascism well i
believe that
the issue right now is the constitution
the constitution separates church and
state uh the constitution is at risk as
i try to argue in uh in my book the
sorrows of empire
and i believe that there's no area which
is a greater risk than in this
uh having the president claim as he did
to uh on
60 minutes a week ago that
he doesn't listen to his own father he
listens to a higher father and points
his finger up in the air that's very
serious why why is it serious ah he's
invoking authority that he's not
supposed to invoke it is illegal under
our constitution where did you get well
first of all where did you get the title
for this book your sorrows of empire
well it comes from the sorrows of young
verterre i happen to be an opera buff
and
so i know it quite well but yet to fit
perfectly
there are some people talking about we
will soon be an empire of sorrow
you started actually you became very
well known with your previous book
blowback
what was it like to have a successful
book like that well it wasn't successful
until 9 11. it was published in early
2000 more or less ignored in this
country very well received in europe uh
and in japan
but on 9 11 it uh simply took off became
a bestseller it went through eight
printings in about two months uh and as
my publisher said it's a hell of a way
to sell books but it's better to sell
them than not sell them again our phone
lines are open if you would like to join
us 202
585-3890 if you oppose the war
202-585-3891 if you support the war ah
what is your california connection what
do you mean california connection what
you well we're here in california for
the la book festival and i live here why
do you live here oh i've lived here all
my life i taught at berkeley for 26
years done another five years at uc san
diego in the new school of international
relations i then retired created my own
research institute i live in cardiff
which is in northern san diego county
sort of a surfers paradise i don't surf
very much but it's a lovely place to
live uh and
i as i say i'm now beyond the university
i no longer have to pretend that my
colleagues were smart well thank you for
coming out it's a little warm today but
let's take some phone calls it is warm
but it's lovely to be here
houston texas your first step hello
houston
hi yes uh
the question really relates to
how
does an individual
take help to take back our country with
big huge corporate
uh
interests in politics how can an
individual other than violence which
seems to be the only way to go
how can they really take back
what are some real good steps for an
individual to take
that are not
innocuous steps to take back our country
to give it to the people not the
corporation when johnson uh or uh
abraham lincoln made it
uh created a central a very strong
central government okay you got my dress
yeah
i got it my uh obviously my approach to
that question was to write a book i'm
not trying to please some
academic bean counting dean i don't need
tenure i'm 72 years old uh my purpose is
to try to mobilize inattentive citizens
to information that i know they need and
i know they don't have i mean very
seriously the subtitle militarism
secrecy and the end of the republic but
to make the point of what can an
individual citizen do i would simply
remind you that slightly more than a
year ago 10 million people around the
world protested against the war against
george bush and for democracy the
largest demonstrations in british
history 2 million people in london 400
000 in new york city a million each in
berlin in madrid i mentioned madrid in
uh in rome that's the sort of thing that
we ought to be doing it's the only thing
that's going to make a difference right
now is direct democracy much as has
recently happened in the spanish
elections i'm afraid the political
system does not offer the uh the ability
i'm afraid to save the republic right
now next call is from berkeley
california hello berkeley
i think mr i think berkeley is gone
this is part of the american empire
project what is that that's a series of
books that henry holt is publishing
metropolitan imprinted henry holt the
first one is noam chomsky's new book
this is the second there will be several
books coming up on
the military petroleum complex
on
numerous other issues concerned here we
probably are going to put out an
anti-imperialism reader
and so far it's doing very very well i
noticed it on
one of the websites for amazon that's a
big bookstore in washington d.c that
lists uh the leading bestsellers in
politics at this point but first are of
course uh uh bob woodward and and uh uh
uh richard clark
barcelos of empire is third i was very
very pleased to see that what's your
what's your reaction to mr woodward's
book so far oh i think uh he's got
another another watergate on his hands
but he almost wondered if he set him up
by writing the software book at first
which allowed him then to believe that
he was a safe uh uh
house trained uh reporter and so then he
came on and gave him some more uh uh
interviews i believe that that as a
result of his book uh colin powell will
now go into history having invented the
pottery barn uh uh theory namely you
break it you own it we sure as hell have
broken it in in iraq and to our regret
we own it
lubbock texas go ahead
hello
hello um
go ahead hello
mr johnson how do you do hi it's fine uh
i would i'd just like to ask do you see
any end to this
this war of ours we've gotten into you
see any way we can just get out of it
i think there is the greatest limitation
on the war party right now is we're
running out of uh out of troops to
maintain the empire uh that 40 of the
troops in iraq right now are uh national
guard and reserves when they became
weekend warriors they did not expect to
uh to be
serving in iraq uh it's uh the real
question is to see whether or not
remember service in the armed forces
today is not an obligation of
citizenship it has not been since 1973
and that under that it's a career choice
people join the armed forces for their
own individual reasons uh they often are
recruited by being told they won't be
shot at now they're being shot at quite
vigorously and we are waiting to see
whether they re-up if they don't then we
might have to go to the draft or the
other alternative that i discuss in the
book you might have to go to a sepoy
strategy that is start trying to hire
foreigners to do your fighting for you
what would be better drafter your
proposal in my view the draft would be
the best in the sense that the draft
would recreate a genuine citizen army
that is then people serving in the armed
forces would know what they were doing
there it was not a career choice it's an
obligation of citizenship they become
much more concerned about whether their
officers are lying to them and things of
that sort that is in we
i was teaching at berkeley in the late
60s early 70s when we discovered that we
were instilling in young americans the
most corrosive of all uh emotions namely
guilt they knew that so long as they
were in the university they were not
going to be called up for the
working-class war um
once we did discover that the the draft
was being inequitably applied uh in our
i believe false wisdom we chose to
abolish it rather than apply it
equitably i think if we applied it
equitably you would have a much greater
much greater strength of democracy and a
check on our now almost unbridled
militarism nebraska republican senator
chuck hagel has made proposed a another
national discussion on the draft do you
plan to be a part of that i'd certainly
be glad to if i'm invited i find that
people in
on capitol hill usually seem able to
control their enthusiasm for me but
next call us from kansas city hello
kansas city you're on with chalmers
johnson yeah i just wanted to make a
comment about the last statement i just
re-uh returned home from iraq
and uh
they were talking about how we're going
to put in the draft i don't know any
any one of the joes that i was over with
in combat would not sign the dotted line
today
to go back over there
so
i don't know i don't i don't think that
they're going to have to do the draft
because i think there's enough support
of
support in the u.s military among the
men to go back over there
so
we're going to find out whether you're
right or not uh i for one doubt that i
believe that no one wishes to be killed
in a lost cause that uh what we're doing
in iraq is basically
kicking down front doors running in on
private homes pointing assault rifles at
women and children and hollering freedom
and democracy in a language nobody can
understand this is creating more
terrorists the truth matter is we're
going to lose in iraq there's no doubt
about that
i believe that once that becomes
apparent to the troops we will begin to
see a more independent stance as it
stands right now what i do believe we
need are a few more thinking people in
the ranks not people that are there just
because they're trying to escape from
one or another dead end in our society
now
we're there so do we come home
we're there these conventional wisdoms
we can neither leave nor can we stay if
we stay the uh the casualties rise so
high that they become politically
unacceptable if we leave we get civil
war
unfortunately however we broke it we
never should have been there that the
the only way now for us to save any kind
of face is to come up with some face
saving device via the un or something of
that sort and get out we better do it
earlier rather than the way it ended in
vietnam who in your opinion is the best
person talking about this issue today
meaning in the administration is there
anybody in the administration that you
support there's no one in the
administration making any sense at all
on the subject probably the most
important patriot in public life today
is senator robert byrd from west
virginia he's i think
delivering some of the most
extraordinary
erudite uh speeches to an empty senate
chamber by an 84 year old man who knows
the constitution well he's our cato i
i believe he will just die a natural
death you may remember cato ended up
with his head in both hands nailed to
the forum wall by the young octavian
the
the roman republic's version of our boy
emperor from crawford
chalmers johnson is the president of the
japan policy reaches research institute
professor emeritus at the university of
california san diego and the author of
this book we'll show you the cover again
the sorrows of empire militarism secrecy
and the end of the republic he's also
the author of the previous book blowback
mr johnson thanks so much for taking
some time out from your time here at the
la book fair and speaking to our great i
admire what c-span does you're one of
the important elements in our democracy
thank you very nice to see you bye we're
going to get up here and come on over
because we're going to get ready for the
next panel discussion which is going to
be beginning just a few minutes live
back in hane
generation kill author evan wright and
mccoy's marines author john coopen were
embedded with american military units in
iraq beginning in 2003
chalmers johnson writes about american
militarism in the sorrows of empire
next they joined moderator bill press
and two former marines who fought in
iraq this is an hour ten minutes
uh
good afternoon it is sort of in congress
on this beautiful sunny day in palm
springs that we sit here to talk about
war
uh when you think about it war is a
horrible human activity but there is
something noble about it
you know nothing
rallies a nation
like a war
nothing stirs the imagination
like a war
nothing fills libraries
like wars
in fact i think if you took all the
books about the civil war and world war
one world war ii and vietnam and now
iraq out of the libraries the shelves
would be almost empty there'd be nothing
but books about love left you know this
guy stuck with books about love
uh and we think about
those of us of a certain generation the
great books about
world war ii
um cornelius ryan the longest day
books still come at ken lafollette and
all those great spy novels either needle
books still coming out about world war
ii recently bob dole's book one
soldier's story just came out think
about the great books about
vietnam stanley carnos great book on
vietnam david haberstam the best and the
brightest graham green
uh the quiet american
and you think of many more that i didn't
mention
and now we're just starting to see the
first books coming out about the war in
iraq
about the war in afghanistan and about
the war on terror
the war in iraq of course is part of or
is not part of the war on terror
depending on how you voted for president
the last time
your opinion on that matter
so um today we're going to meet three
authors who have written about
and two participants who've written
about or participated in
american wars today
two of these books are about the war in
iraq and one of these books is about
america's ongoing perpetual state of war
the militarization of america which
charles chambers says chaumbus johnson
i'm sorry says is draining our country
and threatens to destroy our country
uh so we're going to start with iraq uh
talked to evan wright and john koopman
charles gave
the headline of their books i love the
total titles uh as he told you um evan
who as a reporter and write for the
rolling stone was embedded with the
first reconnaissance marine battalion
from the time they rolled across the
border from kuwait into iraq all the way
into baghdad and through the fall of
baghdad
his book is called generation kill
devil dogs ice man captain america and
the new face of american war
uh john coopman
reporter for the san francisco chronicle
embedded with the third marine battalion
that's right john right also from the
very beginning of the war all the way
through the fall of baghdad the third
marine battalion are the ones that
pulled down the statue of saddam hussein
which we all watched live on television
and the title of john's book is mccoy's
marines
dark side to baghdad
so we'll start with iraq then we'll get
to chalmers for the bigger picture but
evan let me start with you and ask you
you know the war in iraq and then we're
going to talk to our two marines to the
war in iraq it's the most televised war
in history
you were there
you're part of it what do americans
not know about the war in iraq that they
ought to know
i think that americans i'm sorry
okay
i think that americans
really don't know the true identities of
of the men and women that are that are
in iraq and that are fighting the war
there uh we get most of our news
coverage today through television and
which gives great images
um little sound bites and no depth and
and both koopman and i had the the
luxury of being
print reporters and and i had the luxury
of writing for a magazine
which meant that that that i could embed
with this unit and spend a lot of time
with them and
what i found coming back from the war
in iraq
is that
most americans
didn't have a sense of
of the the actual people that were
fighting and that that were uh pulling
the triggers on the weapons television
imagery focuses on
the sexy images of air of high-tech
airplanes the we all were sort of
hypnotized by the first gulf war where
we saw the those those precision guided
munitions sailing in through the windows
of of buildings and
seemingly as we were told blowing up the
right people
if there is such a thing
what i think the american public still
doesn't have a strong sense of is the
incredible
uh
pressure that's put on on the guys that
are pulling the triggers
of of weapons and killing people
at you know 50 meters away
getting shot at in in in the moral
dilemmas of of
being a small american unit
in a crowded iraqi city surrounded by
civilians and
women in black and children and having
little points of light flashing in the
distance and those points representing
bullets coming in at you trying to kill
you
and and these guys have to decide
how do i eliminate those points of light
that are trying to kill me which are the
muzzle flashes of enemy weapons and not
kill all these
women and children that are here in our
midst and how do i live with myself and
i i don't think the american public
to this day has a strong sense of what
that is truly like
thanks evan
[Applause]
let me ask you that that to address that
same question um you came home to a
country very divided about this war in
iraq that you covered for the san
francisco chronicle i know we talked
last night
some of your pieces written for the
chronicle were not accepted
so well by the population of san
francisco that reads the chronicle so
what do you want people to know what
what did you see there that you want
people to know about this war we don't
already know
[Music]
well what i tell people mostly um and
this has to do nowadays with the
with the current situation in iraq which
is that which is that
we we don't know uh uh the the way that
reporting happens
is so distinct from the actual invasion
you know when evan and i were there uh
it was it was a different time and as
embedded reporters we were right up
there with uh
on the front lines or right up there
with the guys who were who were fighting
and you could you could
the story was about the war was about
the invasion now the story is about the
occupation
and uh i was there i spent two months
there last summer and um
correct i went i returned to iraq after
so i was there for the invasion came
back home thinking well i'm done with
that i can shower again this is great
but but a year later i kept reading i
was watching the news and reading
stories and i didn't have a good sense
of what was going on in iraq uh so i
stupidly volunteered to go back for
another tour and see what was going on
it's just just a very harsh time it was
it was different it was very distinct
from the invasion in that uh there was
no longer this sense of okay i'm going
to embed i'm going to be with the unit
i'm going to tell the story of of the of
the fighting menu it was it was
different situation because you could no
longer
you couldn't really embed so much
because nobody was doing the kind of
work that an embedded reporter would
want to do you know evan
went with the first recon battalion and
said oh well you know these guys are
going to be the you know the right in
the fight and i found a unit that was
you know these were hard charging
infantry battalion and we figured
they're going to fight the war that's
what you want nowadays it's like if you
went to to iraq today and said i want to
go see what's going on
i mean you know it's really hard to find
somebody some unit did you say i'm going
to bed with these people and i'm going
to go find fighting because it's like
spread out all over the place and it's
very it's very boring most of the time i
mean yeah there's car bombings and
roadside bombs
i got hit by roadside bomb last summer
that was i mean
but that was purely happenstance i was
out with people who were looking for
those things but uh it's just
you don't get a good sense of what's
going on there because none of us can
report out of iraq all you can do is
sort of uh
do the the stories uh that you know the
car bombings the suicide bombings
whatever but you don't really get a good
sense of what's happening with the
people and the troops
before we get to mike and rudy i want to
ask you and then evan get you to pick up
so you were an embedded reporter you're
both embedded reporters
doesn't an embedded reporter risk
becoming nothing but a cheerleader for
the unit that he's with or he or she is
with
um
in in in your role i mean how how can
you possibly be with them every day
and and not fall in love with them
well in my case it was easy because uh
it was easy to not fall in love with
them
because
well i spent four years in the marines
myself
i was in boot camp like two weeks out of
high school and and quite honestly uh i
couldn't wait to get out you know uh
i am not well i mean i enjoyed my time
my feeling was i
i'll serve my country i'll figure out
what i'm going to do with my life and
then i'll move on which not say that i
don't respect the marine corps but
you know i i don't like taking orders
and i don't like wearing a uniform every
day and all those kinds of things so
when i got back when i was embedded i
sort of i understood what everybody was
doing and why they were doing it but it
held no awe for me personally i mean i'm
not saying that i'm like this great
wonderful objective reporter but i
didn't walk around personally thinking
oh wow you know you carry a gun uh
you're gonna go kill people you must be
really something special it's like
that's just another grunt to me you know
uh and i don't mean that in a bad way i
just mean that uh it was easier for me
because of my experience but
the
the embedding process is a good one it's
it's a very useful one the the issue is
not the process the issue is who does it
i think you know there were reporters
who did a very good job very objective
and then there were reporters who did
who did
have all
yeah evan i thought that this is the
smartest thing that rumsfelt probably
tory clark did was to come up with this
idea of embedded reporters because it i
think it it gave for the most part the
coverage of the war very positive so did
you feel you were being in effect used
by donald rumsfeld um
well i i think that it's the job of
every reporter to to get as close to
your subjects as possible and
people that were suspicious of the
embedding process because it put
reporters in close proximity with the
people they were writing about
uh were wrong about that it's good to be
close to your subjects the the problem
with the embedding process
is the way it was used by the media i
think the media was much more
self-censoring than than the pentagon
would would ever have been and
i i had the benefit and a few people had
the benefit of i didn't have to file
stories every day so
i didn't have to when i came back and
wrote i didn't have to worry that oh i'm
going to offend the guy that's sitting
next to me and has a machine gun and and
which is a real concern that reporters
had and not just not just that you know
the way reporters work is is there's two
ways you get information you get it from
the ground you get it from the grunts
the guys that are right there
but you also get the information from
above you need to seek out
power and who has the power in in a
military unit reporters are very
competitive and one of the things that a
lot of daily reporters function under is
getting what is the story of the day
because it's almost like there's going
to be one story in the day and your
your news agency doesn't want to miss
that one story
if there's a bombing somewhere or
casualties or something you want to be
on that story and if you're out there
embedded with a particular unit
if you want you're competitive with
other reporters in your agency you want
to make sure that your story pertains to
that story of the day well the first
thing you need to do as a reporter in
that situation is find what is the story
of the day you want to stay close to the
people in power the officers the public
affairs officials within the military so
what a lot of reporters got into was the
mentality of i don't want to offend
the people that are going to give me
information which are the people on top
so they they were doing puff pieces in
my opinion and a lot of the tv people
were doing this because of the
technology they were more dependent on
the cooperation of the military so it
wasn't like the military was censoring
um and if they did censor it wouldn't be
overt anyway but the reporters were
basically in my opinion some of them
were kissing a lot of ass in order to to
to be on the story and that's that's my
long-winded assessment of the embedding
process
uh
i don't think it was long-winded at all
and i think it was refreshingly candid
thank you um well we're going to find
out how good a job evan wright did
because our next two
panelists were
members of the first recon battalion
they saw evan up close and
they put up with him for all those weeks
that he was over there uh rudy sergeant
rudy reyes and sergey sergeant mike
saucier uh before questions to you guys
i just have to say
that i
oppose the war in iraq
but i deeply deeply appreciate what you
have done for us and for our country i
salute you
proud of you and thank you for your
service
[Applause]
and i hope you believe that all
americans feel that way um so rudy let
me start with you um what were you
fighting for in iraq what did you think
you were fighting for in iraq
okay uh there's a couple things
the number one thing i was fighting for
the first time uh also remember i went
in with the same crew that i went to
afghanistan the same people i want the
same high-level recon marines i went to
afghanistan and trained with for years
developing standard operating procedures
uh doing the hardest most difficult
training
diving shooting
you name it these guys are my peer group
my uh my family
i go to afghanistan we're the first
marines in afghanistan where
uh you know delta's not even afghanistan
you know what i mean we're kicking ass
in afghanistan so there's a lot of pride
and uh and we're the first guys there
and
um we think we're doing the right thing
i was in australia when september 11th
went down and i was on the ship my
buddies were out drinking i had been
drinking the night before so i was tired
and i was hungover so i stayed indoor
stayed into the ship and uh and lifted
some weights and tried to clear my head
and i saw that september 11th go down
and i thought that we were watching a
movie first the siege i thought we were
watching the siege the film with denzel
washington then i thought that this was
israel or somewhere
but uh
so we go to afghanistan and we think
we're fighting terrorism and and uh you
know we hooked up with johnny walker
lind out there uh we had control of that
guy we were in kandahar and uh
we were doing a good job i thought we
were doing the right thing we come back
i think i'm done with warfare because
warfare doesn't happen in our country
all the time at least overtly um at
least overtly and
i go back into training
i re-enlist and then the word on the
street is that we're going iraq so i'm
going to iraq with my best friends the
toughest people the coolest people
so we're happy evan comes on the scene
when we're in kuwait and he's like man
these guys are having the greatest time
in the [ __ ] what's going on you know
what i mean how could these guys have so
much fun and 130 degrees doing pull-ups
you know
and um because that's just the kind of
people we were so we go to we're waiting
to go to iraq remember we were getting
those briefs mike every day getting
briefs about when uh when our
infrastructure here political
infrastructure was gonna drop the hammer
and we were going to go in we were doing
maneuvers we were shooting we were
patrolling and we were waiting and we
were waiting and we were waiting
and when uh we finally had to go
also they did tell us they had weapons
mass destruction they did say that
and uh so we thought we were doing the
right thing
we went in and once somebody starts
shooting at you you don't care about
nothing you know the politics you care
about fighting and winning
and i was having fun you know
having a lot of fun at first
you were told there were weapons of mass
destruction rudy mentioned 911. we were
all told it was about 911 is about
weapons of mass destruction it wasn't
about 911 and there weren't any weapons
of mass
destruction were you sent under false
pretenses um
well at the time i was 20 years old and
to me it was all about going out and
having a great time so when we
uh then being quite honest but when we
uh
when we're first told about this and
we're getting briefs
we were told yes there was there was
some weapons of mass destruction there
and
we were told at some point in time that
we might possibly also come into contact
with some type of nuclear biological
chemical weapon and
during our prep for going over there we
had received mop suits our chem are
basically our chemical suits
we had got gas masks and we had prepared
for all kinds of the situations um when
we got over there
we found
well we didn't find weapons of mass
destruction but we continuously found
insurgents or
different different groups of people
willing to fight us and we ended up
spending quite uh quite a lot of our
time there um
definitely uh battling out with people
that were opposing what we believed at
the time to be uh
you know what we thought was right for
that country at the time
and
kind of covering what rudy was
covering as far as why we were fighting
there
to me it didn't matter if they had
weapons of mass destruction
it didn't matter so much if the overall
politics of the situation was right or
wrong
it was rudy was there my buddies were
there evan was there and i was told to
get on a gun and make sure they don't
die and so that's why i was fighting
over there
thank you
now
one of my real heroes is sitting to my
left chalmers johnson i read first met
him when i read blowback a few years ago
um
not to put words in your mouth but a
book that basically said that our
aggressive and
foreign policy and our cockiness and
foreign policy was going to uh
come back and haunt us
and make enemies
bingo
and chalmers himself has blown back now
with another book called the sorrows of
empire
the entire title the sorrows of empire
militarism secrecy and the end of the
republic
and one of the things that i think ties
this panel together is i
heard last night and again today
that the members of the first recon
battalion in iraq
were reading sorrows of empire by
chalmers johnson when they were in iraq
that's how much impact this man has had
on the thinking about war and what we're
up to in this country so chalmers uh
thank you for your great wisdom and let
me ask you what you've heard here
uh
is iraq the next american colony
oh it is already that no no doubt about
that i think what i
heard here though was the misuse of
military force
uh it uh that is
in the week after 9 11 the president
said in congress
quoting jesus christ uh you're either
with me or against me it's a line he
didn't know that vi lenin also loved to
quote uh for the communist party of the
soviet union uh but the interesting
thing about it is three years later
there's a great many more people against
us now than there were then that is the
entire islamic world from that's 20
of the world's population
i think it was a misuse of military
force i have no doubt that these people
did well
i'm not a chicken hawk i admire general
zinni's uh uh term for people with no
experience of either barracks life or of
war i was in the navy in the korean war
but it
it is simply not worked that is the the
war was fought under false auspices uh
the country it was lied to our troops
have been
misused i have no doubt that you very
quickly found resistance i would have
hoped you would
that is to say if i come from san diego
if you had a
division of turkish troops in downtown
san diego for the last
50 years as you've had a division of
american troops in in okinawa for the
last 60 years
on a saturday morning men my age i'm
almost 74 would be saying to their sons
or grandsons
sun tonight for the honor of our family
for the honor of our country i want you
to go out and kill a turk
if you get killed your mother and i will
understand we'll be sorry but that's
what you ought to be doing and that's
what's happening in iraq that is we sent
our army in to steal their resources
and they have resisted us
i was going to say charmers you don't
have to hold back
on this panel here you know it's just
sir the new book is even worse but you
can you can sort of let it hang out but
uh somewhat facetiously look
there was the romans had their chance
the british had their chance
this is the american empire
why
do you call your book the sorrows of
empire why not the joy of empire the
thrill of empire the aphrodisiac of
empire i mean empires go down fairly
fast uh
the uh i mean in
in my lifetime i've seen the collapse of
the nazi empire the imperial japanese
empire the british french dutch
portuguese the soviet empire took three
years 1989 to 91.
we're going in the same route we have
exactly the same things afflict our
society today that afflicted uh
gorbachev's uh soviet union the uh and
we're not seeking reform it could happen
blow back the original book was written
before 9 11. uh i'm as you know from my
biography i
formerly was a consultant to the office
of national estimates of the central
intelligence agency its blowback is the
cia term was first used in the
after-action report just declassified in
the year 2000 on our first overthrow of
a foreign government you should
understand that's the government of
mozadec uh the prime minister of iran in
1953 you should understand what blowback
means it doesn't just mean retaliation
it means retaliation for things done by
the united states abroad that have been
kept totally secret from the american
public so they have no way of putting it
in context of seeing causative effect
when the retaliation comes blowback was
a brilliant example of retaliation and
osama bin laden our former ally has been
utterly candid with us about what was
going on it wasn't a clash of
civilizations or anything else he says
in in so many words that i am
gaining revenge for
uh your policies supportive ariel sharon
in in israel and uh and for the way you
abandon us in afghanistan after the
soviet union withdrew
perfectly plausible perfectly
understandable kind of action our
support for the islamic mujahideen in
the 1980s in afghanistan was the largest
clandestine war we ever carried out uh
and uh we're paying enormous prices for
it now so that you say enjoy empire no
call it the sorrows of empire you may
call it soon the empire of sorrows
so
all right all right so rudy
sitting in the sands of iraq
what did you get out of this book and
why were you passing it around to your
fellow marines
well if you read evan's book you'll find
out i'm a little bit of a troublemaker
um
i ended up get
thanks
i ended up getting a little bit in
trouble because i always try too hard
and push too hard and want to be better
than the guys before me and want the
guys that are going to support me being
better than i was and sometimes well
sometimes just going along is what the
american way is all about
and it even happens in elite special
forces unit just going along is what
it's about and uh
when i figured out that i was
that i was going to be court-martialed
but then as soon as we were going back
to iraq i'm useful again and i'm uh top
banana team leader i'm this i'm that i
got the sniper team i got this going on
i'm the number one guy when we go over
there to fight i'm like wow man i was
looking at brig time just a couple
months ago and um and it's all politics
and so i went over there and the place
is completely different than the first
war we fought
and we were naive before we didn't know
what we were doing really we listened to
what people told us and uh when
someone's shooting at you you don't
think about politics i'm telling you you
don't think about none of that all you
think about is killing them before they
kill you and uh trying to
not let all these uh corpses and
freaking people you shoot in the face
you know bother you that's what you
think about doing you think about okay i
gotta drive past this guy that i just
waxed you know what i mean and then we
come back i'm at home for a little bit
and then we go right into a training
cycle right into
getting ready to shoot and fight again
and uh
i go back there and it's completely
different the army's running the show
it's all occupation no one's actually
fighting terrorists
in other words it's a huge freaking
smoke screen
no one's actually doing a job
they're just
hiding in their shell i mean man that's
not what i joined the marine corps to do
and then there you go you know
pretty scary uh mike
so mike you you you come
you're there
genuinely doing
believing you're doing what you should
be doing and and supporting your buddies
and they're supporting you and you come
home and you find a country that's very
very divided if not
the majority of america certainly the
majority of americans don't think we
should have gone there in the first
place how does it make you feel
um
well first off to me
my family they when i came back it
wasn't about right or wrong for me they
were supporting me everyone i knew
personally they were saying hey i don't
necessarily support the war i support
you or i support the war and i support
you
there just happens to be to me
personally there's a handful of people
out there
that uh they go
they go out of their way to
um
ensure that they that you know that they
don't appreciate the war that's going on
um i i've been uh i've been told that
you know we were that we were the best
thing that uh that happened over there
by iraqis um i've come back and uh i
believe uh it was two weekends ago my
friend tony sparrow who was also in the
book was told that he is nothing but a
gladiator slave for the president so i
guess it's kind of uh it's so divided
and
unfortunately
there's just not enough information for
people to see if you could see
the the little kids that are running out
in the street towards us saying thank
you thank you i have something to eat
tonight
that that makes a difference to me it
means that we're doing something
but on the other hand unfortunately
there's times where
we act
you know sometimes accidentally someone
gets killed a wife a daughter stuff like
that and um
you know that that's the type of thing
that i i don't i can't stand i i really
can't take that and um i just wish that
back here people we could see the truth
100 percent of what's going on over
there and i think everybody would come
together and just agree that um
we're doing we're there now we're doing
what we can
to to make the place better
but if we could avoid this all in the
first place in some form or another
there's there has to be another way
and if i could say real quick uh brother
i could say remember you asked earlier
you said uh what does the media not get
and get across to our americans what's
going on over there the media can never
get across the heat
the media can never get across the filth
and the media can never get across the
pestilence and
and the sickness
and those are some serious serious
factors of warfare and americans will
never know that unless they're over
there
i want to
get back get john cooper back in here
john you mentioned you went back last
summer and we'll come back to you evan
he went back last summer
and we're there for the occupation
um
are these guys trained to be occupying
forces
how long how's the occupation going do
you believe in how long we're going to
be there
uh you know first off can i just do
something real quick i'd like to
introduce a friend of mine who was
actually there with me matt baker who
was the executive officer for the
battalion i was with
i haven't seen matt since
since they came back but uh he and i
talked beforehand and he said he's going
to come by and i just wanted to oh hi
matt
um
no uh in in fact i i think that's a huge
problem uh the fact is that right now
you know the united states military is
just
when you see it up close it's this
amazing offensive
fighting machine
uh the m1 tank is just the king of the
battlefield uh artillery air power uh
you know guys with rifles in their hands
will will just slice through anything
that stands in their way i mean nothing
nothing gets in the way it's just it's
just total devastation um and so when
you see it in the in in the form of the
invasion it's it's it's it's all
inspiring uh the occupation is a
completely different situation because
very few people are trained to do that
you know you're you're trained to get
out there and be aggressive and go hunt
your your enemy and kill him that's the
whole point kill your enemy well now who
is the enemy well he's he's a you know
somebody who might plant a roadside bomb
or somebody who might snipe at you or
whatever but what the military hat is
having to do now is
is work with local people try to help
them out uh so you have artillery
commanders
now being
asked to go out and and serve
put together local uh governing councils
like a city council it's like well you
know you know one day they're literally
saying
uh you know
pull the rope and fire the gun the next
minute they're having to say well sir
you need to have five people on your
council and you need to figure out how
to do sewage treatment uh you have
about the only people doing their jobs
over there are truck drivers and mps
everybody else is a you're you're you're
uh the rifleman the uh you know radio
operators um i mean everybody who has a
job in the military normally you know
designed for offensive operations is
doing something else and and it's a
problem because because now it's it's
it's on the job training first time you
get there and somebody says okay get in
a convoy you get it you get a you get a
convoy uh briefing and it's all about
okay you know what are you and the guy
said they're telling you what they're
going to do if you get killed well
wounded how they're going to medevac you
and you're like it's like well gee gee
sergeant that's all really good but i'm
supposed to go kill people and now you
want me to drive along this road looking
for
for dead dogs you know it's pretty tough
evan i know you were not there during
the occupation but what you saw and you
saw the great job that these guys did
so now
is the answer just to pull out and come
home
i couldn't answer that question whether
it's to pull out and go home i just
wanted to make a little correction in
your setup and your introduction of them
wanted to make clear i don't think we
know necessarily whether they're both
for or against the war whether they
think it was a mistake or not and one
thing i wanted to say when people talk
about the troops there's a tendency if
you're against the war to sort of
portray them as as victims of of
something and i don't think they're
victims and i think that one thing we
should consider is that
they they were really looking forward to
combat and even after they were shot at
they they were still excited for it and
in a general sense it's good that we
have people like this who are defending
our country now what we do with them in
in the name of defense is the big
question here um and the question you
asked me i've completely forgotten so
i'll pass it back to you
well then i'll ask you another one which
relates to that i i agree we need people
like rudy and mike and we need people
who are trained to do it who are good at
it or better than anybody else on the
goddamn planet
but don't we need political leaders who
will only send them into action
when there's a just cause
[Applause]
i i wouldn't just blame the political
leaders i i would blame the public and
the media uh and the public for allowing
the kind of media that we have because
the media is
is
is ratings
we have a ratings driven media and i
think that all americans perhaps uh to
an extent were seduced by the the power
of of our military and and the idea of
let's let's use it now because we have
this fantastic military we're the sole
superpower and
i think that the american public
didn't understand how how serious it is
to undertake a war
especially the second time after
afghanistan and we went into iraq so
i think that's the issue here i think
it's it's a it's an uninformed public i
would you know i wouldn't just blame the
political leaders i think to an extent
you get the leadership you deserve
[Applause]
like evan was saying he he's saying that
a lot of the political decisions he
believes are based off of what society
is saying and screaming at that moment
and right now everyone is screaming hey
let's get out of there let's stop this
two months after 9 11 happened
if you would have taken a poll and said
hey sure we've gone over there and
everybody would have been on the
bandwagon saying yes let's do it let's
do it let's do it and
i'm sorry i'm sorry you if you would i
can't if you come to the base you cut
you come to around people in maybe not
california area but
you know what the majority of people
they say hey let's let's do something
about it and um you know now now it's a
little bit different me i'm i'm neutral
either way i got sent i went if it
wouldn't have been sent i don't care but
the politics of it is people say what
they want when it's convenient and it's
not every single time there's no
concrete
so chalmers put this can you put this in
context for us a little bit i mean
you talk about
the military's militarization this
country continuing
uh of which iraq is you know maybe the
latest wave 725 bases is it now we have
what does that mean for this country
where are we going
that 725 american military bases located
in 130 different countries that's
imperialism
uh that's that might that's not a number
i dreamed up it's from the base
structure report of the pentagon which
is an annual survey of the property we
own abroad
my study the sorrows of empire is
concerned above all with the ones they
didn't mention the ones in britain that
are all disguised as royal air force
bases the bases in the balkans the 14
bases in iraq the rest of them that are
covered up for one reason or another but
i think what's being said here
what i'm trying to stress
is an institutional issue
the military is close to being out of
control the two greatest warnings ever
given to us by our presidents was george
washington's farewell address and dwight
eisenhower's farewell address washington
famously warned against standing armies
that's as distinct i'm not opposed to
national defense as distinct from armies
raised because of an emergency that is
these guys all volunteered
it is not an obligation of servant of
citizenship to serve in the armed forces
today that ended in 1973
when i went in the navy back in 1953
it was then understood that you had to
serve in the armed forces it also was a
check on militarism it meant we were
there and we knew why we were there and
we were curious about whether our
officers were lying to us whether the
war made sense whether anybody was doing
thing right whether there was a strategy
to what was going on and everybody else
i mean the vietnam war was ended by
vietnam veterans i mean they're the ones
who actually finally revolted against it
and
and they they had to be withdrawn before
they started really literally
slaughtering their officers but that the
the issue here is the pentagon has grown
too large it's uh we have two
extremely powerful centers of government
on the south bank of the potomac river
uh both that is the pentagon and the
central intelligence agency even if you
were an honest congressman and you want
to do oversight on them you must
understand you can't everything the
pentagon the
cia does is secret 40 of the defense
budget is secret the cia is a private
army in the hands of the president
totally unaccountable
every president since harry truman once
they came into office and told you have
this army and it's yours and nobody
nobody in congress nobody comes close to
it none of them ever resisted using it
this is what's happening to that is to
say washington felt it would ultimately
blow up our balance of power between the
legislative judicial executive branches
of government
that standing armies
bring power into the imperial presidency
eisenhower famously invented the phrase
military industrial complex he we know
from his papers he intended to say
military industrial congressional
complex he was warned off on that
but do you want to go back and read his
farewell statement it is as strident
remarks ever made by an american
political leader who also happened to
have been commander-in-chief in europe
during during world war ii he warns
stridently
about the dangers of unwarranted power
of things being out of control
uh and he's and he says no president has
ever existed in a government like the
one i exist in today there is no there's
no previous president with that
experience of a huge military industrial
complex
today it is not at all clear to me that
any president of either party could
control the military industrial complex
or the pentagon or the cia even if they
wanted to
whoa
by the way we just uh about 10 more
minutes we're going to questions from
the audience as you can see there's so
much to talk about all we can do is sort
of skim the surface here and touch on
some areas that i'm sure will spark a
lot of questions from the audience so
we'll be coming to you shortly but i i
have to
continue this conversation if we can
about
the standing army
as opposed to a volunteer i mean
volunteer army standing up standing army
made of volunteers as opposed to
a military obligation on behalf of all
citizens
um evan
i'll keep putting you on the spot but i
want to ask you first if you think
that's good for the country and then
let's get the opinion of two of our good
volunteers so whether they think they
should have had some people in there who
were drafted to serve alongside of you
i'll just tell a brief anecdote i went
to afghanistan prior to iraq and right
before i went to afghanistan i was
involved in a civil lawsuit and i was
meeting with the opposing side's
attorney who was a woman
from the malibu area of southern
california famously liberal part of town
and i said i was going to afghanistan
okay i said i was going to afghanistan
to write about the troops there and she
said what are you going to write about
the troops and i said well i'll write
about what they think of the war what
their lives are like who they are what
their opinions are and she looked at me
and she said why would anyone care about
that that sounds really dull because
there's morons in the military and
this is
you know this is a very common attitude
i think with respect to the the
larger points that chalmers is making
it would be really beneficial to have a
draft because everyone would become a
potential stakeholder in in the foreign
policy and they're not right now and our
president is always talking about right
now the ownership society uh with
respect to social security in those
programs why not make the military an
ownership society because right now we
have professionals who it's easy to pay
and send them to go off and do this i
think a draft would would significantly
change
our posture as a country with respect to
war i think michael saucier was right i
think right after 9-1-1 the public
broadly supported they gave the
president a blank check to to engage in
any war i think if there had there been
a draft at the time
i i think the public would have thought
twice about at least the second war in
iraq
most military people i know are opposed
to the draft and for a variety of
reasons one of them i think being that
if there's a draft they know that the
public will be on their backs much more
than they are right now
number one reason for the draft
so that's that's my piece on this how
about it guys okay uh first of all
another uh another kudos to mr chalmers
johnson because unlike a lot of people
that are they call them liberal or left
or whatever i really don't like
judgment terms like that chalmers
johnson knows what the hell he's talking
about
you see
and so
so if anyone out there has a problem
with the war or government um the first
thing you ought to do is know what the
hell you're talking about
and uh and i don't think a lot of people
do and probably not a lot of y'all have
spent much time overseas in the third
world so you know really you know your
opinions don't hold any weight with me
uh that's the first thing i'd like to
say number two is
the draft is fantastic
because then all of your kids have to go
to war with us and then maybe people
will get serious about when and where
you send us off the war because you know
in war people die
and the last the last thing the last
thing is this
special forces always has to be
volunteer always because you know what
not everybody can cut it and we need
guys to volunteer for this job
yes
i agree with rudy's point as far as i i
would like to see the draft as far as
seeing people have a stake in the uh and
what's going on you know you have some
kid that says hey i'm not involved i
don't care and you know it's then it's
you know guys like myself and rudy who
are there doing the work uh the only
thing that i would have to say i would
disagree with the draft is because i
don't want somebody next to me who
doesn't want to play you know if if i'm
in there if i'm shooting he better be
next to me shooting because i can't do
it by myself
and uh if if they can find a way
to uh maybe even make
two-year enlistments and say hey you
either go to college or you do two years
in the military you know that at least
give some options and maybe maybe
educate some more kids in this country
also
[Applause]
john get your comment here and then i'll
come back to chalmers to wrap up here
oh i i just couldn't agree more uh uh i
don't um i differ somewhat uh from evan
in that i think that the the most the
military members military that i've
talked to about the draft
it's not some well i suppose it's
somewhat about having the public on your
back but mostly it's it's for the same
thing mike said which is which is just
about proficiency in what you're doing
nobody wants a bunch of guys who don't
want to be there um but but what i what
i see happening in this country is a
role it's a real class warfare situation
um i'm working a story right now about
about recruiting and
especially in the bay area you know it's
like you have all these people who
see it's not enough for them to be
against the war they're against
recruiting they're getting somebody
anybody joining the military and this
kind of bugs me on a personal level um
just because i'm thinking well
it's all well and good if you're in palo
alto california and you don't want your
your kid to join the military right
ahead and go to stanford
wouldn't we all but but you know there's
some kid in nebraska where i grew up who
doesn't have those same opportunities i
mean why aren't you there you should be
opposing opposing the military
recruiting those schools because
otherwise it's just like all right if
you've got money and if you're from a a
nice area you don't have to join the
military and if you grow up in in in
east texas someplace and you don't have
that many opportunities what are you
going to do well you're going to we're
going to wear a uniform and and that's
the fundamental problem in our society i
believe
let me just say
just a word or two about this though i
think what we're trying to stress here
is that
service in the armed forces today is a
career choice
a career choice often made by people
facing one or another dead end in this
society that's why
african americans in the army are twice
as well represented as they are in this
in the uh in the society at whole fifty
percent of the women in the armed forces
are national minorities you'll remember
the case of jessica lynch uh
notoriously uh shot up at nasaria in the
assault on baghdad
when the press asked her why did she
join the army she said i couldn't get a
job at walmart in palestine west
virginia i joined the army to get out of
my hometown she also said when they
recruited me they said i'm i'm a a
supply clerk you'll never be shot at
well as of course it turns out her
colleagues were shot and killed she uh
barely survived it but
this is the is i mean i find it a
terrible misuse of the military to try
and evoke
the old citizen armies of world war ii
vietnam and and korea i'm irritated as
hell by a president who will only speak
to the public he's now given 45 speeches
in front of uniformed troops at fort
hood or somewhere like that well i was a
naval officer and i know god damn well
if the president came around i would say
beforehand to to the truth you guys clap
like hell anybody who sits on his hands
i'll take care of you i mean
john your next uh charles uh is in the
micro is in the audience he's got the
microphone and so you're next john wants
to make a quick comment before we get
our questions from the audience
a very brief thing and that is that
while i understand what you're saying
and i agree with it i got to tell you
though that 90 percent of the
marines soldiers sailors i ever met in
iraq today even under fire love the
president i mean they don't all agree
with the the the war but nobody would
have to tell them to clap if george bush
showed up today that's just a fact in
life we have a problem in that case
[Applause]
all right charles all right any any
questions at all in the audience uh the
first question i have well the question
i have is
pipe hi how are you good i respect all
of your all of your work and uh and your
time in the military uh rudy and michael
um if you have seen the movie 911
fahrenheit 911 by michael moore what do
you think of it specifically
um
all right is that question addressed to
uh any particular member you don't know
them i don't want to know what i think
about that movie but yeah uh
you know did you see it i i i didn't see
it but i could say something about it
all right uh let's start with someone
yeah
some of the i never saw a 911. part of
the reason is some of the footage was
was filmed by a guy in baghdad named
george giddos who's an australian
correspondent and war artist and and he
i sat down with him and i said what do
you think of 911 because your footage is
in it and he said it's it's bs the way
my footage was used was improper it was
edited to in in bad ways this doesn't i
i don't necessarily disagree with
michael moore but i don't think it's
good documentary uh reportage
all right all opinions welcome john uh
has seen the movie
yeah i saw not only that but it was out
last summer when i was in iraq and it
was probably the most popular
behind spider-man is probably the most
popular movie in uh in among among the
troops uh everybody wanted to see it but
for the sake but you know
opinions are mixed and in my opinion was
the same way you know it's it's it's
entertainment but uh the the only thing
i you know the only thing i that i got
from it was well first off i i didn't i
didn't appreciate the the you know the
slanting but you sort of understand
where michael moore is coming from i
thought you know he has a he does have
an affection for for the troops i think
uh despite what some of you saw in some
of that but that was the one place where
i would re i would watch it i would say
yeah you know he's got a point
um the rest of it was was not very well
done
i liked it i uh uh that i saw it the day
after it was uh opened and it's the
first time i've been to a movie in
in 70 years that i was there at 10 a.m
uh but uh but
the things that that i think are
important about it is to
bring back to this country satire the
willingness to spear our political
leaders to remember that this is
supposed to be a democracy not an empire
not a place where
for the president to go and speak in
mainz germany they clear every single
human being out of downtown you people
don't live in washington you've never
seen the the entourage of the vice
president driving around town it's about
32 cars men's with machine guns hanging
out the back of their of their suvs
that's not
i mean
thomas jefferson missed lunch on the day
he was inaugurated and went back to his
rooming house and and waited for dinner
uh it's it's that's a different i
thought the best scene in the film
though was michael moore in his hometown
in flint michigan dealing with these
three black boys who are being told by
the local director of employment there
are no jobs here and they walk outside
and here are two spit and polish
well-dressed dress blue marines saying
babies you're for us
all right guys it was uh in iraq i know
you've both seen it
were you offended by it
all right i'm a troublemaker so of
course i wanted to watch it and it was
contraband at the time yeah if you're
found with it man you know you're going
to be you're going to be busted up
pretty good
of course uh
i loved it because it was funny and it
was uh uh attack
on the administration which is great
because because we need to be able to to
do that because we're supposed to be a
free country
you know what i mean
did did that keep me from going out that
day on a mission and if uh somebody came
at me with weapons from did that keep me
from killing them hell no of course i
was still gonna kill that guy but
um
but you gotta be able to look at
yourself your country your government
and your military in that manner in a
critical manner
and uh
if not it'll be unchecked also
some of the stuff like uh like evan was
saying that it was used out of context
and and of course it was painting a
picture but there was nothing out of
context that marine be in downtown
washington and none of those people's
kids signing up for the military now
that's the truth right there
uh i saw the uh fahrenheit 911 and then
just to uh offset it i watched the
fahrenheit 911 movie and
i was just blown away by
how how much both sides just wanted to
uh skew the opinion just enough to make
it sound like they were right and there
was there were so many facts presented
and just enough
of opinions put in there to make that a
viewers movie and i would just love to
see if somebody come out with the
honest-to-god truth because i think that
would strike home with everyone
oh hey real quick real quick though when
we go to pow school that's how they
indoctrinate us too they'll mix a bunch
of truth with a little bit of untruth
and that's how they get you so keep that
in mind
uh yes sir yes i i
want to address my question to our two
marine buddies over here
i know for a fact that i was in a third
world country in 19 in 1984 and i know
how many people it took me to kill for
me to become numb to the fact of killing
people i'd like to know what your guys's
number is
well
i wouldn't say that i ever uh
became numb to the fact of killing
people uh it became easier after the
first one i mean it was something
it was like the taboo in this society is
to kill someone and
i was sent over to do it so after the
first one it became easier but it never
became a point where i was like hey this
is you know
this is
water on the bridge it was to me it's
still important that uh there's people
over there every day that are being
killed and
needlessly in my opinion in some cases
there's kids there's women there are
little children you know even if
somebody came to america and they said
hey
this is the way we want it we would all
fight against it too but
that's just the way it is over there and
i and i can't
condone my actions but i'm just i'm not
going to score myself either for doing
what i did either
i'm a scout sniper as well as many other
mosses i've been in the recon community
for quite a long time so
i've been indoctrinated and
programs not brainwashed programmed to
be an efficient killer
and uh to do it well to do it silently
and uh
and to be able to do it far far away
from home and that's my job and that's
what
that's what i've learned to do
but
i never liked it
but it is my job and i'm with the best
guys in the world my best friends and
i'll be damned if i pull a shot
and my guys end up taking a shot so uh
no you're never numb to it i mean we
could spend this whole damn uh this
whole damn panel on about uh you know
bad dreams and uh short tempers and bar
fights and
problems with sleeping and things like
that so we're not even going to get into
that
so no
anybody that thinks that it is
easy is wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
got it thank you yes
uh my question is pretty simple and that
is do you think we are heading towards
civil war in this country as we continue
to polarize uh
are you talking about in this country
the united states of america or iraq
in this country chalmers
i don't think so because of what
happened on november second last year
the presidential election until that
time it was possible for the american
public to argue that they did not elect
the president he did not win a majority
vote he was a he was appointed by the
supreme court uh on november 2nd
three and a half million more people
voted for the president than for his
opponent this was and the president says
a referendum on my policies today the
united states public has approved
preemptive war that's what the japanese
did to us in december 1941
we have approved torturing uh
captives in our military prisons this is
going to be a worse scandal than milai
ever thought of being
and and the effect on the armed forces
once the full details come out will be
enormous these were not just a few bad
apples in a uh
one wing of abu grave prison in the
middle of the night it went all the way
up to a lieutenant general
who ordered this kind of activity and
was approved by the president and the
man who is today the attorney general
uh this kind of thing is uh is is what
we're
might ultimately divide us but no i
don't think it's civil war i think that
the american public is easily led by the
combination of media
a
an imperial presidency and a totally
worthless congress
[Applause]
amen
we have our next question here charles i
want to point out that we've had all men
so far so on i want to suggest that we
see some get some of the latest
questions next yes sir you're next i'm
sorry evan do you want to quickly have a
moment
i'm sorry
well short-term memory goes first
yes
all right i would like to start with a
very brief and short comment that is i
don't i don't hold the belief that that
war is really a noble act that human
animal has it so that's that's it and
and there's no just cause for any war
anywhere in this planet so with that
said and i'm wondering since we speak
enough that our marines are here they're
speaking of there was no weapon of mass
destruction and we would lie to and
everything else and and we are occupying
one country that we're not supposed to
be there and occupying it
so are we given a just cause for iraqis
to come over here and revenge what we
have done to them
and i i don't know i have i have
dilemmas with it now i would like to ask
mr johnson if it's possible to elaborate
on what would happen in a society if
there's we really don't have a a
military or a war uh budget you know
what do we do with that with the budget
that the surplus that it's left what do
we do with the rest of the country
it's a compound question um anyone
someone speak to the first part which is
john okay
well i'd just like to make one comment
and and something that um hasn't come up
too much here and that is that uh
you know iraq
the all the politics of the invasion uh
weapons of mass destruction the 911 uh
context are one thing but uh
you you can talk about the the reasons
for for invasion but
what gets lost in a lot of this
conversation sometimes is the common
iraqi
uh if you go to iraq today if you
gathered up 100 iraqis you would find a
huge disparity among them as to whether
they
want what they have now now i'm not
saying that at all as a matter of
suggesting that that was right wrong or
indifferent but
uh silver lining if you will or or you
know what what good comes out of it you
know uh i i could i could gather you up
a thousand iraqis today who would say
thank god saddam hussein is not here
anymore this is not an inconsequential
thing people were tortured murdered
killed families were obliterated
i mean it was a horrible horrible
repressive regime now now if the united
states if we go back in time and
somebody would say well listen there's
this horrible dictator in iraq and and
you know we'd like to start a war to get
rid of him
fine you know we can all sit around here
and discuss whether whether we want to
start a war for that reason but but that
is a fact people were
i i met thousands of people not
thousands i met many many people who who
iraqis who were just
they hugged me on the street
because i was an american and i
represented their their salvation that
way and that's not to be discounted you
cannot look at that just simply say well
you know we don't care about that
because there were no weapons of mass
destruction
we didn't go to war in order to liberate
or bring democracy to iraq
that in fact
our record of bringing democracy to any
country through the use of military
force is among the most abominable on
earth we have supported more right-wing
military dictators around the world than
anybody ever thought of but
it was something you said that bothered
me most namely our extremely
professional highly trained troops are
today
uh carrying out
civil government in a conquered society
and it's on the job training on the job
training if you read the 911 report did
you read that there in this country in
2003 six people
six people all told graduated from one
of our universities in the arabic
language now these are people who are
gone been sent to iraq to these guys to
kick down
the front doors of people's homes come
roaring in with an assault rifle and
point it at at uh old women and children
and holler free freedom and democracy in
a language nobody understands
this is
not
because of course that is to say
armenians define themselves today by
their hatred of
of turks
uh there are you see riots in china
right now over the remembrance of
atrocities committed by
japan during world war ii iraqis until
the end of time will hate the united
states
i know you're next let's get a quick
comment here and then uh thank you
i was just gonna say that that there's
probably 50 to 75 countries
on the planet that that we could invade
and try to fix their their governments
and make their people better and there
would be people on the streets in those
countries that might welcome us but is
it our job and can we actually afford to
do this around the world and and i don't
think we can and i think look back at
the british empire by some analysis
analysis the british empire was a
money-losing proposition from the start
and that's what actually broke it up in
the end
mike's got stuff to say yeah
uh just uh just comment on what you're
saying chalmers about how we had only
six people graduate speaking that
language um when we went over there
initially we were doing exactly what you
said we went in and we kicked in doors
and we decided that hey we needed to
search these people homes
just
for the military aspect we have we have
uh gotten a little bit more wise to uh
what's going on over there and we have
hired arabic linguists to work for us i
personally worked with the shawani
special forces and we did turn it around
over there
we would take uh uh interpreters with us
and instead of kicking on the doors we
would knock on those doors and say hey
we're just here to find out what's
really going on and that led to finding
more weapons bombs rpgs uh than could
possibly have been found kicking in
doors and i just i i definitely agree
with you as far as we need to start
using a little bit better tactics and
use our heads to to accomplish mission
over there versus just just pure brute
force
my question is for chalmers johnson um
the the information i have i hope is
accurate but like defense is one of the
us's largest exports
and
[Music]
on the other side of it
what does it do to the u.s economy to
stay at war
the question was what about foreign
military sales i think you mean
indeed the united states is the world's
largest exporter of munitions without
question uh it is also not a matter of
capitalism or free enterprise it's done
in the pentagon and it normally goes to
only one customer that is so that it's
it's not as though we're dealing with
competition here it is a
a dangerous and provocative business to
arm the rest of the world similarly
uh given the number of troops and we
have overseas today well over a half
million uniformed soldiers spies
teachers contractors in our bases around
the world
foreigners who encounter americans they
don't any longer encounter state
department people they don't encounter
civilians in our government they don't
encounter people who want to trade with
them if they encounter an american it
may be pleasant or unpleasant but
normally it is a heavily armed 18 to 24
year old young man which conveys
indelibly to the rest of the world the
united states prefers to deal with you
through armed force
okay yes
uh the economic impact quickly on uh of
this whole militarization was our second
part of our question yes economic impact
well again the military industrial
complex is extremely clever that is on a
uh a big project like the b-2 bomber
they put a piece of that in every state
so that if any congressman ever crazily
got the idea that we didn't need a new
weapon of mass destruction he can lose
his job i mean
the state of washington has two utterly
charming women liberal senators they're
smart they're well informed they're
capable
say boeing to them and they turn into
bloodlusting fascist hyenas before your
eyes
that i mean that is the uh
the two mother hands of the of the
defense facilities subcommittee of the
senate armed services committee r k
bailey hutchinson of texas and dianne
feinstein of california they do anything
in their power to keep the bases open
it is one of the few things we still
manufacture and that's weapons of all
kinds of destruction
yes ma'am this question is for evan
why should the american people be
involved with this war because they're
still filling up their suvs
their sugar is not rationed butter isn't
rationed nobody's selling war bonds
nobody's involved with this war if you
think of the second world war everybody
was involved everybody knew that there
was a war on
this war
what's going on nobody knows
yeah why the question is why would the
american public care about this war
because they're not involved and i think
we've all made this point
they're not they've not been asked to
make any sacrifices and i think we've
made this point earlier it's one reason
i think we we all agreed a draft of some
sort might be a good idea to keep the
american public engaged because right
now the the politicians really don't
have a lot of accountability to sending
the military into harm's way
and you know um we were talking
to a friend earlier about john mccain's
message
in the year 2000 when he was running and
john mccain said you know believe in
something bigger than yourself
um
maybe the first one says john f kennedy
to really i think excite the american
people's imagination about thinking uh
big like that and taking on a bigger
cause and making one's own contribution
uh and and and and being willing to
sacrifice for the greater good we don't
hear that today we don't hear today from
from anyone i think it's a message that
is sadly sadly lacking in our american
politics and and i remember after 9 11
when people were as you said if there'd
been a draft after 9 11 people would
would have been lining up if there had
been a blood bank after i know people
would have been and there were in some
cities people had been lining up if you
would ask them to go sweep the sidewalks
people would have been lining up and
george bush said go shopping
you know uh and that was about it so
um anyhow i have to tell you this has
been a great exciting panel for me i
hope for you thank the panel for me and
thanks to all of you
thank you guys mike rudy
okay folks thank you very much
once again john coopman thomas johnson
bill press evan wright rudy reyes and
michael associate
for more information on the palm springs
book festival visit their website at
psbookfast.com
[Music]
this week on q a our guest is chalmers
johnson
author of the sorrows of empire
militarism secrecy and the end of the
republic
chalmers johnson when you uh wrote the
last line of the sorrows of empire you
said this
failing such a reform nemesis
the goddess of retribution and vengeance
the punisher of pride in hubris
waits impatiently for her meeting with
us yes i get a sense you might even be
writing your next book name
nemesis the third book is done and it's
called nemesis uh the subtitle is the
last days of the american republic uh
it's to say i don't see the way out any
longer uh that uh
the congress or that is a separation of
powers is clearly broken down
the president has achieved virtually
anything he might have wanted to do in
that area i don't think the political
system will save us
the military could conceivably take over
they have threatened this but i don't
think so for
reasons that i think are pretty obvious
above all the fact that no enlisted only
enlisted men have been convicted in the
in the prison torture scandals none of
the officers the result is that within
the armed forces today enlisted men are
extremely sensitive to illegal orders
uh saying you're going to take the wrap
for it not us
and there's no more illegal order than
to take over congress
uh so that the the officers i just don't
think believe the enlisted men would
follow their orders today
so my wife keeps saying to me come up
with something optimistic and i come up
with bankruptcy it's uh
that looks like might be the thing that
will bring the republic to an end
you know that there are people watching
right now that say that guy's a wacko
i mean that's the extreme of it but it's
like the conspiracy theorist and all
that where did you start having this
conversation in say 1985 and i said to
you four years from now the soviet union
will disappear you'd have thought that's
not really a reliable analyst uh well
it's gone it's disappeared it's russia
today is a much smaller place than the
soviet union was empires go very very
rapidly and we're getting extremely
overextended really very serious thin
eyes that's reported this is not
terribly novel with me right now a lot
of people know this understand it and
are worried about the trend of events
what does it mean to you that you live
right here in the 50th district of
california the home of duke cunningham
well this is the crookedest congressman
we've ever had who is now in prison for
over eight years for uh for bribery uh
he was a lot dumber than we thought he
was i mean that you'd have thought
uh that that he could have become a
lobbyist and stayed out of prison
but
i wrote a piece in the la times
well before this happened arguing that
my congressman was was bought and paid
for by the military-industrial complex
and it was easy to simply see what he'd
reported to the federal election
commissions and where his money came
from and it wasn't within the 50th
district it was
uh
lockheed martin and above all mzm
corporation the uh the the the one that
where his the guy who he was being
paying him off in order to get defense
contracts uh it's extremely serious when
um
the institution that that the authors of
the constitution
presumed to be the heart of our
government the uh the place where
initiatives came from
is today you just want to ask what's
happened to congress where is it gone
it's not i mean one could talk endlessly
about the uh the enthusiasm of bush and
cheney for greater powers in the in the
imperial presidency but you what we
don't understand is how did congress
just disappear how did it cease to
function anymore at all that it's uh and
it has the smell of the roman senate
as we come up on the last days why does
this happen in your opinion what's
what's the start of all this militarism
primarily that is to say well it's
imperialism which
as its inescapable accompaniment is
militarism uh and that this begins to
invoke the earliest warnings we have
about threats to republican government
after all george washington's farewell
address still read in congress each
session
warns against the greatest threat to
liberty is standing armies and it's the
particular threat to
republican liberty he meant by this that
it would destroy
the separation of powers on which the
structure was was set up it would
move power toward the president move it
away from congress and the courts
that seems to me today obvious then of
course then
the equally famous warning by dwight
eisenhower as he left office in 1961
where he invented the phrase
military-industrial complex
and it's worth reading because it's so
strident this was not a diplomatic
remark at all by an outgoing president
it's he he warns in the harshest
possible terms
of what's likely to befall us
from uh spending as much as we do
on
on military affairs and
we can talk about that too how much we
spend but it's i think this is the
combination it's the same sort of thing
that happened to the roman republic
which one mentions only because the
roman republic was so much a model for
uh
for madison and the other authors of the
constitution in ideas of how to this was
the first functioning democratic
republic that we know of
we used and it took many ideas from them
and what happened to them they rather
thoughtlessly acquired themselves an
empire
which then required
huge standing armies instead of the
citizen armies that had prevailed in the
early days of the republic
uh and uh
and there and it it overwhelmed their
government uh leading then finally two
populist military figures of which of
course julius caesar is the is the model
uh and and led to his assassination uh
in the senate but then you get on to
more ruthless figures young octavian
who decides to make himself a god
augustus caesar
how many years did you spend in the
military
two it was back i was i was a student at
the university of california then just
finishing up and i belong to the air
reserve in the navy my
it was always in the navy my father had
been in the navy my cousins have been in
the navy or sort of
kids do that and this is back in 1951
you get you do your service in the navy
um
i didn't get activated but i went into a
program they had to
get a commission uh once you uh once you
finish your degree
and uh
i look through i mean i i was i was sent
to a ship without a name the lst 883
and i remember thinking as my fellow
freshly minted ensigns were going off to
aircraft carriers in the mediterranean
things of this sort
an old chief petty officer who was one
of our teachers said johnson you luck
through i mean
on an aircraft carrier you'd just be a
an errand boy for a commander you're
going to a ship with only six officers
you'll qualify very rapidly you'll
be at sea all the time and
for a young person it was an enormous
experience
what'd you think of the military
i didn't even terribly think much about
it and if nothing more it was again also
a different time
uh service in the military was an
obligation of citizenship
uh that you
the shortest was the army and the
dirtiest uh the navy you got showers
food served
more comfortably a little bit longer uh
the uh but that i just took it as a fact
of life in those days uh oh i argued
terribly with the captain uh he was a
conservative uh mustang that is an ex
enlisted man who'd
been promoted into uh
into an officer uh over uh the cold war
over
uh he disliked the fact that i
subscribed to the old reporter magazine
and was always talking about the china
lobby
seems like ages ago did you were you
political then
i suppose i was in the sense of
all university of california students
were political that i was concerned
about the way the world was going
concerned about our role in it certainly
uh but um
not political in the way this book or
blog is
and
you taught at the university of
california berkeley and at the time you
were how long were you there by the way
26 years teaching what teaching chinese
and japanese politics
but you were at some point supportive of
the vietnam war
that's true uh it and i've
i've talked about this uh in the various
books i was wrong on vietnam i i in
retrospect as i said i knew too much
about communism
which is what i was a specialist in i
was chairman of the center for chinese
studies at this time
but i wasn't
specialist on people like george bundy
or
robert mcnamara who were they well that
is to say that
president kennedy's uh national security
adviser uh then the secretary of defense
uh under lyndon johnson uh people who
who ran the vietnam war and i was
i made a mistake a classic mistake i
believed i had argued strongly in print
uh after my one and only visit to saigon
in 1962 this was a civil war and we
shouldn't get involved in it but i then
took an erroneous view that you still
here today
having gotten involved this is a war we
shouldn't lose
well no it that was an error uh and uh
i was also irritated at the time no
doubt about it by
the student demonstrations they struck
me as
uh pampered little brats who didn't
really know what they were doing i was
very proud of the university of
california
i thought they were damaging the
university at the time
uh and so why
i guess there was another issue that
when we talk about the vietnam war one
seems to think that this is the only
issue out there it was a period of
enormous change in america
and uh at this time i was
very much caught up with uh racial
integration in america i had many
students at the black panther party
who were students of mine at the
university
uh that being the case lyndon johnson
became a kind of hero
because of the
great society
the civil rights act things of this sort
and we attended
not to pay as much attention to what he
was doing in
vietnam as i should have and was wrong
when did you change your mind on vietnam
oh after i changed my mind generally and
that came with
something truly unusual namely the
collapse of the soviet union in 1991. i
uh i regarded the soviet union as a
menace i still do i did i believe that
it was something that had to be
and i when i was a specialist on the
subject i traveled extensively in in the
soviet union in 1978 at the height of
brezhnev's era things of this sort
but when
the whole raison d'etre of the cold war
ended that is they'd collapsed they'd
imploded they'd disappeared
i was truly shocked by the american
government's reaction
instantaneously we set out to find a
replacement enemy
china
drugs terrorism whatever
to keep the military-industrial complex
working
to maintain the huge i mean we're
talking about 737
that's
pentagon's count american military bases
look located around the world at the
present time
i was shocked by this i
it led me as a professor of
international relations to begin to ask
was the cold war just to cover for
something deeper for an american
imperial project probably to replace the
british empire that went back to world
war ii uh and i strongly suspect that is
the case
that uh
uh
and particularly in east asia where i
worked it looked uh
very much like we were on the wrong side
of issues of national liberation in in
china in vietnam in southeast asia one
thing after another i guess then the
other thing that led me really to to
shift my views i mean indeed
people have said over the years well
you're being inconsistent my answer on
that is a is a famous crack by john
maynard keynes when he was accused of
being inconsistent he said
well when i get new information i change
my position what sir do you do with new
information
and it would
the new information i got was the
remarkable american reaction to the
collapse of the soviet union there was
no peace dividend there was no moving
back into
the united states
then also i've spent most of my life
studying japan working on issues
concerned with japan and northeast asia
but i'd never been in okinawa
until 1996
the governor there a retired professor
oda masahide
had invited me to come down after a very
serious incident in 1995 when two
marines and a sailor
abducted beat and raped a 12-year-old
girl it set off the worst demonstrations
against the united states
since the security treaty had been
signed
i had never been to okinawa like many
others it's a it's a japanese version of
puerto rico it's a it's a territory that
is discriminated against that was
acquired in the late 19th century by the
japanese empire
it has 38 american military bases
on an island smaller than kauai in the
hawaiian islands
with living cheek by jowl with a million
300 000 okinawans
i was uh i
took up mr ota's offer visited okinawa
and was uh simply appalled by what i saw
the signs of the raj of which we'd been
there since the battle of okinawa in
1945.
um
it was obvious i mean these troops
reminded me of then the soviet troops
that were in east germany and didn't
want to leave they were living better
in east germany than they would back in
russia after the wall came down
well
our people were living better than they
would in
in oceanside california next door to
camp pendleton
uh that led me to start looking at bases
i thought at first
good cold warrior it's a had been
um
this is just exceptional
the press doesn't get down here it's off
the beaten track
it's people have forgotten about it it's
a vestige of world war ii
as i began to study our bases around the
world our military empire i discovered
no i'm sorry to say it's all too typical
you said 737
military bases around the world that's
the pentagon's count
do you trust that no
why
well i just know it isn't true i mean
they don't there's a lot of bases they
don't include for various political
reasons i mean they don't include
adidas air base and qatar well that was
the headquarters for our assault on iraq
but they don't do so in order to not
embarrass the emir of qatar they don't
include any of the espionage bases we
have a wonderful
old arrangement with britain so that
most of our
bases in britain of which are quite a
few are disguised as royal air force
bases there aren't any americans on them
things of this or so if you if you've
got the full count it would be hard to
do i doubt that anybody knows the really
full count i doubt mr rumsfeld does but
he'd probably go up over a thousand what
if all of a sudden uh and i know you
this won't happen but all of a sudden
you were named and agreed to be named
secretary of defense
and you were responsible for
homeland security i know that's not no
and you're responsible for the terrorism
war and all that what would you do
well obviously you would have to agree
with the president who would be the one
who appointed me but right off i think
we would take out of
a defense budget defense spending is
running three quarters of a trillion
dollars a year which we aren't paying
for we're putting it on the tab it's
being financed by savers in china and
japan who ship capital to america the
rate of two or three billion dollars a
day
right off we'd start cutting that budget
and cutting out things that reflect
military keynesianism that is
it's not stuff we want not stuff we need
it's worthless but it's a way of
maintaining jobs in america like what
we spent well over 500
trillion dollars on nuclear weapons
being throughout the cold war that's an
unbelievable amount of money for
something you never ever used it's about
as good a waste of time as as john
maynard keynes's idea of making jobs by
uh putting money in down old mine shafts
and then paying people to dig it out
again uh it's um but right now it would
be oh
the virginia-class nuclear submarines uh
the f-22 raptor uh
the uh the the uh how much is the f-22
going to cost us well it
it's a it's somewhere around 200 billion
dollars i mean if you if you go through
the whole contract we keep cutting the
contract back because lockheed martin
keeps raising the price on the thing
daily so we're going to get fewer and
fewer of them but the the amounts are
huge i would stop cold the
the
ballistic missile defense program i mean
this is this is really nothing more than
scarecrows stuck in the ground in alaska
they can't hit anything and they know
they can't hit anything it's fake the
the science just isn't developed that
far and moreover you would only work
against a truly incompetent country like
north korea but again let's well that's
really one of the first things to do
well what i want to ask though is the
president says serenity says well
we can afford as a country three four
five percent of gdp i mean and why take
a chance of not having these things i
need to protect the american people
i don't think that's true
uh i think we need to spend the money in
other ways the largest
uh element in our budget of
discretionary spending goes for national
security we are spending today
more
on nationals on national defense
so-called uh really on war
than all the other nations on earth
combined that's an astonishing figure
it's also amazing to see
that perhaps 20 000 insurgents in iraq
have fought to a standstill 130 000 of
the most highly trained heavily equipped
troops on earth and that's what has
happened and that's why they're
withdrawing often in their secure bases
where very few of them ever leave that
base uh it's um
the thing is a fake moreover
what bothers me is the degree to which
militarism has penetrated into our
society it's perfectly logical for the
secretary of defense to want to close
bases domestically that we no longer
need
but it's amazing every time he does that
to see every community with a close base
erupt
and demand that their senator keep our
base open keep those jobs there
the state of washington is represented
by two very decent pleasant liberal
senators
say boeing to them and before your very
eyes they will turn into bloodlusting
fascist hyenas doing anything in their
power to keep
boeing in business because it's a big
business in seattle
uh
that's the kind of i mean uh
when i mentioned that randy duke
cunningham the congressman who's now in
federal prison here in the 50th district
uh had uh
was was uh
spent using his influence basically for
military contracts i got a couple of
letters from people in los angeles
saying
well i wish we had that kind of
congressman in the 34th district i could
use a good job like that
it's something we don't want to admit in
this country
how dependent we are increasingly on
uh the military-industrial complex we
don't actually manufacture that much in
this country anymore but without
question we manufacture more weapons
than anybody else on earth and we sell
them like crazy to anybody who will buy
them we particularly like a military
situation where we can sell weapons to
both sides
again you know people watching will say
uh that know you say you know it's not
he's not being tempered no but he's
isn't it nice he's he's living out there
in cardiff by the sea he looks down over
the beautiful pacific ocean he's doing
okay and all this stuff you're
surrounded by military industrial
complex oh lord knows this is a terrific
target where we're sitting right now but
they're you know they're protecting him
and isn't it nice that he can be this
critical but they're not protecting him
that's the point i mean what in fact the
country is in rather serious trouble
because
of our skewed
priorities i mean after all we have to
create a department of homeland security
because the so-called department of
defense which in an earlier time in this
country we call the war department uh
the department of defense has nothing to
do with defense it has to do with
uh
buying weapons that are worthless
which we do a lot of
buying things that were appropriate to
the cold war even though it's now 15
years old um and even then we knew
throughout the 1980s that there was
never going to be a war with the soviet
union we were kidding ourselves with
with i mean this is not the first time
we've had bad intelligence at work um
the uh
and things of this sort that is to say
slowly over time
as eisenhower warned us
we have become
oriented toward dependent upon accepting
of the rationale of why we have
monstrous standing armies and why we've
also
given up on the idea of citizen armies
i'm not sure how i stand on the draft i
don't particularly like it but at the
same time one of the things i do like
about it is it's a real check on
militarism when you're serving in the
armed forces because it's an obligation
of citizenship you become very
interested in whether your officers know
what you're they're doing whether
there's any
rhyme or reason
to the kind of military activities
you're engaged in
since 1973
service in the armed forces is a career
choice it's a
it is a a way there is no obligation to
do this at all it's a career choice
increasingly open as in many imperial
systems in the past for people facing
one or another dead end in our society
that's why until the iraq war
uh african americans were twice as well
represented in the army as they are in
the uh in the society things of this
sort i read that um you were asleep when
the first plane flew into the world
trade center yes here in california well
what how did you find out about it my uh
pardon me my publisher called to talk
about it
and uh we'd by then figured out that it
was a terrorist incident we'd seen the
attacks on both towers
but and we talked about it i discussed
it with many other people around the
country in that same day
the question being
who were the terrorists it hadn't
crossed our minds yet that they were
islamic terrorists
the date stood out september 11th
september 11th 1973 is a date known to
everyone in latin america that's when
the cia under the orders of richard
nixon overthrew the elected government
of salvador allende in chile and brought
in one of the most odious figures in the
history of american foreign policy
namely general agusto pinochet
um so we searched up maybe chileans
maybe okinawans maybe greeks probably
the most anti-american democracy on
earth they will never forgive us for the
regimen of the greek colonels put into
power by the uh by the cia until
the colonels went too far and got
themselves thrown out
any number of people in in central
america uh from the 1980s uh
you could the list is extensive it could
be guatemalans it could be indonesians
we after all overthrew the government of
indonesia or helped overthrow it and
brought in general suharto
so that uh
our support for uh
for dictators has been
legendary we used to call ferdinand
marcos who was the first president bush
who referred to him as a great democrat
well he certainly was anything but that
um
so that uh
it we were interested it uh the uh
certainly i did not believe that we
should have
have made it once or tried to see this
at once as a clash of civilizations i
don't think it was my own i believe
we've handled it miserably i believe
we'd have all been much better off if we
had treated it as
the way we would approach organized
crime that is attacks on innocent
civilians
building cases that would stand up in
court
focusing on who did it since we knew who
did it
and going after them instead of this
again war of choice so many of our wars
are wars of choice uh in which
arguably the world couldn't possibly
have been worse off if
george bush and dick cheney had never
heard of iraq
going back to the publisher though that
some people's misfortune turned out to
be your fortune didn't we oh
no doubt about that uh and it's an
unfortunate statement i mean that is my
publisher henry holt met bond books was
down on west 18th street uh that's
getting fairly close to ground zero and
uh my publisher is a lovely woman she
says i'm getting out of here uh but uh
the uh uh it turns out that the first
book i published blowback called the the
costs and consequences of american
empire it was two thousand year two
thousand well before 9 11 had not
received much of her perception in the
united states i mean people were not
terrible nice abroad but not here
uh
but it then turned out to be a
bestseller and uh right after
almost at once how many different
editions were oh there were at least
eight printings almost in a month uh
after uh after 9 11. and you remember
then that barnes and noble and places
like that had their little little uh
bridge table set up called you know 911
corner or something like that with a few
a few books on it mine was one of them
uh
i uh
i said to her one day it's a hell of a
way to make a living and she said yes it
is but it's better to sell them than not
sell them and um so that's essentially
what happened what's what was the impact
i mean can you think back of
once blowback got
uh you know on the best seller list and
all that what kind of feedback did you
get how much of a change did it make did
it have any impact well no it didn't i
mean blowback is a specific cia term it
was first used in the after action
report on our first overthrow of a
democratically elected government namely
the government of iran in in 1953 in
which the the report was not
declassified until the year 2000 in
which the word or the phrase
occurs in there we're going to get some
blowback from this well blowback doesn't
just mean retaliation it means
retaliation for things that we did
abroad uh for which that were kept
entirely secret from the american public
so that when the retaliation comes they
have no ability to put it in context to
seek cause and effect
that's why we ended up with
the president actually getting away with
a truly absurd question to congress why
do they hate us
you might well have wanted to ask who is
it on earth that doesn't hate us
for good reason i mean often in many
cases very good reason these things were
kept secret from the american public
they're not kept secret from the people
on the receiving end uh that when we
carry out one of these so-called
clandestine uh operations so that it um
uh
i was criticized almost once for
suggesting that the united states was in
some way responsible
in some way had was involved in
what had happened on september 11 2001.
of course i had argued precisely that
that this was blowback from the largest
single clandestine operation we ever
carried out namely the recruiting arming
and sending into battle of the
mujahideen in afghanistan in the 1980s
against the soviet union we once the
soviet union collapsed george bush
rather famously just walked away from
afghanistan osama bin laden was an asset
and an ally of ours in those days we
worked closely with him we armed him we
certainly knew where his basic cost was
because we had built it for it uh that
when
when bill clinton decided to bomb it
with cruise missiles things of this sort
they felt betrayed um
uh let down uh it was also foolish on
our part that we never once asked who
were these people we were supporting
they were anti-soviet but
william casey
reagan's cia director was a deeply
devout
mother passionately devout catholic who
seemed to believe that the greatest
single force against
communism would be religion
and uh he welcomed
islamic allies never once asking
what about islam what kind of islam
whom they might be what they
at any rate they um
osama bin laden and company felt
betrayed by the americans and they got
even they let us know what they were
doing
they did it quite regularly they had
already destroyed two embassies in east
africa they'd bombed the uss coal
similar bombings already occurred at the
world trade center
to be surprised at what happened on 9 11
seemed to me is is
incompetent on the part of political
leaders like to ask you about religion
um in the
movie in united 93 the story of
the united flight that went down in
pennsylvania
i haven't seen it well it doesn't matter
both sides in that the americans riding
in the back of the plane and the arabs
who are in control the plane
as they're headed toward their death
both sides are playing praying to their
god yes
what's your take on the religious aspect
of all this i mean
is god on somebody's side in this thing
well i think it's just the
politicization of ideology and of
identity uh that what we've really got
to see here is this is a matter of
geopolitics
that in many cases our foreign policy
has been badly conceived poorly carried
out and above all
hypocritically explained to the american
public that is the
oil politics that what happened to us in
the iranian revolution in 1979 when one
of the two pillars of our uh petroleum
policy in in the middle east collapsed
and that we've been working on it ever
since that it's not accident accidental
that virtually all of the political
leaders of our current government are
former petroleum company executives of
one kind or another you explain that in
your recent book yes exactly and
you but you think once somebody i mean
you're talking about this thing is
religion is is an element that is used
for identity purposes but i don't
believe that we are talking about
religious motives religious
identification one of the things that
interests me is that in the case of the
so-called american taliban
the young man john walker lind that was
arrested he'd only been in afghanistan
he arrived in august of 2001. he was
extremely pious young white middle-class
man from marin county california who had
converted to islam he had actually met
osama bin laden and was disgusted with
him because he didn't think he was
sufficiently devout that he was not
he was not a quran reader and
that he was a he was a terrorist
moreover it seems to me that contrary to
religious explanations bin laden in a
week after 9 11 in pieces that were
published the british press in new york
times things of this sort told us why
they did it
and it was
as i re recall them if i can get them
right
uh you americans will never live in
peace so long as you continue to back
the israelis against the palestinians
was one you will never live in peace so
long as you still have infidel troops
based in
the uh the
fountainhead of islam namely saudi
arabia which was a bad idea we never
should have put them there we put them
there after uh nine after uh the first
gulf war are they gone they're finally
gone yeah we've moved them to uh
to qatar and the united arab emirates
and places like that uh we had to i mean
saudis just simply couldn't live with
that and of course osama bin laden is
himself a prominent saudi figure the
sort of person that in the 1980s would
have been welcomed from the member of a
millionaire family you'd have been
welcomed at kenny bunkport as a guest of
of uh of george bush back to what you're
talking about when you're connecting the
current leaders with the oil business
and you write about this in your book
the sorrows of empire
you mentioned
george bush dick cheney condoleezza rice
and others
but the motive again i want to get back
to is that most of those people have all
made their money oh they've made their
money they're concerned with petroleum
security for the united states also to
use petroleum as a way of ex
exerting influence over other nations
particularly
high growth nations in east asia such as
china for the right or wrong reasons for
the right or wrong motives
their political geopolitic
geopolitical motives whether you think
these are right or wrong these are the
sorts of things that nations do to each
other we are uh
the last time we had i don't
particularly admire him but the last
time we had a candid secretary of state
on this subject was henry kissinger uh
victorian comes closer to it today too
they talk about the way we actually
teach international relations and what
goes on there and we i have never ever
heard of a course that taught any
important war being fought over religion
were you ever offered a job to serve in
an administration i would never offer an
administration job i was a consultant to
the cia
back in the late 1960s early
1970s to the office of national
estimates primarily because of my
interest in chinese communism
he's taught for 26 or 27 years 26 years
and then came down here for five years
and where are we cardiff by the seas
where oh it's just
slightly north of san diego it's a
lovely pleasant town but also located
between the headquarters of the 11th
naval district and if you looked at the
harbor it's filled full of
of the uh john stennis and the ronald
reagan that is aircraft aircraft
carriers that sit about six inches off
the bottom this is not the world's best
harbor for them uh but they like it here
and the marine base to the north it's a
it's a big concentration of military
power right here pendleton
now you you uh taught at the university
of california san diego for how many
years five years
are you retired now yes
your best decision i ever made why
there's life after the big organization
uh you no longer have to pretend that
your colleagues are smart you married
your wife sheila ware when
well 50 years ago actually not quite 49
in a
25 cent parking meter in washoe county
nevada namely reno
she was i'm sorry to say i think it's
called sexual harassment today she was a
student of mine uh and
she never forgave me for giving her a b
but we're now in our 49th year of
of marriage
or what is called the long conversation
and you have children no we don't uh my
wife is dutch she lived in occupied
holland during world war ii i she also
has her own phd she decided that
children are not an endangered species
and
we
didn't need any i took the view that if
the mother doesn't want children among
the worst kinds of vanity is male vanity
that thinks he needs to have one and
we've been very happy with that
understanding
back to the bases uh you once took a dip
in the caspian sea yes what were you
doing there
i was i was visiting in the ussr working
at the institute for the usa in canada i
took an extensive tour through the
caucasus uh georgia
armenia places like that
while in that area i was traveling with
russian colleagues
all members of the communist party of
course uh the uh they were interested in
me because of my work in east asia i was
interested in them uh i learned a lot
from them i used to walk in occasionally
and say i quote something that i read in
pravda and they would say oh you fooled
nobody gets their news from providence
uh you read pravda the way you read the
new york times to get the line
to find out whether you can keep your
dasha uh or whatever and know what you
have to do you get your news from
friends walks in the woods people you
trust
maybe the bbc occasionally
but that's what i was doing there i had
a wonderful swim uh the chief thing i
remember about it was that the water was
slightly oily
but the thing that impressed me in those
days was i uh i brought a nice big can
of caviar
got american airlines stewardess to put
it in her ice box carried it home
and said to my wife when we have a party
and she said like hell we'll have a
party
open this up and eat it ourselves
the reason i mention it is because you
devote a lot of time to all the bases
over in that area yes
the stands the kazakhstan the
stand all that with the collapse of the
soviet union in 1991 we moved vigorously
into this area uh it wasn't certainly
just george bush and the republicans it
was very much a democratic thing too
a lot of money involved
the
we had already had troop exchanges we've
now had
bases in uzbekistan and kyrgyzstan
uh
the
vice president has just visited
kazakhstan to try and arrange more oil
after insulting
the russians in a speech in in vilnius
it uh
yes it's one of the last areas on it's
this territory southern eurasia was
opened up by the collapse of the soviet
union to enormous geopolitical pressures
i don't think we've done it particularly
well
i think we've been remarkably cynical i
can't imagine how these people with a
straight face talk about the promotion
of democracy in places still ruled by
old soviet apparatchiks
who are very regularly welcomed to the
to the oval office by our president and
described in glowing terms whereas
the british ambassador to uzbekistan
quit uh because of the tortures being
carried out by the government uh and and
and uh
explained them to the world
so that i you know it's uh yes i was
interested in it and i was i was
fortunate to have visited in this area
too to also have some sense of
what
azerbaijan for example is like
why do leaders and this president's not
the first one to do this talk about the
need for democracy say in this case a
place like
um
iraq and then support dictatorships in
other parts of the world it's a default
position it's when their policies
doesn't work they don't work
then they uh wheel it out it's like it
could be
in in other contexts it would be islam
christianity or something of that sort
is the public paying attention to this
i don't know
i think they might
uh we've had a long history of this
after all going back into the first
world war when
uh woodrow wilson uh william jennings
bryan his secretary of state were
declaring that we were the exemplar for
good government on earth that all moral
issues
rested in in american leadership
i think as a historical generalization
you could not be wrong today to say it's
an unmitigated tragedy that the american
president believes such nonsense
had he not we might have avoided
intervening in a war between
the british and german empires in your
book in 2004 you wrote the four sorrows
of empire are endless war
loss of liberty habitual official lying
and financial ruin yes
expand on that a little well i think
they're all still here that is to say
we've uh
by the loss of liberty i mean that the
structure of government
bequeathed to us by the founders is
today in tatters if you believe
the government in washington dc bears
any resemblance to the government
outlined in the constitution of 1787
the burden of proof is on you there's
just way i mean
i cannot
for example is just inconceivable to the
people who created our republican little
r
form of government that you would that
the president would have at his disposal
a private army that's the cia totally
secret
no way you can do oversight on it no way
you can that he can be held account
accountable for it that 40 of the
defense budget is black it's not
reported it's
in contrary to article one of the
constitution that says you will be told
how your tax money is spent you will
never be told and that's not something
george bush
started with the manhattan project in
world war ii to build atomic bombs
it's these things
are cumulative there's now so many of
them
so built up over such a long period of
time that i believe there is a real
threat to
the continuation of of the republican
form of government that is
what
provides our democracy what provides our
civil liberties it is and by this we
mean
divided government the impossibility of
somebody becoming a dictator being
checks checks and balances a balance of
power
imperial presidency is a good term for
it uh today and it's out of control
i've interviewed a couple people that
participated in the documentary why we
fight jane jarecki's documentary one
thing i was interested in it was uh
karen katowski and bill crystal neither
one seemed to know
what the
mission was of the
uh the documentary and
bill crystal hadn't seen it and i just
wondered when you participated in it did
you know where mr director was going
i didn't except that he was very much
interested in ideas that i'd presented
in the soros of empire he was a great
admirer of eisenhower
i
wanted to argue with him that i have
enormous admiration for a former
general of the army five-star general
who ends his career by warning against
out-of-control military vested interests
and this is what we mean by militarism
we're not talking about defense of the
country nobody has any doubt about there
is an obligation at times to raise
citizen armies to defend the country
against aggression what we're talking
about the military
about militarism is the military as a
way of life as a way of making a living
as a uh as a
a kind of corporate organization with
interests of its own and uh and things
of this sort jarecki i think uses
eisenhower's
warning to us and it was as great a
warning as as george washington's
warning about standing armies um uses it
very effectively in the story he then in
the in the film and he has some awfully
good commentators including certainly uh
uh lieutenant colonel karen kitovsky uh
who resigned her career commission over
what she knew was going on inside the
pentagon um but
he also then has a couple of stories
built into it of a
a uh uh new york city policeman
whose uh
kid
was whose son was killed in the uh uh in
the the twin towers attacks
uh he's uh
spontaneous
not terribly thoughtful
utterly extremely interesting in his
belief in the presidency in in the
presidency as speaking for us and
he's basically saying if the president
says iraq did this to us fine let's go
hit iraq let's really go after him he in
fact worked very hard as it is explained
in the film to get the marines
delivering uh uh weapons from off one of
the air aircraft carriers to get them to
put his son's name on a bomb that was
dropped in iraq
he wanted retribution and he was getting
it
when he then uh uh uh directly uh quotes
a famous scene of president bush sitting
at the uh
in the cabinet room at his table and he
says uh i never said there was any
direct connection between iraq and 911
uh that saddam hussein was a uh was a
secularist the bath party was a
socialist party not
uh certainly not uh
islamic jihadists or fundamentalists uh
and he said um
i flipped out you know if you can't
trust the president who can you trust he
was lying to us
uh and we haven't done anything about it
we have procedures in this country for
getting rid of unsatisfactory political
leaders because that's what the congress
is supposed to do you could impeach them
we can have periodic elections we've had
an election that basically ratified
george bush's president's
presidency
and it's an interesting story that has
nothing to do with with the various
commentators that jarecki got into it i
think it's quite effective but the
reason i bring it up is that the
documentaries have been done now lots of
books are being written you wrote two
books uh well actually one really around
this particular the sorrows of empire
issue
you you're getting anywhere with this i
mean you suggested it's not gonna matter
if we're we're toast
um
if i'm wrong you're going to forgive me
because you're going to be so pleased i
was wrong uh
the uh but the evidence adds up that is
all you can do is to try in dealing with
contemporary history
to uh
use your experience
the facts that you can get put them
together in a plausible and coherent way
it looks like the united states
continues to head toward a terrible
cul-de-sac
that as it stands right now given
the largest that's the last of the sorts
of empire bankruptcy the largest trade
and current account and
fiscal deficits virtually in economic
history
we are
some people in my latest book i call it
a blanche dubois economy we are
increasingly dependent on the kindness
of strangers well as you remember the
strangers
became less and less kind to blanche in
tennessee williams play too
and we're
we're dependent on the kindness of the
minister finance of the people's
republic of china and of japan
now as many smart economists have said
it's an odd business for the world's
largest debtor nation to go around
insulting its banker all the time that's
what we do to the chinese all the time
and all he's got to do is to say one day
i think we've got too much money in
dollars the euro was a much stronger
currency uh the yen is a stronger
currency uh we ought to start the truth
of the matter is he's obviously thought
of that and they're doing it privately
and quietly anyway in order to not
disturb the markets when is your third
book in this trilogy coming out nemesis
probably at the end of this year
yeah i'm
still editing it a little bit working on
it uh the publisher has to decide they
don't like to publish books like this in
the christmas season in this country
in germany they don't mind doing so how
different is nemesis from the other two
books
it's
it's different in that it comes up with
a
i say that nemesis is already here
she's just waiting her turn
uh she's watching she's uh it's an
extremely interesting figure in greek
mythology uh edith hamilton has a
wonderful treatment of it in her famous
work on mythology uh that
and so that i believe that probably it
is irreversible that is i can't imagine
a president who caught any president who
could bring the military-industrial
complex the secret intelligence agencies
and the pentagon under control i think
they are they have lives of their own
today define your own politics
well that's
hard to say i guess i i voted twice for
ronald reagan
uh and i uh but today i vote democratic
uh no matter what oh certainly matter
what i mean here in uh in the 50th
district i'm voting for my neighbor
francine busby uh who
i hope will be elected this district
desperately needs change what party
democratic she's she's she's an
ex-republican uh who's also become a
democrat simply because of the uh
of the stultifying quality of sort of
san diego county orange county
republicans what but what do you think
the strongest about
i mean like in issues what's besides
what we've been talking about oh those
are the things that i feel strongly
about that is to say the united states
is being sold down the river
by people who don't understand what it
is
i really do recall when i was a kid
ages ago in arizona
my parents used to take the fourth of
july
as the only holiday that mattered
my mother in 1940 voted for wendell
wilkie
even though they all were very dependent
upon the new deal but she said no
president should be in more than two
terms where were you born in arizona in
the countryside
what did your parents do
well my father was in the navy for three
wars uh first second in korea but then
in between he was uh working as an
irrigation official in southern arizona
a place called buckeye it's a wide spot
in the road it has only one city limit
sign uh
i mean it's a hell hole
but it was a good place to be from if
you were a kid it was fun but on the
politics saying where were you before
ronald reagan for instance oh i voted oh
i guess when i was a college student
when i was a graduate student i was very
much on the left no question about it
that i
uh and i still know
even though as i said i
i think of the soviet union as a menace
i still know and admire a great many
people who
gave up on
on russia because the kgb because of the
gulag and all the rest a long time ago
but who can't help but stand up if you
hear the international plague uh it's
there was still idealism
that was
rooted in it idealism rooted in chinese
communism
that
was betrayed and is gone
but it
one would be crazy ever to deny that it
was there
and then after ronald reagan
where would you vote for
i did vote for dukakis simply because uh
the first george bush got on my nerves i
thought he was a walking watercress
sandwich
too yelly for my taste uh and i just
didn't care for him uh it was more of a
personality thing than anything else he
didn't
he do did know a great deal more than
his son about the world
ex-director of central intelligence uh
scowcroft was probably his
admiral schoolcraft not uh general
schoolcroft not
the world's greatest intellect but
you have to say he'd never let things
get out of control the way condoleezza
rice did and he didn't he understood uh
uh how the government worked and what
were our responsibilities in
international affairs i
i did not like bill clinton
but he just ended up being president
anyway i didn't didn't i didn't think he
had the right background i still don't
think he did the right things i was
astonished at how fast after he's
elected
wall street showed up to give him a
lesson in the bond market
and uh and he changed his policies very
very quickly
even so i do admire at least he did
begin to
reduce the national debt
what do you think of the current
president
i can control my enthusiasm
i think it's the best way to i don't
think he's qualified in any way and will
go down as an unmitigated disaster uh
but
the worst thing is the cynicism with
which he has mobilized
the hopes and aspirations of a large
number of american citizens
and
distracted
the public
through a meaningless and worthless war
we could have handled
i mean
what osama bin bin laden did on 9 11
didn't affect the balance of power one
iota
there was nothing changed at all on the
day after
if you wanted to maintain democracy you
didn't want to declare war on him you
didn't even want to call it a war you
want to call it an emergency we knew how
to deal with terrorists we would had we
been more intelligent we'd still have
all of our allies we'd have most of the
arab world supporting us too they
understood these issues
we'd have been able to proceed
intelligently and correctly instead
we are in terrible trouble and it's
extremely hard to figure out how we're
going to get out
anybody you see coming along in the
leadership world that you would be
supportive of in the future
not
not that i've noticed frankly no i don't
think you sound like a couple things and
just tell me what that you're not very
happy with your country and that you're
basically don't have much hope
i guess that's
true
uh that that is put in another way i
don't think hope means anything at all
unless you could analyze it unless you
can see how things would begin to change
i believe that we need
and could conceivably have in america
a mobilization of popular democratic
sentiment to retake the congress to
reconstitute the country i'm always
amazed to see how the poll numbers seem
to be more powerful than anything we're
reading in the media but even so it's a
huge country i don't see how you can
mobilize it when uh most of the media
are in the hands of conglomerate
interests and
are simply not worth watching i mean if
you know what's going on in the world
and you watch the evening network knows
you know that the direct opposite is
what being reported it's just or
what's most serious is what's being
omitted uh what's simply not regarded as
newsworthy as they shift to
what some mba has told them is important
to do now put in a segment for old
people on their aches and pains and how
to sell pills or which pills don't work
or things of this sort it's um this is
the sort of thing that that worries you
corruption
it begins to look like
the roman republic
and it does begin to look like we could
be awaiting
a julius caesar a
that after all a
a person within
the establishment a former consul
who then decides to throw in his lot
with the military a military populist a
juan peron
a napoleon bonaparte
uh
now in what is said to be the greatest
tyrannosite in history of course a group
of
senators stabbed him in the forum uh the
uh
but uh
he was then succeeded by his grand
nephew
a truly ruthless man
octavian
who goes on we call it the roman empire
it's the roman military dictatorship
chalmers johnson thank you very much
thank you it's a pleasure talking with
you
[Music]
for a copy on dvd or vhs tape call
a 1-877-662-7726 us at q a dot org
q a programs are also available as
c-span podcasts
[Music]
and a half hours we're going to present
two live programs on these two books in
about 75 minutes chalmers johnson will
be live to take your calls on his new
book this is it it's called nemesis and
the subtitle is the last days of the
american republic this is the last in a
trilogy of books by mr johnson the first
two were blowback and the sorrow of
empire but first we're going to discuss
this book which was published recently
by harper collins it's by british
historian andrew roberts and it's called
a history of the english speaking
peoples since 1900 throughout our
program our phone lines will be open and
you're invited to join us if you would
like here are the phone numbers for
republicans 202-737-001
for democrats 202-737-002
and for independence 202 628-00
you can also email us during these
programs if you have a question we'll
take emails at booktv cspan.org
andrew roberts last appeared on this
network in 2003
excuse me 2002 actually was recorded it
was on a book notes for his book called
napoleon and wellington and since then
he has written hitler in churchill and
what might have been and waterloo and
the book that we're going to be
discussing today this book a history of
the english speaking peoples since 1900
this is from a 2000 2002 book book notes
and mr roberts will be joining us live
in just a few moments from new york but
here's a chance for you to learn a
little bit about him and his writing
there's one tiny little fact in your
book that's american and that is that
you found a napoleon wellington high
school somewhere in the state of
missouri
how did you find that and if you happen
to have been there i haven't been there
no um but i was giving a a a speech in
at fulton missouri the um i've got an
honorary doctorate from
from westminster college there and um i
was giving a speech about winston
churchill and um i drove past it so it
was something that um that lodged in my
memory i made a note of it and the
importance of uh fulton
well the importance of fulton is um that
it was there in march 1946 that winston
churchill attempted um unsuccessfully at
the time interestingly enough to um open
the world's eyes to the threat of
communism and basically um
told the british and the americans that
russia was not the um the friendly power
um that it had been during the during
the second world war but actually um
that uh they ought to wake up and
realize that there was a cold war going
on so it was one of the most important
speeches in retrospect of the century
however at the time it was considered to
be war-mongering rhetoric and we know it
as the iron curtain speech we do it was
the speech in which he said that from
stettin to
down to the danube there was going to be
an iron curtain that effectively had had
landed and there were three or four very
important
um
countries that had hitherto been seen as
part of the west and that of course we
didn't consider to be again part of the
west until the fall of the of the berlin
wall um in 1989. and what led to you
getting an honorary degree from
westminster college well i'd written um
a few books on winston churchill and
he
got another one coming out next month in
fact and um
he um has got a
um a library there dedicated to him and
um
the continuation of what they do to um
keep churchill's memory alive at fulton
is absolutely fantastic and i was very
honored to be
invited to uh to give a lecture that
today where do you live full time i live
in knightsbridge in in london just a few
doors down from harrod's department
store i think that's probably the way
that and are you attached to school or
is this full-time java writing no it's a
and i i wouldn't have the time i don't
think to to uh to teach or mark exam
papers or anything like that i i'm kept
pretty busy doing this now this uh well
napoleon wellington book that we have
here was originally published here in
this country when it was published um in
um april 2001.
and in the united states it's published
by simon schuster and i wonder in the
in in this book
the lead blurb on the back is from
somebody by the name of henry kissinger
was that the same blurb you had on the
book here in uh great britain it wasn't
no um i sent a copy to uh dr kissinger
after it was published and
and he obviously very um kindly gave me
something to put on the back of that um
it was something actually that my
publishers organized rather than myself
i'm very pleased they did if it'll help
because what we have to remember
is that he has an amazing locker standee
um not just obviously as the historian
of um diplomacy but also his latest book
but also um
he wrote a book about
metanic and castle ray and taliron three
of the great european statesmen of the
time of of napoleon and wellington and
so he really does know his stuff when it
comes to that period he says andrew
roberts has re-examined the relationship
between 19th century europe's two
greatest generals their inevitable
battle at waterloo and its impact on
history napoleon and wellington is an
absorbing book well-researched enriched
and new and interesting detail valuable
both as a biography and military history
but you also have another connection
with henry kissinger well yes um i'm
going to write his biography i've been
asked by um uh alfred knopf to do the um
uh a sort of life of him it's not going
to be an authorized life in that um dr
kushner is not going to have the right
to blue pencil anything i write he
probably won't read anything i um i
write before it's published but he is
giving me cooperation for um allowing me
into his papers at the library of
congress 30 tons of them i've been told
so that's going to be quite a few uh
quite a few years i don't have to hand
in the book until uh 2006. so um
i have met him yes i met him on a couple
of occasions and uh um
got on very well he's uh obviously a
tremendously impressive figure why do
you want to go from winston churchill to
napoleon and wellington to henry
kissinger what's the connection henry
kissinger it will be the first living
person that i've i've written about um
all my other um people have been have
been safely dead and i um i well i find
it a
quite a challenge i don't shy from
controversy uh it's very clear that um
dallas christians is a pretty
controversial figure um in america
probably the most controversial american
living today i would have thought uh
with the various attacks that have been
made on him so i think it'll be very
very interesting for me as a
non-american
somebody who can't remember the vietnam
war i
vaguely remember being i mean i was 12
when saigon fell for example um
but
i'm therefore i think going to be able
to come to it with a degree of
objectivity that many americans wouldn't
be able to because of course the
um both vietnam and uh and and cambodia
are really
such emotional issues for americans in a
way they simply are not for me i think
are going to be able to get a
historian's objectivity
and that was mr andrews in 2002 on a
book notes program now he joins us live
from new york city hello
hello first of all let me ask you what
happened to the kissinger book
oh my life changed very suddenly um and
drastically after that i got
i've recently got married and
i want to stay in england frankly rather
than spend months in library of congress
and do you think there's someone else
out there to to write that kissinger
biography oh i know there is a great
friend of mine neil ferguson is doing it
and uh
also another friend of mine sir alastair
horn is uh is writing that book so
together uh they're both writing
separate books but we're going to have
two pretty impressive works from two
very significant and serious historians
so i don't feel that i've dropped a
catch or anything like that but today
we're here to talk about this book a
history of the english-speaking people
since 1900 what were you trying to do
with it
well i was trying to really finish uh
off winston churchill's history of the
english-speaking peoples in 1956 so just
over half a century ago
he wrote this wonderful four-volume work
which brought the um the story of the
english-speaking peoples by which he
defined them as those countries where
the majority of
people speak english as their first
language so american britain uh canada
new zealand australia the west indies
and ireland and bring them up to the
present day because he stopped at the
time of the death of queen victoria in
1901 and it always struck me that really
the much more interesting period
for the english-speaking people has been
what's happened to them since 1901 with
the first world war the second world war
the cold war and now of course the uh
the
war against terror i want to dig into
this uh go to page 635 read you a little
bit and get your reaction give our
viewers a little idea about the angle
that you take on your history you says
you say this it was the athenian
historian thucydides who first wrote of
uniting the four distinct but successful
and related conflicts between athens and
sparta from 4 uh 31 bc to 404 bc into
one great peloponnesian war the subject
of his classic narrative composition
similarly the four distinct but
successive attacks on the uh
the uh security of the english-speaking
peoples by william uh germany the axis
powers soviet communism and now islamic
fundamentalism ought to be seen as an
overall century-long struggle between
the english-speaking people's democratic
pluralism and the fascist intolerance of
different varieties
yes that's right i think that uh those
different types of
fatty fascism the proto-fascism of the
wilhelmine um uh prussian militarists
and then of course axis fascism of of
germany italy and japan and then the red
um soviet uh communist fascism and now
this uh fabulously intolerant
totalitarian
terrorist fascism that we're seeing from
islamic fundamentalists
all have enough in common that bind them
which really is a loathing of what the
english-speaking peoples have stood for
for
many years now certainly since 1900
which is uh
representative institutions religious
tolerance um freedom of speech freedom
of expression freedom of the press and a
free market
when you uh when you first started
writing this book what were you were you
trying to be opinionated you said in the
clip from the book notes that you do not
uh shy away from controversy in the back
of the book one of your blurbs actually
says that this is an opinionated history
yes um i
think of myself very much as an
objective historian somebody who comes
from a uh comes to his uh final
points of view from looking at the
evidence
but as i was writing this book it did
seem to me more and more and i it took
me to the papers of 200 people in 30
countries on three continents um that i
i came across really almost unbidden
came to me this uh this very much this
strong sense that the reason that the
english-speaking peoples have been the
world um uh political culture the the
dominant world political culture since
1900 has been very much because
you in your country have stuck to the
principles of the 1776 to 83 uh
revolution and we in britain and
britain's
former empire and colonies and now
commonwealth have very much stuck to the
principles of the great revolution of
1688 and once those thoughts had uh had
really come into my mind um i looked for
other ways to see whether or not that
could be tested against the general
assumption i found it good and i found
that it stood up
you talked a lot in your especially at
the beginning of your book about this
historical relationship between this
country and yours and specifically
giving some historical background on
that and i'm not sure i can say it
correctly but you talk about the fact
that
both of our countries were successful
when we were together and non-successful
when we were against each other can you
give the historical aspect of that
well yes when one thinks of the uh
really since 1900 since the uh time of
the great prime minister lord salisbury
and your
very great
president theodore roosevelt um on those
occasions the first world war of course
was uh was one example the second world
war another the cold war and on those
examples those times when we were on the
same side we tended to prevail uh when
on the other hand uh we weren't on the
same side one thinks of the sewers
crisis of um
the period for britain uh of the second
world war up until pearl harbor uh one
thinks of i suppose vietnam as well
would also count as that uh when we
haven't been um together
we tend not to and i think that's a
that's a very interesting and of course
uh has all sorts of um modern day
overtones very interesting factor about
our two civilizations and you talk about
how it's played out in this current war
too
well absolutely yes but i think that
overall going back really to the mid 18
1800s mid 19th century all the way
through to the 21st century people in
the future historians in the future will
see
the rather than uh see it as first the
british empire and then the american
republic having uh world primacy i think
they will think of these two being
together and being seen as the
english-speaking peoples after all today
when one thinks of ancient rome one
doesn't split it up between the uh the
roman republic and the roman empire and
one's a a historian
or a peasant and the two are not
mutually exclusive
our phone lines are open if you'd like
to join us for republicans 202-737-001
for democrats
triple zero 202-737-002
for independence 202-628-0205
and we also will take your emails at
book tv
cspan.org
what do you think of the current
conflict that the united states and your
country is and and the world is in terms
of of uh islamic fundamentalism
well i do think that um
it's not seen enough in its overall
historical perspective one of the things
that i try and do in my book is to place
this um this war in iraq and in
afghanistan in the overall
um great historical sweep because i
think it is the war against terror in
general
a
a world historical struggle i think that
americans have in a sense been very
fortunate in some of the wars that they
fought recently uh one thinks of grenada
one thinks of kosovo one thinks of the
first gulf war which all of them had
tremendously low casualty rates now that
is not going to be the same in this
great um massive world historical
struggle of the war against terror and
the trouble is that it seems to me that
americans have assumed that it might
well be the same now you've lost um
a total of
3150
men so far and uh
and of course every individual death is
an appalling tragedy but when one sees
it across the uh the historical scope in
fact you know you lost almost that kind
of number taking a single island of
tarawa in the second world war we in
britain have lost 130 men in
in iraq and that's a quiet weekend on
the western front from the great war um
in the american civil war of course 622
000 americans died um killing each other
it's um the the three thousand or so
who've died in um this present conflict
you'd imagine from the um from the media
that some appalling and monstrous defeat
has been um affected on the uh american
arms that is frankly not the case you're
only three years into a struggle nearly
four years into a struggle which is
going to be a very long very dangerous
very costly one and i think it's very
important to get that into its proper
perspective another historical aspect
that you write about uh fro about this
conflict you say just as the roosevelt
administration and churchill government
had agreed to destroy hitler first even
though japan was the immediate enemy
that had struck america so the bush
administration and the blair government
correctly identified the importance of
removing the core problem in the middle
east saddam hussein even though the
immediate enemy uh that had struck the
post-11 excuse me that had struck the
united states had been al-qaeda
well absolutely and the interesting
thing about that really is that um it
was a
an act of the mr clean foresight on
behalf of the uh roosevelt
administration back in 19 late 1941
early 1942 to choose to attack even
though you yourselves have been attacked
in pacific the first major ground thrust
took place in north africa and that was
uh that was a very um very deeply
impressive
and act of foresight the key thing is i
think with regard to iraq that you were
being mocked and humiliated for 12 years
by saddam hussein and it's very often
not the big states the big manikin
struggles and clashes between big states
that signal the end of great power
status when one looks at austria-hungary
versus serbia when one looks at um
a french empire at dmvn foo in indochina
in 1954 or the british empire at the
time of the suez crisis in 1956 or
indeed of course uh the soviet union in
afghanistan in 1989 1979 to 89 it's very
often the small states that herald the
end of great power status and it if one
just completely ignores wmd if one takes
out of the picture the the horror the
monstrosity of the uh saddam hussein
regime
iraq still had to be
taken out and defeated in 2003 onwards
in order to
show that america still had the
necessary prestige in the world to
affect all the other positive things
that it's able to do everywhere and why
was it why is prestige uh important
prestige is very different from
popularity by the way i don't think
americans should worry too much about
whether they're popular across the world
we certainly didn't when we the british
empire around the world any more than
the romans did or napoleon did or you
name it um the importance of prestige is
that you don't have other great powers
attempting to rest from you the primacy
that you uh that you've enjoyed really
since the 1940s and i think that's a
very important thing for the
english-speaking peoples
you in the uh conclusion of your book
talk about the mistakes that uh america
has made over the years you list them
they take a couple paragraphs actually
no not just america i mean the whole of
the whole of things right and many
mistakes ending with um some of the
things that happened in iraq but you go
on to say that other powers if they had
been in the same shoes would have done
it worse yes i think that when one looks
at the way that the um
the the germans uh the french the
spanish and
several other um powers that were
significant the ottoman empire also
significant in 1900 i think that uh one
looks at those uh certainly uh the way
they ran their empires the uh the the
russians also the russian empire ought
to be drawn into this as well i think
that they would have a far less
um uh
decent
uh record in what they have done were
they to have been the uh the prime world
powers since 1900 i think that overall
the world's been a very lucky place that
britain and america australia new
zealand and the other nations have been
the people who've been setting the pace
when one looks at
the morgantown plan the doors plan the
fabulous things that
american civilization has done for the
world i think there's an awful lot to be
proud of to the phones now indianapolis
hello
hello
uh i'd like to ask if
the author thinks that
england established itself as the world
hegemon or the leading state at the end
of the seven years war or at the end of
the napoleonic war this is uh i belong
to a group of people they're very
interested in napoleonic history and
we've been having this discussion and
also what point and for what reason
as short as you can why britain lost it
and passed it to the united states
and that's a very good question
from the gentleman from indiana
uh and it's also a one that we
historians in in britain discuss quite a
lot i would say what happened at the
time of the seven years war is that we
set up the vital
big
issues like uh like canada and india
with our victories um at placi and uh
the heights of saint abraham and
quibbering bay and these various very
important battles uh which gave us the
uh the the big land masses in the seven
years war but it wasn't really until um
the end of the napoleonic war in the
treaty of uh vienna in 1815
that we managed to get the key nodal
points that allowed us via the royal
navy of course to um to hold and
resupply these um
these important land masses and of
course we also in that war knocked out
the french as a um as a primary threat
to uh to these uh places so we cleared
the seas and um and managed to back
ourselves up in the second of those wars
but it was the first of those wars that
had to have taken place before we were
able to do that in the first place and
the turnover happened when
turnover happened well again historians
will debate this um endlessly but i
think really january 1944 was the month
in which more american
troops were active actually engaged
against german divisions in the western
hemisphere than there were british and
commonwealth
troops and of course in the pacific war
right from the beginning the americans
had a huge preponderance
over the uh forces of all the other
allied powers so so the key moment comes
a good five months before d-day in my
view brookfield ohio
hi i was just wondering if he uh
in his book because he reconciles uh
english colonialism
with the high moral decent
uh
ground that english speaking people take
yes i do very much so there are there
are a couple of chapters dedicated very
much to the way in which uh generations
of uh extremely high-minded serious uh
moralistic uh christian gentleman gave
their entire lives um many of them 40 or
50 years of their lives to attempting to
improve the lot of
the very vast empire quarter of the
world's land surface almost that we had
by uh by 1914 i think that overall when
one thinks of
the fact that there are only 60 members
for example of the sudanese
civil service that ran a company of uh
sorry a country of 15 million people
first of all one realizes that they were
not held down by uh by the kind of
vicious force that
anti-imperialists and uh and socialist
historians uh make out today they were
in fact very largely uh governing by
consent and they governed extremely well
in fact the happiest time that the sudan
has ever had when one thinks of what's
going on there now with a quarter of a
million people dying in the last three
years uh the happiest period of its
history both before and after uh was the
time when the british were there and i
i have quite a lot of that in my book
you have in your photos of your book
several
interesting juxtapositions i wanted to
ask you about first one is this one
where at the top of the page you have
the statue of lenin coming down in 1991
and at the bottom of the page you have
the statue of
saddam hussein coming down in april of
2003. and then coming over to the other
side of the page you have richard nixon
leaving on his helicopter uh in 1974
and coming down you show the helicopter
leaving the embassy
in saigon in april of 1975. and one more
here you have a picture of edmund
hillary um who's uh
um
he's going to go up mount everest here
and at the bottom of it you have the
landing on the moon what were these
juxtapositions supposed to mean
um
well i think
they uh in a sense that one there that
you're showing uh speaks for itself the
english-speaking peoples uh hillary of
course was a new zealander rather than a
than a britain
getting to the most
difficult
top of the peak along of course with his
nepalese bearer
sherpa tensing
and that was a great moment for the
english-speaking peoples because it took
part it took um
place on the very day that queen
elizabeth ii was crowned
and then down um
you have the this this fabulous
technological um victory of the
of the american people getting to the
moon in 1969 there it is it's a
it's a thing that should make every
american's heartbeat prouder frankly
staten island new york hello
hi uh
my question is
um niall ferguson's um premise that if
britain had stayed out of war
the first world war in 1914 had to stay
neutral she would have been an adequate
counterpoint to germany even if germany
had won the war
i i actually think that's a pretty sound
notion uh what do you think about that
sir
again it's very good question but no i
disagree uh there because i think what
would have happened is the um the french
would have been defeated in 1914 in the
same way that the um that they were in
1870 and so you would have had um
wilhelm germany which was a pretty um
aggressive and unpleasant power then
turning in this way same way that hitler
did in 1941
turning on the east and uh and being
able to use all the divisions that were
held up on the western front in
actuality
against the russians when one looks at
hindenburg's victory the battle of
tannenberg in 1915 he could well have
knocked the russians out of the war and
had he done that he would have been able
to uh dominate uh the kaiser would have
dominated the whole of the european land
mass from pretty much breast to the
euros and that would have been a
disaster for the um
for the british empire because we
wouldn't have had any ability really to
have uh established a foothold in the
same way as we didn't for 25 years in
the napoleonic wars so by and large i
agree with pretty much everything that
neil
says but i don't agree with him on this
point uh for reasons that i i also give
in uh the i think third chapter of this
book
uh i would be remiss on this uh
president's day weekend here in the
united states to uh to not ask you who
your favorite united states presidents
of this time period that you worked with
are and uh who your least favorite are
um i was most impressed by theodore
roosevelt um fdr who i think is a giant
amongst presidents in the 20th century
uh saving capitalism at the time of the
great depression and then saving um uh
really representative institutions in
the time of the second world war i think
he was an enormous figure i also have a
great deal of respect for ronald reagan
and
as far as the people i'm less impressed
by i suppose this book is not terribly
kind to jimmy carter i think that the
period in the 1970s
of his presidency also not entirely
due to him but but he didn't help much i
don't think
in the way that
really if you're looking for a terrible
decade for the english-speaking peoples
across the board
and also across the globe you go to the
to the 1970s they were a dismal decade
and your favorite and least favorite
prime ministers
um well i'm a uh
i'm a trustee of margaret thatcher's
archive um and uh she
is somebody who i've always uh
admired greatly um winston churchill of
course stands head and shoulders above
the the rest
and uh i once wrote a biography of lord
salisbury who was the prime minister
right at the beginning of our period and
uh and he's also somebody who
i think is uh is tremendously impressive
i never expected tony blair by the way
to be impressive i'm a fairly
reactionary tory in british domestic
politics and i thought that he was going
to
just be yet another machine politician
who would do whatever the opinion polls
wanted him to but after 9 11 when he
said that he would stand shoulder to
shoulder with the americans and then did
and has ever since
he has gone up
hugely in my estimation and
so i would count him up there with the
greats as far as the um less impressive
ones concerned um
harold wilson and john major i think
were neither of them really um
should have been prime minister i don't
think they were either
they were they were properly qualified
for that post woodstock uh georgia hello
hello uh mr roberts i'd like to switch
gears just a little bit and ask you
about the future
what you see is the future i am becoming
deeply concerned with the abilities of
the governments of english-speaking
peoples to handle major problems simply
maybe because of
the openness and may and so on i'm
talking things like border control the
middle east
social security medicare in our country
and i'm sure you have them yourself and
i'm becoming concerned that this form of
government really can't handle these
problems and i'd like your comment on
that if you would please sir
um well
again a very good question but not
really one um uh the gentleman from
georgia should ask a historian because
one of the great things about being
historian is you don't have to look at
the future you can concentrate solely on
the uh on the past but if one is really
uh pressed to um
to comment on this i would have thought
that um all the way through the 20th
century there have been people worrying
about the same kind of things that
you're worrying about today so
especially um
process whether or not we've got a
active enough democracy to be able to
deal with these issues and frankly
each time we
we've done a pretty good fist of getting
out of the um of the worst problems and
uh and getting ready for the next one so
i think if you look really in the
history of your republic the whole way
back over 200 years people have always
been ringing their hands and saying oh
what are we going to do disastrous
problems for the future and yet each
time uh given goodwill
given in
statesmanship given intellect and given
a certain degree of wisdom on behalf of
our leaders
we've got through it
lincoln park
illinois good good day i i'm somewhat
confused i actually uh only been
watching you guys for roughly the last
five minutes
um your title english speaking peoples
is that and
is that sort of
localism of european uh uh anglo uh i
mean what what is the gist of that are
you speaking of governments in
particular
no no uh it's a phrase that sir winston
churchill originally came up with when
he published his uh his book in 1956
and it means those countries where the
majority of people speak english as
their first language so that's uh that's
britain and america
australia new zealand
canada the west indies and ireland there
are lots of places of course i mean when
one looks at india 14 of indians speak
english for example but they don't count
because it's not a majority and so as a
result otherwise of course you wind up
uh writing a history of the world but i
think the the gentleman from illinois
has hit on an uh an important uh issue
here and that is the importance of the
english language itself and to what
extent the english language is a binding
thing
and to what extent also is it helpful in
the expansion of the influence of the
english-speaking peoples because at the
moment an astonishing statistic this
there are as many people learning
english
as their second language mainly in china
as there are english speakers who have
it as their first language today 350
millions and so what that might well
mean is in our life our lifetimes or
possibly our children's lifetimes
english is going to be a world language
is going to be the language in which the
entire globe is going to be able for the
first time in history to have a global
conversation i i go into this a little
in my book but you also say that you you
think that possibly uh china is the
future where we're gonna have to look
well i think that um it's clear that if
uh if that number of um of people are
embracing capitalism to the uh and the
free market to the uh extent that they
certainly seem to be
if they are able to do what uh the
english-speaking peoples have up until
now managed to do which is to be at the
very forefront of all the great uh
technological and industrial innovations
that have taken place when one thinks of
the revolutions that have taken place in
uh automobiles and aeronautics and
computers finance
i.t the internet the english-speaking
peoples have up until now been at the
forefront of all of those and that's led
to
their power and influence if however um
they have their place taken by either
the chinese or the indians or who know
some other um
civilization then and people are able
other people are able to create the
right products at a cheap enough price
for people to want to buy them then the
underlying
factor of the english speaking people's
primacy will be
will be taken away old tap in new jersey
you're next with andrew roberts
go ahead new jersey hi mr roberts
i'm a commander believe me i'm not very
smart
i'd like to know do you think the
american you know america right now
leads are becoming more imperialistic
than democratic it seems like we try to
get our footprint all over the world
and we never leave
and then the second part i would like to
ask you is did you ever see the
documentary why we fight i'd appreciate
your answer
i i didn't see that documentary i'm i'm
afraid um
but uh no i don't think america is
imperialistic in that uh it does leave
it uh it's left um germany it's left
japan it's left
europe pretty much it
when it fights um very successfully say
in kosovo
after that after the victory it leaves i
don't think that i by the way in this
present conflict i think it's going to
be a long time before america should
leave
various bases in the middle east because
that's going to be an extremely
difficult and dangerous place for many
years to come perhaps decades but
nonetheless i don't see any desire in
the american people or indeed their
politicians their administrations to try
to um
be imperialistic in the same way that
the british were imperialistic in the
19th century where we actually sort of
colored um the the map red and
and ran
the day-to-day affairs of
billions of people that is really not
what washington is all about mr
robertson looking at your
acknowledgements as most authors you
have quite a long list of people who
you uh say helped you or that you talk
to in writing this book and i i mark
just a few of them because they'll mean
a lot to our viewers uh benazir bhutto
douglas feith newt gingrich irving
crystal
john mcsender john mccain richard pearl
don rumsfeld how did they help you
and not just you've just you've gone
through all the uh
all the neocons there are also people
like colin powell uh there who
who and several others actually you can
you can read them off there who are not
uh um you know fully paid up for card
carrying right wingers um they helped me
through conversations um i uh i met
several of them at different lunches and
dinners that were taking place in
in the united kingdom a lot of these
people
visit london and whenever they do and i
can hook up with them i discuss the
english-speaking peoples with them i've
moved on now i'm writing a book about
the second world war so whenever i meet
anybody now i talk about the second
world war but it's a it's been
completely invaluable to hear uh for
example colin powell's view on the help
that the australasians were able to give
when he was
he was your secretary of state in the
intelligence sphere for example because
um that's one aspect where the
english-speaking peoples have helped one
another stuck together a little bit like
nuclear cooperation as well to a
tremendously uh deep degree and one
that's immensely helpful for for all
sides evanston illinois hello
hi um i
was struck by what you were saying about
the decline of the british empire and
how and when it happened
i've always thought that the seeds of
that
destruction was rarely in the loss of
its
of really the flower of its youth all
those young men in the beginning of
world war one and uh many of these
officers that made these gallon charges
with
many of their regiments up the hill
with a swagger stick and that sort of
thing and
really
really the battle techniques that uh did
not catch up to the
the weaponry you know the machine guns
and so forth and how um this was really
the thieves of uh
much of the uh idea bank if you will of
of the british empire to come and uh
this is a loss that they just really
couldn't uh couldn't replace and if you
agree with that
i do agree with that uh very much yes um
i think the gentleman from illinois has
got it absolutely bang on i go into this
in i think it's the fourth chapter of my
book in some detail the um the appalling
losses that took place on the uh western
front and also in gallipoli during the
uh great war um were absolutely
fundamental to the
loss of um of self-confidence really
that uh afflicted the british empire by
1919 and it was in a form of decline
pretty much ever since we often forget
that actually self-government was coming
to india in the 1930s had it not been
for the second world war it would have
it would have come there earlier than it
did and
um
i went to the but many of the
battlefields of the english-speaking
peoples in the course of this uh of this
book when one thinks of the d-day uh
landings 98
of the um
men killed on d-day were from the
english-speaking peoples um i also went
to the battlefield of uh gallipoli
several of uh of those very very
powerful moving battlefields where the
australians new zealanders and uh and
britain's lost thousands of men fighting
in frankly impossible circumstances with
tremendous courage and it was one of the
most moving aspects of uh of writing
this book
next new york hello
hello yes new york city you're on the
air
yes um
uh historically it seems that uh there
have always been empires whether it's
the uh
roman
islamic or the american empire but
our uh um
her empire is really uh uh inevitable
and why can't countries
uh
the individual nation states just work
through
uh international uh uh
law and institutions to resolve their
problems
well um i as i said earlier to the
gentleman i think it was from illinois i
don't believe america is an empire i
think that uh really very unusually for
the world
america america doesn't uh have any
desire to decide on the day-to-day
activity of what's going on um across
the globe but i do think that
since the foundation of the united
nations there has been a kind of attempt
at doing what you say but again and
again unfortunately the united nations
has not um been successful in uh in
doing this largely beginning
in keeping the peace largely i think
because it um
it prefers to always attempt to go for a
compromise when sometimes it's up
against people with the league of
nations of course it was hitler recently
it was saddam who simply are not
interested in compromise but in your
bigger question your larger question
about whether um
about the rise and fall of empires in
general
i think it's very important to remember
that the
um
wealth of an empire your country of
course at the moment by far and away the
richest country in the world does not
necessarily mean that it will um
survive in its potency forever frankly
uh when one looks at the mayan empire
they were richer than the conquistadors
the ottoman empire was richer than the
mongols the
roman empire richer than the huns um the
the romanovs were richer than the
bolsheviks and the weimar
even poor old weimar was richer than the
nazis so in many sense it's the
willpower of the um of the people as
opposed to just the simple wealth of an
empire and i think that's tremendously
important that americans should should
bear in mind today
last fall george stephanopoulos of abc
asked president bush what he was reading
and he said he was reading this book
did you what was your reaction to that
and did you ever have a chance to talk
to the president about it
well um actually the president then
wrote me a uh a
full page handwritten letter um inviting
me to the oval office because he said he
wanted to talk about it a bit more so um
so next week i'm i'm going off and
having lunch with him at the at the
white house him and and also mr cheney
and mr rove um which is a great honor
needless to say and i'm hugely looking
forward to it but only three days after
i got that letter i then got a letter
from uh from tony blair my prime
minister to say that um that uh mr bush
had given my book to him in the oval
office and um and then i read in a in a
uh a blog somewhere that mr howard the
prime minister of australia is also
reading the book so um it seems to me
that
the leaders of the english-speaking
peoples are at least interested at the
moment in the history of the
english-speaking peoples and what is the
one thing that you hope they take from
it
oh golly that's a good question um
i suppose overall
it would be
um
not to
feel
any kind of um sort of preemptive cringe
uh
culturally or socially because
we at the moment are the top dog power
in the globe i think that overall um
it is better it has been better that a
um a
civilization like ours which is capable
on occasion on many occasions of um
acting um
with uh with positive
altruistic motives should have been
running the world for the last 150 years
i
don't necessarily think that
some of the other nations that are
likely to take over are going to be much
kinder to the globe than we've been have
you had any opportunity in in your visit
here to the united states to
get a feel for the anti-war movement
those voices and listen to any of the
discussion on on the floor of the house
or senate i have actually on on c-span
uh i've been watching c-span um i was
stuck in atlanta airport because of
these snows that you've been having
these blizzards in in new york and so i
had uh 24 hours virtually to watch your
um uh what you call a debate it wasn't
really a debate in that people didn't
seem to be answering each other in the
same way that they do in the house of
commons in
in london but your debate on the
non-binding resolution and it seemed to
me
um it seems to me that the
second paragraph of the non-binding
resolution um was
contradictory to the first because you
say uh in the first that the you support
the troops and yet the one thing that
troops want in warfare is actual genuine
support which is reinforcement and the
second paragraph uh completely
contradicted that and so it seemed to me
when that was passed
that um
it's uh
it's a very um it's an amazing thing
really for and for uh america to be able
to do something like that in britain it
wouldn't cross anyone's mind to vote for
a uh to even to even have a resolution
like that
whilst the troops are actually in action
and uh and you know fighting in baghdad
there's simply no way that we would have
uh have had a resolution let alone
passed it in the house of commons that
effectively
undermine the uh the commander on the
ground seems very strange to me new york
hello
yes hi let's have a couple of quick
questions going back to the original
quote of how of fascism and the english
people how we like to know how the
gentleman defines fascism as opposed to
if you ever have recently walked down a
street in london or new york city where
cameras are everywhere and you speak
about the willpower of the people of
course in england that would never
happen because they're creeping towards
the fascism almost faster than we are
here in america as far as a preemptive
cringe to quote the fine gentleman um i
think we have a preemptive cringe
because i think basically the willpower
of the people in america and in britain
have not been listened to and that's
what's going on here is again
for example he defines granada as a war
i think we're looking at police actions
here not wars at all we're looking at
imperialistic police actions and again
going back to my first quest i don't
want to straight away how does he define
fascism and what what does he feel are
the parameters of a society leaning
towards fascism whether they're speaking
english or spanish or chinese andrew
roberts
well i certainly
stick to the classical uh form of
fascism i was talking of course about
the axis fascism of the uh of the second
world war and then the totalitarian
fascism of uh of the um soviet communism
and and now this uh this islamic
fundamentalist and i think that uh for
you to
to say that there are there are uh
cameras as you walk down the street
equals some kind of big brother fascism
is uh frankly absurd i think that uh you
have just heard you've had a vote in
yours we were discussing just now a vote
in your in your national parliament uh
that went against the um the policy of
your administration hardly a fascist
country when that happens
next call is chicago hello chicago
hello andrew thank you for your uh very
uh knowledgeable and uh insightful work
um
i would uh i'd like to uh
go back to a topic that was assessed a
little bit earlier um
and i'd like to get a little more depth
on it uh earlier in the program they
talked about you talked about the
polypanisian war and the spartans versus
the athenians and kind of uh some of the
uh ideological differences which caused
that war and which and i was interested
in how you saw from a historical
standpoint
um some of the overlying themes that
were in that war
as in in light of today with the free
and civilized world and uh dealing with
islamic fundamentalism
um
golly what a what a massive
subject
i think that overall what thucydides was
trying to say in what i um
quoted thucydides for
um was the idea that although there were
four separate conflicts
um actually it was one long war and from
from 431 bc all the way down to 402 bc
and
when one looks at his arguments about
the differences between athens and
sparta
the
spartans being a much more closed
society a society in which
there wasn't any
democratic debate
one that was very much dominated by a a
small elite
versus the athenians who were a much
wider broader
spectrum of people everybody apart from
uh the
medics and helots and slaves had the
vote and so the to the broad
citizenry of athens
had the vote and that i think is
something i.e representative
institutions is something that the
english-speaking peoples did not invent
any more than the invented law that was
invented by the romans or or um
capitalism invented by the dutch or
protestantism invented by the germans um
you name it we haven't actually come up
with the ideas ourselves which have
nonetheless made us great but we have
been able to
use them and when you see in the present
conflict the
dividing lines they're very much the
same because
the
hope for iraq of course and certainly
the actuality back in december 2005 when
10 million people
braved al-qaeda threats to vote
is that we would like to see
a um a
pluralist democracy there whether it's
going to happen in the next five or ten
years i wouldn't like to say fortunately
as i say i'm a historian i don't have to
look into the future but i can see that
we are up against a particularly
loathsome form of totalitarianism and
one that historically the
english-speaking peoples have on three
previous occasions fought face down and
defeated an emailer michael southwood
asked if you could please tell us about
any of the historians who have had the
most influence on your scholarly work
well uh on this book of course it was
winston churchill
who won a nobel prize for literature in
1953
uh just before this uh this his great
history of the english-speaking people's
the full volume work came out and uh
reading that has had a lot of
effect on me but more recently um
thucydides his uh his history of the
peloponnesian war is a very moving and
powerful work uh the works of um a
british historian called kenneth rose
who's a he's a very fine biographer
the historical work of uh alexander
solzhenitsyn of course tied in with uh
with novels but nonetheless he's also
written some pretty important and
serious history has had a major effect
on me and i'm a book reviewer
in london i review i'd say about 50
books a year so
i have a pretty much constant sense of
what is
is being written historically i read a
lot of it and
it's my passion in life otherwise i
wouldn't be doing what i do but those
are the major figures churchill's four
volume readily available
yeah do you know it has been it's one of
those books that's been in
print ever since it was published over
half a century again and it well um
bears re-reading
cleveland ohio go ahead
hi i really appreciate the chance to
talk to a historian i don't have this
chance very often outside of college
circles i have two quick comments and
then a question i'd like to ask
my first comment is that after 9 11 i
never thought i would say this in my
life but i truly
missed richard nixon i was wondering how
mr roberts felt about that my second
comment is i found the analogy between
iraq and germany kind of disturbing
germany was of course the heart of the
matter in world war ii and hitler opened
the door by declaring war on us had he
not done that i'm not sure how things
would have panned out
and if you're going to use that analogy
of germany being the heart of the matter
i would say that maybe saudi arabia is
the heart of the matter here and then
finally my question would be in the
viewpoint of history how do you see this
panning out in the best case scenario
for the western world thank you very
much mr roberts
uh thank you um very much well you've
given us a lot of food for thought there
certainly
um
richard nixon is a uh needless to say a
fascinating historical figure um i uh i
once had an opportunity to meet him and
uh instead i went out and had dinner
with a girl
who i rather
admired at the time and i've i can't
even remember the girl's name now and
i've been kicking myself ever since i'd
love to have i had another chance i'd
have i'd have met mr nixon
i think that um it's very important to
see the differences between what he was
facing in vietnam and and what's going
on in iraq because although an awful lot
of people have claimed to see or believe
they can see um
the similarities between the two i not
only simply just because of terrain but
also because of the
way in which in between 1964 and 1972
north vietnam the majority of north
vietnamese supported the vietcong
the majority of insurgency support the
uh insurgency today so i think they're
very different things and of course the
sheer numbers lost are very different
you have lost 3150
u.s servicemen in iraq whereas in
vietnam it was 55 000 class so i mean
it's only six percent of the of the
numbers i think that um
nixon would perhaps have behaved in
roughly the same way that uh mr bush has
in fact he um
uh was a uh he was a pretty
shrewd old old bloke um nixon i don't
necessarily think that it's a it's a um
a great loss for america that he isn't
around today in fact for your second
question about the uh about the second
world war no of course you're absolutely
right of course uh
um hitler declared war on you and it's
one of the great what ifs of history of
course if he if he hadn't
but i think the um
the
analogy still stands in that
the americans in 1942 appreciated that
he was the
the main danger
and the way in which i i number them in
my uh in my book in one of the later
chapters in my book the way in which um
saddam hussein gave
protection and hosted effectively pretty
much any terrorist organization that
killed americans was something which was
a severe threat to your um to your
prestige in the world and so i think
that he had to be overthrown
and the last point that you make about
looking forward um is uh as i say a um
something that i uh i very fortunately
don't have to do i would hate to be a
politician i think the kind of
responsibilities on them must be
appallingly heavy and it's one of the
great pleasures of being historian that
i don't have to worry about it mr
roberts you say in your book that
the fact that the united states
stayed in iraq
and fought there
while electing the american australian
and british leaders in the process was
further proof to the world that it was
serious about allowing iraqis to decide
their own government for the first time
in over 30 years this was written
obviously before
the elections last year in uh here in
the united states does it still hold
true
do you mean the midterms the midterms
yes
yes it was yeah i had to publish it at
some stage and so uh and so obviously
that uh was done before the midterms oh
yes i think well you you re-elected uh
george bush in uh in 2004
i think that um
you'll probably um have as one of your
um
candidates either
certainly for the republican party
either mr giuliani or mr mccain or mr
romney who i understand
were all of them
in favor of the continuation of the iraq
war so in fact um it's a uh it's a
pretty
um
amazing thing really that a war that can
be
60
or whatever it is maybe more than that
unpopular can nevertheless have um
have serious frontline politicians and
leaders who will
argue in favor of it even though it's
not in their short-term political
interests so to do and i'm i'm i think
that's a pretty good thing for american
democracy to florida next palm coast
florida
yes good afternoon mr roberts
um
after
going through the list of some of your
most avid reader readers including the
president and some of your contributors
mr five and others it's not surprising
to me and to many others
how far from realities
are
your views of the world
but that's your prerogative
um
short invitation come down to the
caribbean speak with the natives from
there
who were under the government of england
for 400 years and see how that can be
related to the concept that you have of
english-speaking countries australia and
new zealand and others and we're not
going to say how axe you how they came
to be because you know that
my question to you is the following
how would you react
if the united states who do no harm
in your views have decided to go into
england and impose whatever decision or
view that they have of the world would
you side it with the americans how you
would oppose them as so many iraqis are
doing today
thank you
um
again a very interesting statement you
made at the beginning about the 400
years of
of british
rule in the west indies if one looks at
the standard of living in the places
that
that were run like anguilla antigua
turks and caicos
uh these
british colonies um british virgin
islands uh they could name any number of
them
and equate them with their neighbours in
cuba of course being won
many in the isthmus and down in in latin
america you equate them with those
countries that haven't had the rule of
law and haven't had
freedom of speech for many years i think
you'll appreciate that actually the
british empire did not do you the kind
of harm that you seem to suggest that it
did
as for the
united states occupying
countries
we had over a million
american troops uh in britain between
1940 and 1945. they then went over to
france they went into
germany and
holland and denmark and they liberated
the continent at the time that they were
originally stationed in britain and then
they left as soon as the job was done
and i believe that that is precisely
what will happen
in the middle east once the job is done
but the fact is that we're still a long
way away from that job being done why
did you uh juxtapose the two photos in
your book of dresden before and after
the bombing of 1945
um because it shows what an absolutely
uh
well there you can see just above
dresden one of the most beautiful 16th
century
german
cities and then the absolute total
devastation of
of below
it was a example really of the
english-speaking people's
real ruthlessness in combat
i think it's very important to remember
and also of course one could do exactly
the same thing with hiroshima
that there is a uh horrific price to be
paid in war um the germans of course
declared
war
and uh and look what happened to dresden
the japanese invaded pearl harbor and
look what happened to hiroshima it is a
um
a terrible thing when a city gets
flattened in the way that both of those
two do and i go into this in some detail
in my book but i justify both the
bombing of dresden on strategic grounds
and of hiroshima on the grounds of
trying to end that war before american
servicemen had to hit the beaches of
mainland japan with the inevitable and
appalling slaughter that would have
taken place
and so i very much wanted to make it
clear that this book is not attempting
in any way to um
to uh whitewash the uh the the dreadful
things that that have happened in the
20th century but
i believe in both of those cases there's
terrible cases they can be justified
morally and
politically and intellectually howard
beach new york
good afternoon
um thank you for coming and i'm enjoying
this uh immensely i have two aspects of
my i have two parts of the question
first i'd like you to consider
in the definition of fascism i always
thought that there had to be a racist
or should be a racist component
to the uh the government philosophy of
the country being called
fascists
as opposed to let's say
russia
and the gulag i didn't think that there
was an over racist component
there were other reasons why people went
to the gulag but it wasn't because you
were a jew or a catholic
and the other aspect of my my question
in 1936
um
germany
reoccupied the rhineland
and i understood that to be a violation
in general terms of the facade treaty
yet i've never been
uh
told or heard of the exact uh
consequences
that were available to the allies
through
um
the body of the versailles treaty what
was the
prerogatives available to them
after i had reoccupied
the rhineland thank you
um
the answer to your first question is
that um yes racism is a uh is a
instinctive natural part of fascism um
when one reads about what the kaiser
wanted to do with the jews gaston
one is reminded needless to say of the
holocaust uh in the second world war one
doesn't need any um further explanation
about the racism but also uh soviet
communists were fabulously racist uh
when one thinks of the way in which they
stalin in particular dealt with the
nationalities seven nationalities i
mentioned them all in my book uh
totaling nearly 30 million people were
um sent were moved from one part of the
country to another
four million of them did go to the gulag
over three million of them died
when one thinks of the way in which the
ukraine was subjected to an entirely
artificial famine one does appreciate
that there was a racist element they
were also incredibly anti-semitic the
the bolsheviks as well
and so um so i would take issue on you
with you uh on that and on your second
point um
i've completely forgotten um i'm sorry
sir what what was this actually he's
gone and i completely forgot it too
let's just move ahead to this drawback
about about two point things i know it
was a very it was a very interesting
subject and it was something that i
would that i was keen i'm terribly sorry
sir i it'll come back it's it's jumped
my mind that's the joy of a 75 minute
program long island new york go ahead
good afternoon
i'd like you to discuss the relationship
between fdr
and churchill
churchill wanted to originally uh
get in uh get invited to the terrain
conference but roosevelt originally
didn't want to invite him the reason was
he was
he figured that churchill was trying to
promote the continuation of the british
empire at the expense of american troops
and use the american army
to control the near east
and also
he was trying to suppress the
development of the u.n when roosevelt
said he wanted to unite korea and
vietnam and put it on the u.n
trusteeship
also
i'd like to ask you a question about
the overthrow the attempted overthrow of
fdr
during the 30s
when the liberty league these are the
same gentlemen dupont ford melon who
were financing the hitler war machine
and weren't even building airplanes in
this country for the purpose of invading
russia
and that was the uh
lord halifax was the architect of the
munich conference for the purpose of
invading russia and using
czechoslovakian gold
uh to pay off these military industrial
complex for the purpose of having a nice
little war
i'd like to
i wonder if i could just just butt in
there because you've brought you've
you've brought up um
you've brought up four completely
separate um and in my view absurd
conspiracy theories i've written a
biography of lord halifax i spent three
years my life studying lord halifax and
he was not um the uh doing the kind of
things that you said he was doing
neither is it true that american
industrialists uh wanted a war to break
out in uh in the late 1930s nor is it
true that they were financing um
the
nazi war machine i really do think it's
very important that when one discusses
serious history that you um look at the
the facts here because i'm afraid that
these are just
conspiracy theories and nothing more
they're not confused sir
can i answer your questions
and i don't believe it i'm sorry to say
that i think that when you have a uh
democratically elected president it
requires a coup d'etat to get rid of him
and if you're telling me that there was
an attempted coup d'etat
i'd like to know a few more details
about it because i frankly don't believe
you this emailer asked can you explain
roosevelt's insistence to churchill that
the british give up a certain colonial
uh controller power in return for
america's help during world war ii
which which one what what's he referring
to can he email back and tell us maybe
so
did roosevelt insist church will give up
some of his uh the of your imperialism
uh in order for to get the american help
during world war i absolutely absolutely
not no the um
the discussion did take place about the
empire at the tehran conference in uh
uh in november 1943 but it was a there
was a straightforward disagreement
between uh roosevelt and churchill
neither man wanted to um or would agree
with the position of the other on
subjects like india and they agreed to
disagree there was absolutely no uh
secret deal in order to get america into
the war america was already in the war
the day that um the japanese bombed
pearl harbor i'm imagining your
gentleman who believes in conspiracy
theories would also tell us that fdr
knew about that before it happened but
i'm afraid once again i simply don't
believe it chicago hello
yes please um thank you for your time mr
roberts
my question is
more like a request for comment um i
i've heard it said in this popular
history i'm sure more so than academics
that england is one of the few empires
that after world war ii actually walked
away from
its imperial authority or power and
obviously it was fading after probably
after world war one to some degree but
england voluntarily chose the path to to
become a european common nation or a
human commonwealth nation i should say
and i wonder do you think that in your
history historian america will
ultimately
walk away from
and it's not the same kind of empire but
the popular culture empire that we have
that is the empire that tends to
allow us to influence a great deal of
the world to economic and social uh
tools or or either directly or
indirectly through our through the
control through cultural effect which is
obviously having such a harsh effect or
having harsh repercussions in parts of
the world
where where they reject western use of
western values
i'm just curious to see your comments
i think that very good question um i
think that overall the world is becoming
so much a smaller place all the time
with communications and
ability to get from a to b so much
faster and the
interaction between
states and the way in which the
environmental issues for example don't
respect any borders
but it would be almost impossible now
for america to choose isolationism which
i think is the is the uh um underlying
crux of your of your very good question
i think that um there might be an awful
lot of people who would want to not
least because of course on your
on your tv shows night after night you
see
these pictures of americans
dying
overseas nonetheless i think that it
would be next to impossible for any
administration be it um hillary clinton
or mr obama or uh or a republican to
actually disengage
um significantly from the affairs of the
rest of the world we are just so tied up
with each other now that i think that it
would be an impossibility and i'm very
pleased about that obviously because i
think that american engagement in the
world is uh overall a um a very good
thing mr roberts is part of your
biography
it's written that in 2005 you chaired
the conservative party's advisory panel
on the teaching of history in schools
what did you find
well we found some rather nerve-wracking
things for example
we found that
23
of our school children believe that the
commander of the american forces in the
american war of independence was denzel
washington
which is a little bit concerning
we managed to find that school children
mix up nelson and napoleon they have
virtually next to no
dates that they know beyond the battle
of hastings in 1066
and they um
think that
that
i think 45 of them think that auschwitz
was a was a battle as opposed to a
extermination camp so i think there's a
very serious problem in the teaching of
history in uh british schools i don't
know what the situation's like here in
america but i think our educational
establishment desperately needs to uh to
look at this problem because otherwise
we're going to have a new generation of
school children who when they get to
voting age are just not going to have
the necessary
background intellectual um knowledge
that it uh requires to make an informed
political decision at the polls and uh
that does worry me a lot it's why i
chaired the panel the conservative party
have yet to act on our recommendations
but
i keep my fingers crossed that they
might this is mr andrews's book
excuse me mr robert's book
it is the history of the english
speaking peoples since 1900 it is
published by harper collins and next
what's the date that you'll be sitting
down to for a meal with the president
uh on on wednesday week
and do you have anything special you
want to say to him
but i'm not going to tell you on c-span
because otherwise he'll get ready with
the answer
thank you very much for joining us today
andrew roberts joining us live from new
york city
thank you very much indeed now we're
going to turn to another segment and the
opportunity for you to talk to author
chalmers johnson this is his book it is
called nemesis the last days of the
american republic and this is the last
in his trilogy
of books that were preceded by the book
blowback and the sorrows of empire
mr johnson appeared on c-span last
summer and in this clip prior to you
meeting him again and getting a chance
to talk to him he talks about the themes
that came up in this trilogy
i read that you were asleep when the
first plane flew into the world trade
center yes here in california well what
how did you find out about it my uh
pardon me my publisher called to talk
about it
and uh we'd by then figured out that it
was a terrorist we'd seen the attacks on
both towers
um but and we talked about it i
discussed it with many other people
around the country in that same day
the question being
who were the terrorists it hadn't
crossed our minds yet that they were
islamic terrorists
the date stood out september 11
september 11th 1973 is a date known to
everyone in latin america that's when
the cia under the orders of richard
nixon overthrew the elected government
of salvador allende in chile and brought
in one of the most odious figures
in the history of american foreign
policy namely general augusto pinochet
so we thirst up maybe chileans maybe
okinawans
maybe greeks probably the most
anti-american democracy on earth they
will never forgive us for the regimen of
the greek colonels put into power by the
uh by the cia until
the colonels went too far and got
themselves thrown out
um
any number of people in uh in central
america uh from the 1980s
you could the list is extensive it could
be guatemalans it could be indonesians
we after all overthrew the government of
indonesia or helped overthrow it and
brought in general sue hartung
so that
our support for
for dictators has been
legendary we used to call ferdinand
marcos
the first president bush who referred to
him as a great democrat well he
certainly was anything but that
so that
it we were interested
certainly i did not believe that we
should have
made it once or tried to see this at
once as a clash of civilizations i don't
think it was my own i believe we've
handled it miserably i believe we'd have
all been much better off if we had
treated it as
the way we would approach organized
crime that is attacks on
innocent civilians
building cases that would stand up in
court
focusing on who did it since we knew who
did it
and going after them instead of this
again war of choice so many of our wars
are wars of choice uh in which
arguably the world couldn't possibly
have been worse off if
george bush and dick cheney had never
heard of iraq
going back to the publisher though
some people's misfortune turned out to
be your fortune
oh
no doubt about that uh and it's an
unfortunate statement i mean that is my
publisher henry holt metropolitan books
was down on west 18th street uh that's
getting fairly close to ground zero and
uh my publisher is a lovely woman she
says i'm getting out of here uh but uh
the uh
it turns out that the first book i
published blowback called the costs and
consequences of american empire it was
2000 year 2000 well before 9 11 had not
received much of a perception in the
united states people were not there nice
abroad but not here
uh
but it then turned out to be a
bestseller and uh right after
almost at once how many different
editions were oh there were at least
eight printings almost in a month uh
after uh after 9 11. and you remember
then that barnes and noble and places
like that had their little little uh
bridge table set up called you know 911
corner or something like that with a few
a few books on it mine was one of them
uh
i
i said to her one day it's a hell of a
way to make a living
and she said yes it is but it's better
to sell them than not sell them and um
so that's essentially what happened
what's what was the impact i mean can
you think back of
once blowback got
uh you know on the best seller list and
all that what kind of feedback did you
get how much of a change did it make did
it have any impact well no it didn't i
mean blowback is a specific cia term
it was first used in the after action
report on our first overthrow of a
democratically elected government namely
the government of iran in in 1953 in
which the the report was not
declassified until the year 2000 in
which the word or the phrase
occurs in there we're going to get some
blow back from this well blowback
doesn't just mean retaliation it means
retaliation for things that we did
abroad
for which that were kept entirely secret
from the american public so that when
the retaliation comes they have no
ability to put it in context to seek
cause and effect
uh that's why we ended up with
the president actually getting away with
a truly absurd question to congress why
do they hate us
you might well have wanted to ask who is
it on earth that doesn't hate us
for good reason i mean often in many
cases very good reason these things were
kept secret from the american public
they're not kept secret from the people
on the receiving end
that when we carry out one of these
so-called clandestine operations so that
it
i was criticized almost once for
suggesting that the united states was in
some way responsible
in some way had was involved in uh what
had happened on september 11 2001. of
course i had argued precisely that that
this was blowback from the largest
single clandestine operation we ever
carried out namely the recruiting arming
and sending into battle of the
mujahideen in afghanistan in the 1980s
against the soviet union we once the
soviet union collapsed
george bush rather famously just walked
away from afghanistan osama bin laden
was an asset and an ally of ours in
those days we worked closely with him we
armed him we certainly knew where his
basic cost was because we had built it
for uh that when
when bill clinton decided to bomb it
with cruise missiles things of this sort
they felt betrayed
let down
it was also foolish on our part that we
never once asked who were these people
we were supporting they were anti-soviet
but
william casey
reagan's cia director was a deeply
devout
another passionately devout catholic who
seemed to believe that the greatest
single force
against communism would be religion
and uh he welcomed
islamic allies never once asking
what about islam what kind of islam
uh whom they might be what they
at any rate they um
osama bin laden and company felt
betrayed by the americans and they got
even they let us know what they were
doing uh they did it quite regularly
they already destroyed two embassies in
east africa they'd bombed the uss cole
uh similar bombings already occurred at
the world trade center uh to be
surprised if what happened on 9 11 seem
to me
is is
incompetent on the part of political
leaders when you
wrote the last line of the sorrows of
empire
you said this
failing such a reform nemesis
the goddess of retribution and vengeance
punisher of pride in hubris
waits impatiently for her meeting with
us
i get a sense you might even be writing
your next book named nemesis the third
book is done and it's called nemesis the
subtitle is the last days of the
american republic it's to say i don't
see the way out any longer that
the congress or that is a separation of
powers is clearly broken down
the president has achieved virtually
anything he might have wanted to do in
that area i don't think the political
system will save us
uh
the military could conceivably take over
they have threatened this but i don't
think so for
reasons that i think pretty obvious
above all the fact that
no enlisted only enlisted men have been
convicted in the
prison torture scandals none of the
officers the result is that within the
armed forces today enlisted men are
extremely sensitive to illegal orders
uh saying you're going to take the rap
for it not us
there's no more illegal order than to
take over congress
uh so that the the officers i just don't
think believe the enlisted men would
follow their orders today
so my wife keeps saying to me come up
with something optimistic and i come up
with bankruptcy it's
that looks like might be the thing that
will bring the republic to an end
you know that there are people watching
right now that say that guy's a wacko
i mean that's the extreme of it but it's
like the conspiracy theorist and all
that where did you start having this
conversation in say 1985 and i said to
you four years from now the soviet union
will disappear you thought that's not
really a reliable analyst uh well it's
gone it's disappeared it's russia today
is a much smaller place than the soviet
union was empires go very very rapidly
and we're getting extremely overextended
really very serious thin ice that's
reported this is not terribly novel with
me right now a lot of people know this
understand it and are worried about the
trend of events why does this happen in
your opinion what's
the start of all this militarism
primarily that is to say well it's
imperialism which
as its inescapable accompaniment is
militarism uh and that this begins to
invoke the earliest warnings we have
about the threats to republican
government after all george washington's
farewell address still read in congress
each session
warns against the greatest threat to
liberty is standing armies and it's the
particular threat to
republican liberty he meant by this that
it would destroy
the separation of powers on which the
structure was was set up it would
move power toward the president move it
away from congress and the courts
that seems to me today obvious then of
course then
the equally famous warning by dwight
eisenhower as he left office in 1961
where he invented the phrase
military-industrial complex
and it's worth reading because it's so
strident this was not a diplomatic
remark at all by an outgoing president
he warns in the harshest possible terms
of what's likely to befall us
from uh
spending as much as we do
on uh on military affairs and
we can talk about that too how much we
spent but it's i think this is the
combination it's the same sort of thing
that happened to the roman republic
which one mentions only because the
roman republic was so much a model for
uh
uh for madison and the other authors of
the constitution in ideas of how to this
was the first functioning democratic
republic that we know of
we used and it took many ideas from them
and what happened to them they rather
thoughtlessly acquired themselves an
empire
which then required
huge standing armies instead of the
citizen armies that had prevailed in the
early days of the republic
uh and uh
and it
overwhelmed their government
uh leading then finally to
populist military figures of which of
course julius caesar is the model uh and
and led to his assassination
uh in the senate but then you get on to
more ruthless figures young octavian
who decides to make himself a god
augustus caesar
miss chalmers johnson from last may at
his home in california this is his new
book nemesis the last days of the
american republic and mr johnson joins
us live from california good afternoon
thanks very much
let me uh ask you first um
when you
finished writing this book did you feel
like you had wrapped everything up that
you wanted to in the trilogy
i suppose in the trilogy yes i mean the
book is a
serious warning
to my fellow citizens that we are
approaching the tipping point that uh
they should at least even if they don't
care about this it's time for them to
understand what they're about to lose
the fact that once they lose it it won't
be coming back uh after the roman
republic lost its uh
its democracy it didn't come back for
well over a thousand years
uh and so that yes this says essentially
what i believe needed to be said again
let me stress this was an inadvertent
trilogy i didn't set out to write three
books to do a little sort of mini gibbon
on the decline and fall of the american
empire
i began with a study of what i thought
were going to be the consequences of our
clandestine activities abroad
i then moved on
to the size of our military empire
around the world uh it was then
after after the
disaster of iraq and afghanistan that i
then went on to say we're uh moving very
very rapidly toward in the roman
direction and we know what that means
let's open up our phone lines again and
invite you to join us here is uh how you
can join us if you are a republican
202-737-001
for democrats 202-737-002
and for independence
202-628-0205 mr johnson is going to be
with us for about an hour to take your
phone calls we'll also take your emails
you can email us at booktv
cspan.org
what's been the reaction to your book i
know it's just been at a short period of
time
well it's just been out a little bit
more than two weeks but it's been really
quite fantastic uh the uh i am surprised
compared with the soros of empire how uh
much more receptive the american public
is today
to the combination of assaults that are
now uh on top of us i mean when last
week the president sends to congress a
defense budget that's larger than all
other defense budgets on earth and
that's defense in quotes uh it's really
just the formal appropriation bill uh
people are beginning to be aware that we
are toying with bankruptcy if uh
if the middle eastern countries from
which we uh purchase oil decided to
start financing uh asking for payment in
euros instead of dollars the american
dollar would collapse almost at once and
we would be in bankruptcy within
24 hours this emailer asked do you think
that other countries are tired enough of
u.s imperialistic actions to throw a
concerted effort spark to spark a run on
the us dollar as retaliation
yes i think they are that is to say
i'm sorry to say that when the u.s goes
down it will not produce a great deal
more sorrow than when the ussr went down
uh the uh it's gone on too long now
there's too much incompetence arrogance
exactly the sort of thing that invites
nemesis uh that displayed in our
government and uh i don't believe that
the rest of the world is particularly
reassured
by the election of democrats mrs pelosi
is surely a very pleasant person but
our government has we've had it here all
along in the constitution we have a way
of dealing
with uh unsatisfactory political leaders
with those that say uh that uh that lied
to us into a war
that
undercut our civil liberties through
devices like
denouncing the uh the geneva treaties or
the treatment of prisoners of war and
things of that sort it's called
impeachment when the democrats come into
into control of congress and say on the
very first day impeachment's off the
table
my inclination is saying of that case
the republic is probably off the table
too
would you did you watch any of the
debate over this past weekend
yeah
was there anything there that uh
that
gave you any
any uh
point to to feel any better about the
whole situation
what we're talking about is the need to
reconstitute the constitutional system
what is broken is we have devices for
preventing what has happened in this
country uh for preventing the excessive
secrecy that dominates the defense
budget the central intelligence agency
things of this sort we have devices for
uh
not things that just have happened you
know in the past few days the uh the
attorney general uh courtier from texas
uh of president bush has decides to fire
u.s attorneys around the country who uh
seem to have defied the white house's
will uh and things of this sort and uh
we need to uh
we need to reconstitute
the uh the constitutional form of
government this obviously would not be
easy it's very hard to imagine any
president who could stand up to the
vested interests of the military
industrial complex or of the secret
intelligence agencies which are
virtually without any form of oversight
they are the president's private army uh
but what would be required is
mobilization of inattentive citizens to
what they're about to lose i don't think
the electoral system is likely to
do that there is signs of people waking
up but it's very late in the day
uh this is such a large and diverse
country i find it extremely difficult to
imagine the mobilization of really a
significant
uh
force among the people uh they are not
well informed uh it's very hard to get
information from network television when
one realizes that once that its purpose
is simply advertising revenue when
rupert murdoch contemplates buying a
third of the los angeles times you know
we're in trouble uh
so that uh yes i heard the debate and i
thought it was a long long overdue
that the more serious problem
seems to me that the american public
after the election of 2000 could claim
that uh what george bush and dick cheney
did uh
it was not
not what we authorized we they didn't
win the popular vote they were appointed
by a 5-4 decision of the supreme court
but after the election of 2000 bush won
by over three and a half million
votes even including some voter fraud in
in ohio uh the that is to say his wars
became our wars in the eyes of the rest
of the world this occurred after abu
ghraib after the disgrace of the u.s
armed forces
and not holding a single person from
rumsfeld on down accountable uh
that's why i say i think it's uh it's
very chancy today to imagine uh how this
uh
how this could be changed could be
turned around chalmers johnson our guest
he's in san diego today live uh on
c-span 2 book tv first call for him is
chicago hello hello you're on the air
mr johnson what do you envision of a
future america i
think very much like you do and
i'll keep it brief have a great day i
wish you would send me some san diego
sunshine
we do have some nice sunshine today
the
bankruptcy would not mean the literal
end of the united states it would be uh
like what happened in germany in 1923 in
china in 1948 in argentina in 2001 and
two it would mean a catastrophic
lowering of our level of living of uh
learning to uh
to
how to behave in the world again
and we would go on it would be as i say
very much like argentina discouraging
there would be a howling recession for
about a year the rest of the world would
emerge from it we would take a very long
time to emerge from it um
a
man i admire a good financial analyst
marshall auerbach has referred to the
united states economy as a
blanche dubois economy that's referring
to the name of the leading character in
tennessee williams play a streetcar
named desire you'll recall that blanche
ends uh
the play by being dependent upon the
kindness of strangers uh that's us we're
dependent on the kindness of
of the ministries of finance of china
and japan right now and uh they have
less and less incentive to be interested
in
in being kind to us copley ohio go ahead
hi this is james and copley
go ahead sir hi mr johnson
hi are you familiar with economist kevin
phillips and his book wealth and
democracy
well i know i mean i can't say that i
know it intimately
but certainly i do know kevin phillips i
was quite interested
there's similar themes in what you're
talking about today
right
oh i think we have known this has been
coming for a long time i mean standard
economic theory would tell you that oh
when you've got a current account
deficit of say three percent of gdp
you're in serious trouble well we've got
a current account deficit that's six
percent of gdp of gross domestic product
uh we have we have the world's we are
the world's leading
debtor nation uh we uh and in the
meantime we don't manufacture much
anymore our auto industry is marching
resolutely toward the same graveyard in
which uh
american consumer electronics are buried
uh we only think we really do well is
is arms manufacturing that is we and
that's
in nemesis i refer to this and study it
as a form of military keynesianism as a
way of artificially propping up our
economy providing jobs by keynesianism i
mean of course i'm referring to john
maynard keynes
the great english economist of the 1930s
who advocated counter-cyclical spending
in order to put money back in the
out
hands
of
uh uh uh men and women the uh military
keynesianism works in a different way i
mean we've spent well over five trillion
dollars by the way on on nuclear weapons
uh since uh uh since the 1940s
fortunately we never ever used one but
it's a perfectly good example of
keynes's idea of we might have to uh
bury money and disuse mines and then pay
workers to go in and dig it up again uh
the uh it's about about as useless we do
it again today i mean that is to say
what we call the defense budget uh is
not the defense of the united states
it's uh we've had to create a new
department the department of homeland
security concerned with that it's
concerned with lunatic investments in
outer space weapons
in
burying scarecrows in alaska and calling
them anti-missile missiles
the they don't work we know they don't
work and we don't care that they don't
work the uh uh that's not the purpose
the important thing about them is
they're expensive i mean you see it in
this country this penetration into our
democracy of the military-industrial
complex that that
eisenhower so powerfully warned us
against we see it in the uh
it's perfectly logical for the secretary
of defense to close military bases that
some go back to the civil war and are no
possible use to us every time he
proposes it
every community affected
rises in
moral outrage preachers give sermons
editorialists write in newspapers uh
unions demonstrate save our base save
our jobs the uh uh this is the military
industrial complex understands this on a
big project like oh the b2 bomber
they do everything in their power to put
a piece of that in as many
constituencies as possible so that if
a member of congress
happened to get the idea that maybe we
didn't need another weapon of mass
destruction and wanted to vote against
it the military industrial complex can
make sure that he pays a heavy price at
the next election
i live in the 50th district of
california we have just made ourselves
famous by
having our republican congressman go to
prison for eight and a half years as the
most thoroughly bribed congressman
that's randy duke cunningham in the
history of our republic of course the
people bribing him were defense
contractors and he was parading himself
always as a stalwart veteran who was an
ace from the vietnam war uh but he was
now then just last week
we've uh the the
federal attorney in san diego has
indicted the number three man in the fbi
uh who's also a friend of cunningham's
for uh for taking bribes uh this is the
the
but their bribes from the from the
military industrial complex that's what
has to be brought under control
to uh to begin to
control to produce oversight on
unauthorized power remember 40 percent
of the defense budget is black nobody
sees it it's you can't do oversight if
you can't see it all of the budgets of
the secret intelligence agencies are
secret and always have been
all of this uh information is on page
139 of chalmer johnson's book nemesis in
which he has a chart on the numbers of
military bases in foreign countries by
size and by military service showing
between 2002 and 2005 the changes that
have happened with the total number uh
at the end of 2005 being uh 737 has it
uh that's right has it changed a lot
since then do you know
well we don't know i mean this these
numbers come from the base structure
report which is an annual inventory not
classified
that the
pentagon puts out on property it owns
around the world uh these are real bases
too don't uh you'll hear defenders of
the military establishment tell you that
oh this is preposterous that i'm
counting uh marine guards at embassies i
guarantee you we don't have any 700
embassies around the world these are
real bases uh
the uh take an example the southernmost
island of japan okinawa has 37 american
military bases that's
including 17 000 marines of the third
marine division the largest uh military
installation in east asia kadena air
force base where we just flew f-22
raptors in that's the latest and most
expensive of our
airplanes that were designed to fight a
war with the soviet union even though
it's been gone for the 15 years it's uh
uh
the the the base world is our empire
that what i
many times people wonder is this really
an empire we don't have colonies is
usually the phrase well of course the
british french dutch portuguese they did
have colonies and they did ultimately
get rid of them but i'm thinking of an
empire much more like that of the soviet
union
with its satellites in eastern europe
bases in these countries
massive forces on their borders
governments that are uh
flunkies are satellites of
of moscow
that's our form of empire today it's
there to exercise hegemony over the rest
of the world we could very easily do
comfortably
without uh 700 of them 37 would do just
fine you're right we're not talking
we're not talking about isolationism
either you write in the book that
americans cannot truly appreciate the
impact of our bases elsewhere because
there are no foreign military bases
within the united states we have no
direct experience of such unwelcome
features of our military encampments
abroad as the networks of brothels
around their main gates the nightly bar
brawls the sexually violent crimes
against civilians and the regular hit
and run accidents these together with
noise and environmental pollution are
constant blights that we inflict on
local populations to maintain our
lifestyle people who live near our bases
must also put up with the racial and
religious insults that our culturally
ignorant high-handed troops often think
is their right to dish out
that's pretty strong
that's pretty strong but i wrote it i i
stick by it i think it's true i'm
professionally i'm a specialist in uh
the politics and economies of east asia
china japan the two koreas
i had never actually been in
okinawa even though i've devoted my life
to the study of japan i've never been in
okinawa until 1996 when i was invited by
the governor to come and uh attend a
conference with his officials about a
very serious incident that had occurred
uh the year before two marines and a
sailor abducted a 12 year old girl beat
her and raped her and left her badly
wounded it produced the greatest
demonstrations
uh in an ally of ours uh since the jeff
japan america security treaty was
was signed
i this led me to begin to investigate
this case and cases similar to it at
that time by the way the uh
the commandant of u.s forces in japan at
the time was general richard myers who
later became george bush's uh
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff at
that time the rate of sexually violent
crimes committed by americans in okinawa
this is a close ally bear in mind
leading to court martial which is
important meaning also the woman came
forward and testified in cultures like
japan uh generally speaking the women
would not do such a thing the rate was
two per month
uh it had been that since the battle of
okinawa in 1945 i'm not
joking here about what we asked others
to put up with and and i know full well
what the attitudes of americans would be
if they were treated in the same manner
one must understand imperialism is not
sweet
british imperialism roman imperialism
imperialism is a form of tyranny it does
not seek the consent of the governed it
does not offer respect for the consent
of the governed it is a form of
domination back to the phones oklahoma
city oklahoma go ahead
hi mr johnson a big fan and i think
unfortunately you will be a prophet uh
however uh last spring seymour hirsch
wrote a series of articles uh suggesting
uh intense discomfort and even a level
of defiance among the joint chiefs and
other high-ranking military officials
regarding a first strike against iran do
you think in the event of george bush
ordering a strike against iran without
congressional authorization as he
apparently sees his powers allowing him
to do this do you think there's any hope
of high-ranking military commanders
rejecting such an order
well of course this is pure speculation
i have enormous admiration for seymour
hirsch going back to his work on milai
and uh and the
really amazing record that he has put
out that's the kind of journalism we
actually need and we get so little of it
as for
resistance by the armed forces i'm by
the high command
i'm sorry to say i don't see it i think
that
then most of the grumbling we've heard
is from
two three stars very comfortably retired
living in uh in arlington virginia uh
that on active duty to actually uh
cut into their perks that way i think it
would be very very unlikely uh there and
that the uh
clearly they're recognizing they're
saying that the
madness has got to stop
that
iraq has proved to be the most
disastrous occurrence in the history of
american foreign policy and it will
continue
giving as long as we're there uh
and that
we see
the same kind of fantasies from
the american enterprise institute the uh
neoconservatives about
iran today
that
it is possible to imagine that these
people might
attempt a unilateral unilateral strike
but again let me just remind you iran is
a country not a small country it is
totally surrounded by nuclear powers by
the soviet union by india and pakistan
by israel and by the united states with
now two
full-blown carrier task forces in the
persian gulf and allegedly two more on
the way
the only way to defend yourself against
that kind of force is to go nuclear is
to develop a nuclear weapon
to say as churchill did in 1940 if
you've got to go take one with you
that'll stop us that's i mean that is
the reason that we did attack saddam
hussein is we knew full well he didn't
have weapons of mass destruction if he
had we'd approached him the same way we
do north korea or iran with much greater
diffidence i think the truth of the
matter is we must learn to live with a
nuclear-powered iran
it can easily be deterred there is
nothing easier on earth than to detect
where a missile
is launched from
the iranians know that but they do need
to cause some sobriety in washington dc
and tel aviv on
on these issues uh and
i'm not alarmed by it i am alarmed by
the leader of iran i think he certainly
shoots with his mouth
but
we in america have no right to make that
complaint about others thomas johnson
taught for 30 years at
the campuses uh of the university of
california both in berkeley and san
diego he has uh been gone from those
campuses now for 15 years and he is an
author of i have 16 books here is that
correct
it's around there i'm not absolutely
certain anymore next we go to tampa
florida hello
hello uh mr chambers i have two
questions uh do you think there
eventually will be impeachment
proceedings against uh president bush
and if a democrat wins in 2008 do you
believe there will be an end to the war
in iraq and more progress towards a
palestinian-israeli resolution
i'm sorry to say that i doubt
that
the congress has the will
to uh
do what the constitution calls uh calls
on it to do the congress is an almost
total failure uh we don't explain it
it's easier to explain bushes and
chinese megalomania than it is to
explain why the congress has failed us
so badly that it uh simply has gone
along with the imperial presidency and
uh and
it's almost totally out of control
but i don't see the signs that congress
would would do that as for
a change in parties
in 208
uh
of course it's likely to occur but
whether it will make any difference is
entirely another matter in a certain
sense i can't think of anything that
depresses me more than the thought of
one more dynastic cycle of uh bushes and
clintons uh this time jeb and hillary uh
the uh
i
it's that's not what we need but again
as i said earlier i don't see how
given this the way our government has
evolved the power of secrecy in our
government today it's it's the misuse of
secrecy the inability of a citizen even
if they wanted to to play the citizen
role as envisaged by benjamin franklin
they unless they are
very astute users of the internet
they're simply not going to be able to
have the information to be aware of what
is uh going on so that i don't see uh
that uh
bringing to power of the democratic
party is going to make that much
difference uh unless it is spurred by a
so far not yet discernible genuine
renaissance of opinion on the part of
the public and a desire to recreate the
genuine american republic who did you
vote for in 2004
in 2004 i voted for uh
kerry
and it was was he your favorite
candidate at the time
he certainly was not my favorite
candidate uh i tried to remember my
favorite candidate was the former uh
government of vermont what is his name
now the head of
the democratic party
i had his bumper strip on my car but
ever since the press killed him off for
yelling too loud one day howard dean
howard dean you're right that was my guy
san antonio go ahead
hello go ahead you're on the air uh yeah
so i just wonder about the idea what you
thought the basic idea that bush had
that uh
democracy was the best way to fight
the war on terror
that uh you're dealing with people who
want to sort of impose a 12th century
model that uh suppresses the women and
they view the values of the west as
being uh
hostile to that i mean once their women
are exposed to our values
they won't know part of that
virtual slavery over there and also
concerning the war in iraq if we were
winning this thing we really wouldn't be
having this discussion uh
if we had gone in there like we went
into japan after world war ii with just
sort of overwhelming forces
and say that this you will be a
democracy you will give the vote to
women
uh we wouldn't be having this discussion
i fear that a lot of liberals have so
much invested
in our failure in iraq and the failure
of the economy that
they go after bush because
they feel they're superior and that bush
doesn't have the intellectual
ability to govern and that it's some
sort of cosmic injustice that
such
backward people have power and
also because he actually does
believe in his judeo-christian values
let me respond by saying you have many
assumptions that i don't agree with i
think their american assumptions and
that they have been fatal to us let's go
back to this issue of clash of
civilizations
and the threat of our values
within two weeks after 9 11 osama bin
laden our former asset and
an ally in afghanistan the kind of rich
pious saudi arabian you would have
expected in say the first bush
administration to probably have met as a
house guest of the president at
kennebunkport maine that he uh
went public on why they had attacked on
9 11. he didn't say anything at all
about disliking our values our wealth
our way of life or anything else he
listed three reasons for warfare against
the united states that is asymmetric
warfare as the pentagon called it the
first was that after the first gulf war
we had put
u.s troops in saudi arabia to defend the
regime that is responsible for
the security of the two most sacred
sites in islam mecca and medina he
resented that did not believe it was
necessary i don't believe it was
necessary either if you wanted to defend
saudi arabia it is surrounded with water
that's what we have a navy for we
certainly didn't need ground forces it
was a stupid idea the second point he
made was that the americans will never
know peace so long as they are allied
with the radical zionists uh against the
palestinian people no one doubts the
need to protect the ultimate integrity
of of israel
most all of us doubt the need to
continue the expansion of israel into
the territories of the people who were
displaced virtually by ethnic cleansing
in the in the creation of israel third
and something again that americans
simply totally forget
osama bin laden mentioned a half million
iraqi children who had died during the
1990s as a result of what president
clinton himself had called the most
rigorous campaign of sanctions ever
carried out against another country now
i mention these things not to say that i
agree with them or that they are but
these are causes belly these are not
high flown statements about uh clash of
civilizations these are uh reasons for
going to war because you've got serious
grievances i think it is uh that it has
to say that we have been out promoting
democracy as an answer to uh
to terrorism strikes me as simply absurd
uh moreover we didn't do that until uh
we got bogged down in iraq and bush gave
up on his original ideas of what he
wanted to do
and
pull this old chestnut out that we're
promoting democracy you can't promote
democracy at the point of a bayonet
that it's that is to say the picture
that the americans see most of their
troops in iraq is some burly guy kicking
me in the door going in and pointing an
assault rifle at a cowering woman in
women and children on the floor and
so they start hollering democracy in a
language nobody understands that's not
influencing anybody including uh iraqi
women so that i i simply disagree with
the premise
that this was a clash of civilizations i
believe we handled it mishandled it
terribly on september 12 2001 the day
after 9 11 the world balance of power
had not changed one iota the united
states was still the
most dominant power on earth and had
tremendous responsibilities for the
regime of international law and
everything else that we had helped
create throughout the cold war instead
we made massive mistakes mistakes that
also look like they were simply
operating to opportunistic mistakes of
bush and cheney that is we started
calling it a
war on terrorism we should have called
it an emergency we should have treated
it as uh as we would treat organized
crime that is uh
uh illegal activities against innocent
bystanders we should have chased them
down we could have done so if we kept
our eye on the ball arrested them
brought them back to the united states
tried them in our courts without any
hint of torture uh convicted them and
executed them that we would have
retained in that case our
high ground as the victim in 9 11
we would have retained the support of
our allies around the world
instead what we did has led to the point
where we are today virtually detested
everywhere that the the pew research
institute which is done by far the
largest poll ever on attitudes in the
islamic world uh asked thousands of
people from morocco to indonesia
name something about the united states
that you admire and the answer by over
90 was nothing in particular cambridge
ohio
hi um thank you for your books mr
johnson i haven't read them yet but i
look forward to it it's
great to be able to hear you today
my question is about your comment about
we the united states
could go bankrupt now that might be one
way that it would
slide for a while at least
and and i'm curious
about what you might have to say about
it a couple of things
first
and i'll make try to make a brief just
first would be during the vietnam war
um uh lyndon johnson um took away the
capital reinvestment tax credit
uh which uh corporations had used you
know
and uh then we saw the steel industry go
etc
and then we also had the environmental
aspect which was an important one but it
also was costly it is costly
secondly during the same period we have
the
emerging global economy
and we have corporations becoming global
and
their allegiance is no longer to
our nation or any particular nation
a reporter at the washington post wrote
a couple of books morton mintz he wrote
america inc and world inc i don't know
whether you're familiar with those or
not
back in the in the 60s 70s
and um there's an interesting little
quote i once read in a nice little
history of nantucket when thomas
jefferson was president
though whalers on nantucket petitioned
the new u.s gov the fairly new us
government during the world war 1812 to
let them sell their whale oil to england
while we were at war with her because
that was their customer
and
tj is supposed to have said something
like to a merchant
there is no
you know national allegiance that it's
where he makes his money
well there's nothing new under the sun
about any of that i mean that's part of
reality
i'm going to leave it at that thank you
mr johnson any reaction to his two
points
well simply what we're referring to here
is something that in any american
universities economics department is
anathema it's called industrial policy
it's what has made japan the world's
second richest nation it is what
motivates the chinese government today
it does mean that you are responsible
for the industrial structure of your uh
of your society that it is uh i mean
i've often put it this way if you were
really an american imperialist you would
have admired bill clinton a lot more
than george bush because bill clinton
was a good strategist he disguised where
he was going he put it under the cover
of allegedly technological ineluctable
forces called
globalization there's nothing
ineluctable about globalization as
anybody in the third world will tell you
uh the uh
globalization so long as we profit from
it the uh uh
it's
those were the days in which i was
strongly advocating that we in the
united states should learn from japanese
industrial policy should learn why the
the japanese after all they have one of
the world's greatest steel industries
there's not an ounce of steel ore in all
of japan
they had to plot that out and do it
we've failed to do that we continue to
be as ideologically written as the
former soviet union was in gorbachev's
time on the eve of its collapse and uh
that's the i think what's being referred
to here the but we continue to do it in
the meantime some americans as we read
about income distribution some few
americans are getting extremely wealthy
santa barbara california hello
good afternoon mr johnson um i have two
questions both uh related to each other
the first is as well if you read the new
article in the vanity fair magazine by
craig unger from the wonderful world
folks who brought you a rag i recommend
you read it and
everyone else in the audience reads it
the second question has to do with that
um has to do with these think tanks and
these ideologues like members of the
american enterprise institute
project for the
new american century
and all these other think tanks um
i'm wondering why these ideologues who
were so
stubborn in their own thinking ideology
and i think it's very dangerous and
they're the ones who were leading us
down this horrendous path in iraq and
the
future horrendous path in iran which i'm
afraid of
um why isn't the media giving any
attention to these members of pnac or
aei
or why isn't congress or the senate
doing congressional hearings on these
think tanks and all the power and
influence they have
you've just identified the failings that
i'm talking about first of all i haven't
read the article in vanity fair there's
an awful lot to read these days i will
take a look at it
sounds good it's a good magazine
i think the
the failures of the press are huge and i
mentioned some of the reasons for them
already
they've been co-opted into the
establishment uh they do the bidding of
washington d.c the whole country has
potomic fever in a way
that is simply uh unimaginable
in our original constitution i mean the
president goes around saying i am the
decider i can't think of anything more
constitutionally ludicrous than to call
the president the decider the system the
system was set up in such a way that
there's a lot of deciders just as in the
old roman republic two consuls
either of which could veto each other
we're supposed to
to be a country that does not have kings
and dictators that we have to reconcile
with each other now then to ask me
though
where do these ideas that have been
propagated so powerfully by
think tanks in washington dc paid for by
extremely wealthy right wing
trust funds and
private families that have
used their money to impose their
opinions on the country
i
i would think that the first great
source of error here was the uh
what we did and thought after the
collapse of the soviet union i was a
cold warrior i believed the
soviet union was a menace i still
believe it was a menace
i was a consultant to the office of
national estimates of the central
intelligence agency many people have
asked me why did you
change your mind so radically well
i usually quote john and may john
maynard keynes on that when he was
accused of inconsistency he said when i
get new information i i
take a new position what sir do you do
with new information but the new
information we got was the collapse of
the soviet union in 1991
eliminated at once the justification for
our massive global military deployments
and uh and
preparedness for war with the ussr the
reaction of our country was
instantaneously to find a replacement
enemy
china terrorism
drug lords
even instability anything to keep
financing the military-industrial
complex we concluded from the collapse
of the soviet union something
disastrously wrong namely that we won
the cold war
the soviet union and the united states
both lost the cold war they lost it for
similar reasons the imperial overstretch
ideological rigidity inability to reform
russia was always a poorer country than
we were therefore it is taken they went
first we're beginning to catch up with
them now finally
facing the same sort of things it was
hubristic it was the sort of thing that
attracts the attention of nemesis to
start saying that we were phrases like
the lone superpower we began almost
really to go mad we began to think that
we were a new rome that we could do
anything we wanted to do that we were
beyond good and evil and that's when you
began to see wolfowitz in the first book
administration was already writing for
the department of defense that we need
to create a structure in which no one on
earth friend or foe can ever even
imagine imagine challenging us
militarily well this is
so unrealistic so out of touch with the
world
that we're
paying the price for it now the uh
that's where i
why the press didn't pursue it uh i
don't still fully understand i don't
know why there aren't more seymour
hirsch's and others like that in the
country today that was
the first amendment to the constitution
was not written to protect people's
people's magazine it was written with a
specific idea that the free press would
use its power to penetrate the secrecy
of the bureaucracy and expose it to
daylight it doesn't do that job instead
is much more likely to cover it up
but
your question is just simply a sign of
the
of the peril that approaches us north
branch new jersey
mr johnson i'm a refugee from communism
and
a conservative republican
but when a group of communists led by
bettina absecker that i knew from new
york
started the fsm and called for
meaningful dialogue i and talking
service for political action fully
supported that because we felt that
america needed to revolutionize itself
out of the position it was in coming
into the 60s
now i'm a scientist as a scientist i
have to distinguish between information
that is sufficient to explain things and
information that is necessary now much
of what you say is quite sufficient to
explain things but what is necessary and
you have disregarded
is that george bush is really
representing the interests of a bunch of
speculators who produce nothing and
expect to make a fortune out of it and
part of that fortune goes to pay your
pension and mine and we are doing it on
the back of our kids and because a bunch
of old farts like us are deceiving
ourselves and exploiting the situation
because of people like us who say ain't
my kid going to iraq and we have this
disconnect syndrome all of this can
happen and i haven't
seen you hit at the american culture of
middle age which is either
believing in uh in the bible because
it's so much easier than calculus or or
these things that's what makes it
necessary for a person like bush to be
president everything you've said makes
it sufficient but the necessary fact is
that we as a nation we as a people have
aged and rotted and it becomes claudic
and we are dying not economically but we
are literally dying from a cerebral
dysfunction thomas johnson
um thank you for the invitation it
probably would take the next book my
wife has already said another book i'm
75 years old another book probably leads
to divorce uh so i probably won't take
you up on it but i do agree that
that there is a very considerable
cultural dimension
at work here and the fault lies not with
george bush
or with his cronies but it lies with
ourselves that
one of the oddest things in our culture
is when
in 1973 we discovered that in the
vietnam war
the draft had been applied inequitably
christian abbey's book working class war
is really a wonderful study of the fact
that uh
you uh if you could remain in yale there
was not a chance of you ever getting
shot at or anything happening to you you
could look at the career of dick cheney
uh and how astutely he avoided the draft
having discovered that the draft was
inequitable we didn't decide to make it
equitable we decided to abolish it now
that changes things at once the armed
forces of the united states are no
longer citizen armies with people in the
armed forces because they know why
they're there it was an obligation of
citizenship they get extremely
interested in whether their officers are
any good or they know what they're doing
whether there's a strategy to what's
going on and they can show it as they
did in vietnam the uh
you uh you
these are the sorts of issues that seem
to be we are paying for today service in
the armed forces today is a career
choice uh often a career choice made by
people in our society uh who
face blocks and cul-de-sacs uh that's
why until
five years into iraq uh the uh the army
had a uh considerably higher proportion
of african americans than exist in the
uh in the population why 50 of the women
in the armed forces come from national
minorities uh things of this sort should
we do something about that yes i think
so if we're going to maintain an army
this size i'd certainly still rather see
it be
like the old
roman armies before the creation of
standing armies citizen armies who went
off to battle when called because of a
national emergency
we didn't do that
we knew what we were doing uh and uh
we're paying the consequences today by
having an armed force that is
increasingly separate from our society
the campuses are quiet i know why
they're quiet of course
nobody is at risk
san francisco
hello you're on the air great okay
you said that the americans need to wake
up or else we're going to lose it what
is it that we're going to lose it
or what is it that we're going to lose
how can we prevent from losing it
and also
you're giving you so much information
that um
do you ever uh
fear
um or do you ever get threats on your
life because
this is a lot of information that i
think the
secretary
government
would try to keep you from
helping the americans thank you very
much
well i'll probably reserve
uh my escape route uh and not reveal it
over the air uh the uh
uh
the point that you're making is the one
that i'm trying to get at what are we
going to lose
we have a democracy we're proud of our
democracy we love it we flourish in it
uh its greatest enemy is imperialism
the intervening variable as
i discussed in the interview at the
beginning uh with mr lam
of
c-span uh is militarism is the huge
interest in militarism in the the fact
that
i mean it was indeed george washington
who said the greatest enemy of
republican little r republican liberty
is standing armies it moves power to
washington it moves taxes to washington
it creates vested interest in service in
the armed forces these are things that
we should recognize and deal with
the much greater warning was that of
eisenhower of course in in 1961
and i'm saying
what we are today moving thoughtlessly
in a direction much like that of the
roman republic not like that of england
after world war ii deciding
in order to hang on to india there's
only one way to do it they've done it
enough in the past and that's
administrative massacres in india
the
british began to realize to keep their
empire they would have to turn
themselves into a domestic tyranny they
chose instead
to keep their freedom
and to give up their empire i believe
that's what we should be debating in
america today
very very vigorously and very rapidly
but again as for personal threats no the
truth of the matter is i've not
experienced personal threats and
in some ways i uh
i am invulnerable as my i've had a lot
of graduate students over the years
in the university of california they
usually say to me look you're
invulnerable you're retired you've got a
good pension uh if you won't speak up
don't expect us to and i sympathize with
them because i know that the boards of
regents can be very vindictive very
unpleasant to people who say things that
appear to
cross the interest of the ruling class
but no i'm not terribly worried about it
uh and i uh
and i intend to run to write it out but
i do have to say that i occasionally end
speeches by saying if you have a little
money ahead and you've got a couple of
young children
it wouldn't be the craziest investment
to buy that condo in vancouver
san diego
hi dr johnson um
my question is you mentioned earlier
about
the country the united states going
toward bankruptcy
i'm looking at two main
events of history
the fighting of world war ii to the nth
degree that the united states finally
chose to do
and afterwards the rebuilding of the
some of the
destroyed areas through the marshall
plan my contention is
if we looked at man-made budgets we
would have never done either one of them
another contention of mine is we haven't
ever and never could possibly pay off
either one of those things
so i'm looking at the third point here
to respond where we are at today
if the government feels or bush or
anyone else feels that what they're
doing in iraq
is necessary for the security of the
country
can't we
what is your opinion of allowing a
budget
a man-made budget to
allow limits on that in other words it
has to be done or it doesn't what comes
out on the pencil and paper uh doesn't
matter can you pause one second i'll
hang up the phone and get to the tv i'm
in another room thank you thanks san
diego mr johnson
well it's
it's not just a yes or no issue
everything is limited everything has its
restraints
i've always thought that the marshall
plan was indeed a brilliant testimony to
general george marshall and what but he
also recognized it was a testimony to
the reality on the ground the united
states had emerged without any damage
done to it at all uh compared with the
other parts of the world we were a
colossus a thwart the world simply
because our wealth the marshall plan was
in our interests it was to recognize the
root causes of war that you could not
live leave people in that kind of uh
misery my wife happens to be dutch she
lived through the
german occupation of holland and came to
america in 1947 it was a i've talked
with her late now late mother about this
many times the decision to allow her to
come to america she said well you just
can't imagine what europe was like in
1947 that
we had no no real alternative when the
opportunity came uh uh we did so and i
said yes of course i wouldn't have met
her if you hadn't made that decision but
it is to uh to say uh i don't think it's
comparable to what's going on in iraq we
know from a lot of inside testimony
right now that the real purpose behind
the war in iraq was the recognition
by
political leaders all of whom have one
thing in common they're all former
executives of petroleum companies the
recognition that the two main
pillars of our petroleum position in the
middle east had collapsed one iran in
1979 as a result of our own foolish
overthrow of the iranian government back
in 1953 and bringing the power of a
tyrant namely the shah of iran we'll
never
unlikely we'll ever have friendly
relations with iran again the second was
saudi arabia we had after all
discovered oil standard oil company of
california we had the arabian american
oil company was an intelligent
organization that went out of its way to
avoid the kind of arrogant and racist
mistakes that the british had made in
the anglo-iranian petroleum company and
things of this sort
we had a friendly relationship with with
saudi arabia for a very long time
it is in recent times when we have begun
to use saudi arabia as a military base
that we started to run into trouble the
saudis did not like our
imperialism
and began to restrict it increasingly we
that is the
the iraq war itself was fought from
another country from qatar
much smaller much easier for us to
intimidate
i believe as we've heard any number of
pentagon insiders say the purpose of
this war was to create a new enclave of
the united states
in southern eurasia after the collapse
of the soviet union and this was iraq
this is why it still remains such a
remarkably delicate issue for the
americans ever to come out and say we
don't intend to build permanent bases in
iraq we've already built five of the
largest airfields on earth that are as
permanent as you can get
the uh that maybe the iraqis will
ultimately inherit them but certainly we
intended to stay there it is the second
largest oil reserves on earth we had
that in mind uh this is not the only
purpose of the iraq war we were also
deeply influenced by
israeli interests in going to war but we
know now without any shadow doubt that
we
lied to the american public we ruined
the central intelligence agency by
producing a national intelligence
estimate in 2002
calling
warning about weapons of mass
destruction in iraq in which not a
single word in it was true
that we then observed our secretary of
state
go down in flames in his speech before
the united united nations security
council in which he comes with his
finger raised in the air saying i'm
going to give you our best secret
intelligence and not a single thing he
said was true that was the end of colin
powell right then and there two minutes
left st mary's pennsylvania go ahead
um earlier your guest had mentioned
economy and secrecy
and i'm wondering what he can tell us
about clinton sending factories overseas
well i don't think clinton sent
factories overseas as much as he allowed
them to go overseas in lieu of a policy
that he reflected the interest of
large-scale capital uh of uh and of the
interest of foreign countries
that is to say
we have our largest single trade deficit
with any country is with china today
uh
china
we are extremely happy to buy products
manufactured in china walmart lives off
of it i don't think clinton had anything
to do with it except the refusal in
america to have
explicit industrial policy
explicit jobs
creation explicit recognition of what
so-called globalization was going to uh
to cost us we've lost three million
uh manufacturing jobs in just the 21st
century alone that is since uh the year
2000 these are serious consequences
you mentioned earlier to a caller that
uh sherman want to think about
uh buying a condo in vancouver have you
have you thought of uh of leaving the
united states
uh not really i'm too old i'm going to
stay here i love san diego i have
thought about it at least once since
though uh i have a geriatric
cat uh a russian blue that i'm extremely
fond of so i did take the trouble to see
what uh countries i could get into
without a uh a quarantine turns out
spain uh doesn't care uh you can take
your cat there and get him right in and
settle him down so if i had to go i
suppose it would be malaga
chalmers johnson has been our guest for
the past 75 minutes this is his book
nemesis the last days of the american
republic mr johnson thanks very much for
your time we appreciate it well thank
you great pleasure i admire your program
and to our viewers have a great day
thanks
chalmers johnson author of nemesis the
last days of the american republic for
more information visit
americanempireproject.com
and earlier we spoke with andrew roberts
author of a history of the
english-speaking people since 1900 learn
more at andrew dash roberts.net
this program re-airs tonight at midnight
eastern here on book tv
chalmers johnson argues that the u.s is
on the verge of internal collapse in the
final volume of his american empire
trilogy nemesis he spoke about it
recently at martin luther king middle
school in berkeley california for about
an hour 45 minutes
[Applause]
well charmers um let's just get the
oh sorry
how is this
thank you for not being shy is this okay
i hate nuance
that's so french
[Laughter]
we wouldn't want to be that um well um
chalmers why don't we just get the
the
uh essential out of the way right off
the bat would you explain blowback and
nemesis
blowback is a cia term it's used first
in the uh
after action report on the first
overthrow of a foreign government we
ever carried out that in 1953 against
muhammad mozadek of iran for the sake of
the british petroleum company
we accused him of being a communist
pope would have probably been a better
candidate uh the uh
uh
it mean it does not mean just
retaliation obviously that's what it
means is retaliation it means
retaliation for acts committed abroad
that were kept totally secret from the
american public so that when the
retaliation comes they're unable to put
them in context to see cause and effect
uh the best example being of course uh
september 11 2001 uh which was
retaliation
by former assets and associates of ours
against us
for the largest single clandestine
activity we ever carried out namely the
recruiting arming sending into battle of
the mujahideen in afghanistan against
the soviet union in
the 1980s
osama bin laden was the sort of person
you would have logically expected to
meet as a house guest at kennebunkport
in maine and the first uh uh
that is uh he uh uh and he became so
disgusted by the way we walked away from
afghanistan after the soviet union
withdrew in 1988 uh that
he and his associates have been after us
for some time uh certainly uh uh 2001
was not out of the blue and it was not a
clash of civil civilizations he had very
very specific things in mind made it
clear to the world within a week after 9
11 that he went out of his way to say
that there are three things that we had
in mind i mentioned them simply because
they're all casa spelling they're not uh
grand statements of clash of values or
we dislike you because of your democracy
or your wealth or whatever else he said
that we we attacked the united states
because of your placing american troops
in saudi arabia after the first gulf war
uh we disliked intensely the use of uh
of uh
uh
of non-believers uh charged with
defending the house of fod which is
responsible for the the safety of the
two most sacred sites in islam mecca and
medina
he said that you will you americans will
never know peace so long as you continue
to back
israeli aggression against the
palestinian people and the seizure of
their land
and third he properly accused us of
killing at least a half million iraqi
children in the most fierce set of
sanctions we ever imposed on any country
that is against iraq during the 1990s
under
bill clinton and madeleine albright
again these are perfectly
uh recognizable reasons for asymmetric
warfare as to use a bit of pentagon
jargon but i prefer it to uh to
terrorism uh the uh and uh
and they followed along a long pattern
that had been going uh
but that was that's blowback
is basically saying um uh
that is i wrote the book well before 9
11. uh with east asia in mind thinking
that the main foreign policy problems of
the 21st century were going to be things
left over from uh
from the last century uh as they came
back upon us we've uh in fact even on
march 11th itself i was chatting with my
publisher uh in new york about
once we had known that it was a
terrorist incident
uh that uh it didn't cross our minds at
once at all that they were islamic
terrorists least of all saudi arabians
the first thought we had march 11th
everybody in latin america knows that
date march 11th 1973 the day the cia
overthrew
a bigger party
oh stepped up i think one yeah i was
thinking the month we're living in now
right
september 11th 1973 the day that we
overthrew the government of salvador
allende in chile and installed probably
the most odious
dictator on either side in the cold war
general augusto pinochet
the it could have been okinawans it
could have been greeks it could have
been any number of people that have
legitimate reasons to wish to have to
attack us nemesis is a different story
you wanted to hear about that one too
nemesis is all of you very good many of
you will know is the greek goddess of
revenge of
the attacker of hubris of arrogance
the
she is classically portrayed as a bright
young woman with a whip in one hand and
a scale in the other uh she was a very
legitimate and high class goddess she
was the
sister of erato the
goddess of love poetry uh
the uh
probably edith hamilton in her great
work on greek mythology uh says it
probably the greatest single act of
of nemesis was she she's the one who
came across narcissus in the forest
and led him to the pond and showed him
his reflection in the water and he fell
in love with it and dove in and drowned
the sort of things that but i'm i'm
contending that uh
nemesis is present in the country today
uh biting her time before she uh
starts settling the scores with some
people who have shown remarkable hubris
the
essential argument of
of
nemesis is simply that
uh there is no politically history tells
us there is no more
unstable
configuration than that of the united
states today namely a domestic democracy
and an external empire you can do one
you can do the other you can't do both
uh the uh they are fundamentally
conflict with each other i try to
explain why they are and what happens
when you try to do both the classic
examples are of course the roman
republic
uh which is important to us because so
many of our constitutional provisions
were adapted from the roman republic
which succumbed after the assassination
of julius caesar and the rise of
of octavian
to
a military dictatorship democracy did
not return for at least a thousand years
it was the first great experiment in a
large scale experiment in
in political democracy and it
it failed uh in a way that
would be easy to expect uh today in in
the united states um
the that is to say
militarists by by this time the roman
empire
or the roman republic had acquired an
empire rather thoughtlessly much like
the united states paid not much
attention to it uh
took it as it's due
and uh
the old legions that were raised among
the citizenry for purposes of defense
had now become standing armies uh with
huge vested interests great problems of
what to do with the troops after they
became redundant uh they were long
service troops by now uh under those
circumstances uh
exploitative militarists
caesar being easily the best example uh
uh began to think that they might uh
champion
the interests of the armed forces in
return for uh life dictatorship uh
that's precisely what did happen uh and
uh
uh
whether you
i mean if you were if you have know
you're given you would think that uh
uh the first uh
that is octavian declaring himself to be
the god augustus caesar uh was not a bad
thing that this was a big improvement
over the endless bickering and arguments
of the uh
of the wonderfully balanced roman senate
but do bear in mind what followed uh
uh uh augustus caesar uh
then came tiberius who uh
withdrew to capri with a boatload of
young boys for his sexual tastes
uh he was succeeded by caligula a
genuine madman
rightly
understood as as such
but who did at least
help perfect the praetorian guards which
became very important in roman history
he was then succeeded by a drooling
idiot
claudius
whose wife
fed him a poisoned mushroom to get rid
of him
and for the sake of her son by an
earlier marriage namely nero uh now i
mentioned these characters simply to say
this is not good government no matter
how you look at it uh this is i mean
that uh the the the
the uh the republic may have
the alternative i try to suggest if you
can find it all there are not many cases
of the opposite there are very few cases
of empires that ever gave up
uh gorbachev is probably the only one in
recent times that really did uh the
uh but i argue that uh the british
empire after world war ii against nazism
and in view of
the record of nazism that had been put
on the
for the world to see and to understand
uh or to attempt to understand uh that
in these circumstances the british
realized they could not hang on to the
jewel and the crown of their empire
india without resorting to as they had
so many times in the past administrative
massacres
administrative massacres would not have
been that is in order to continue to
carry them out uh
britain would have had to transform
itself into a tyranny uh there would
have been uh
really no alternative the therefore they
gave up their empire it wasn't too hard
for them to do because they did have the
united states that they could
come under its wing uh but they gave up
the uh the empire particularly india for
the sake of maintaining domestic
democracy i believe it's something we in
america ought to be thinking
very very hard about ourselves our
empire is now the official count 737
american military bases in well over 130
countries uh the uh uh we and they
provide nothing that we need or want uh
but they're simply expensive and they're
a form of
of of hegemony now the british didn't do
a very good job of this uh there were
huge
atavistic throwbacks afterwards the the
uh
damn near genocide against the kikuyu in
in kenya the anglo-french israeli attack
on egypt in 1956
and then of course the latest best
attivistic case we've got is tony blair
who of all the places you just thought
an englishman would have kept away was
from was this the bastard child that
they had created called iraq uh but they
didn't uh and um and they they
so do you have to say
the british do enjoy militarism you've
got to watch the changing of the guard
at buckingham palace one day just to
realize how much they truly enjoy it uh
the
uh but
that's
more than you wanted to know
oh go on
it is
but
nemesis is then spinning out these
issues the intervening variable between
this
social scientists like to say jargon the
causative link
uh is uh is militarism that is you can't
have a
an empire without having an army uh and
that's where the troubles all begin
the uh and they're uh
they're fatal um
to uh to go in that direction i mean it
it's it's astonishing to talk about such
simple-minded things
the americans pay no attention anymore i
mean
the opening of every new congress
by law we read washington's farewell
address
what did washington say
the greatest enemy of liberty is
standing armies and it is the particular
deadly enemy of republican liberty
well
that was a long time ago and he was dead
right uh that is he knew exactly what he
was saying what he had in mind and uh do
we have a standing army well i'll tell
you it's a biggie
well i um
i i like one of one of the things i like
most about nemesis is its emphasis on
rome as a cautionary example and
i recommended to you the
the documentary why we fight and i find
every about every two years after we
have a so-called election
i go down to the local video store and
rent
all of uh masterpiece theaters i
claudius and watch it and every year it
becomes every two years it becomes more
relevant and one of the things as
chalmers said is that you you start with
augustus who seems pretty awful but by
the time you get to the end of the 15 or
16 hours in fact you can see why they
called it a golden age because at the
very least he was sane
most of them after that weren't yeah
exactly and so it becomes more relevant
all the time so i highly recommend you
watch i claudius again
if you're into that sort of thing you
can watch rome on hbo too uh
once you start you won't be able to put
it down
well um
you likened yourself to gibbon and i
think i did not though
after all the subtitle is the last days
of the american republic yes yes
he took six volumes i took only three
[Music]
you have been likened to jeremiah too
yes there's also
i think of you cassandra because uh of
course cassandra was cursed to tell the
truth and not to be believed although i
think you're being believed more and
more as we slog deeper into this
quagmire
maybe so i find that the new book uh is
being better received uh than the first
two were and by the way this was a
inadvertent trilogy i certainly didn't
set out to write uh three books on this
theme it they one grew out of the other
but the public or the public that i'm
talking to this kind of public
is
is more receptive considerably more
worried i do mean the subtitle i'm not
just trying to uh to sell books i'm
trying to tell you i can't see the way
out i can't imagine any president of any
party that could possibly stand up to
the vested interests of the
military-industrial complex or the
secret intelligence agencies
particularly the central intelligence
agency there's simply no way that this
could be done uh and even then the
system the political system has for all
intents and purposes failed us that uh
we have a
good constitutional provisions for
dealing with an unsatisfactory political
leader uh one that lies us into war or
spends us into a bankruptcy or whatever
else it may be it's called impeachment
so
wait
last november the public elected the
opposition party and the first thing mrs
pelosi said is that impeachment is off
the table
well
if it's off the table then
democracy may well be off the table too
uh that's it that we're we're
spinning our wheels
uh and uh
and and the system uh doesn't work
anymore that's what's gone wrong if you
think
the government in washington dc has any
resemblance to that outlined in the
constitution of 1787 uh the burden of
proof is on you
you talk about how little americans are
permitted to know about just what their
government is doing
and since the present war is
couched by those such as samuel
huntington in terms of a war of
civilization against barbarism
i wonder if you would talk a little bit
about the
extent of cultural destruction which is
going on throughout the middle east
the
burning of the libraries in baghdad in
the first week of the invasion was
considered so unimportant by the
chronicle that it didn't even merit an
article
um
the we heard about the museum that was
destroyed there we really don't know
very much about what was done around the
rest of the country and as a matter of
fact throughout the middle east could
you talk a little bit about well it's
it's one of my charges against these
people uh the others are more serious
certainly abu ghraib and things of this
sort but there is no question
that uh
nemesis is in
is in search of those who commit hubris
stupidity arrogance things of that sort
you can't imagine the the arrogance of
the marine corps writing semper fi or
painting spray painting semper fi
uh that is their slogan on the side of
the ziggurat at uh uh at ur
uh the uh then they had to guard it so
that the press couldn't photograph it
the uh the destruction of the main gates
at uh
uh in nebuchadnezzar's
palace uh that uh
the the area between the tigris and
euphrates
which
in greek mesopotamia uh is uh
uh is the absolute cradle of
civilization the place is uh
is is rife
with
with artifacts that cry out for
protection
that
in one
prominent place we had
tiles and other
spaces laid out at the time of alexander
the great that were all uh cracked by
our tanks driving over them uh the uh
numerous sites are simply unusable today
uh
the uh at the great talil air base next
door to
the uh
the the uh ziggurat the the uh
stepped
uh pyramid uh at or one of the uh
sumerian building
one of the oldest
places on earth where we have two ten
thousand foot runways today uh and uh at
talia air base uh prominently
promises that they've just opened a new
burger king uh
makes uh the troops allegedly feel more
at home they should claim the aroma
coming from it uh
the i mean what can you say the uh that
is uh robert fisk of the london
independent and a great middle eastern
specialist uh had warned
on the day that it occurred that the uh
that the library of koran's was a fire
and that the marine corps could have put
it out
the the marines simply sat around and
said we got a guy here who's telling us
there's a there's a museum of bibles
that's burning uh and of course nothing
happened it as we protected one
institution the oil ministry uh
these are the sort of things that
come back to haunt us
that are going to come back to haunt us
uh that uh the uh
the indifference
to uh
uh to what was happening rumsfeld's
cracks about stuff happens and uh that
it looked like an endless tape of people
carrying vases out of the the national
museum that uh that had been
established by miss bell back in the
1920s when the british
when this is a british territory
it's a terrible tragedy but
we had
four people in the army who spoke arabic
four
uh compared that with the effort we made
say during the japanese war
uh during world war ii in which we
trained
thousands of japanese linguists at
boulder and at the university of
michigan many of which went on to become
the absolute backbone of japanese
studies in this country
and seiden sticker won the the nobel
prize for his translations of kawabata
uh things of this sort
this was just scandalous the war was
going on for two years apparently before
the president actually got it through
his head that there is a difference
between shia and sunni islam
and that uh and that iraq was ruled by a
dictatorial sunni minority government
now if you overthrow it
the the majority comes to power
and that's what they've done and they
align themselves with the
shia superpower next door iran and
it's hard to say even
even from a neoconservative point of
view how this serves the interests of
the united states israel or anybody else
uh but it's uh with that kind of
incompetence uh
you you could expect
the other
greater disasters uh the uh such as abu
ghraib for which probably the united
states will never truly recover
i'd let me just say from a gray
rick and i ran into each other today
right here on the berkeley campus are uh
ferdinand botero's
abu ghraib paintings in the uh in the
library and uh
the uh
i'm
i admire your book so much and
particularly its chapter on the
university of california i i
feel embarrassed to compliment the place
but it was a uh i do too yes of course
you do but it was a uh
important i think that the university of
california did
take these paintings after they've been
turned down by virtually every museum in
the country
uh and i think it was the center for
latin american studies american studies
that did it and i gathered then
uh that there were people in the
administration who could control their
enthusiasm for
uh what was going on but they are
fascinating unbelievable uh pictures uh
by uh
a a very prominent colombian painter who
uh many of you will also know that he
did uh earlier series on on
drug
wars in colombia that are truly
goya-esque they're fabulous things no
you haven't seen them go see them
they're still there for two more weeks
in the doe
library um
in all of this i mean particularly as
the war started i you know when i
i mentioned in the new introduction to
my book that i was able to watch in the
free speech cafe the students enjoying
the spectacle of um baghdad being
pulverized um
on a cnn
screen up above it
yes and it's you know there's no
question in fact that we have made
violence one of our most popular forms
of entertainment so i'd like to talk a
little bit about the responsibility of
the media and all of this it seems to me
that one of our problems is happy talk
tv and hate talk radio
i was just recently in times square and
i looked up and i saw these broadcasting
towers on top of the
high rises and they looked to me like
gigantic steel syringes injecting
soporifics and other poisons into the
public mind
so i wonder if you could uh make a few
remarks about the role of the mass media
um
in this crisis which we're now involved
in well it's it's obviously a huge
subject but it it doesn't seem to be
palpable and not really uh
even argumentative anymore that
the citizen cannot possibly play the
role that for example say benjamin
franklin had in mind uh for the role of
of the informed citizen exercising
elementary oversight on the government
in the first place even members of
congress can't i mean
all
everything the cia does is secret and
it's secret above all from the congress
uh the uh it is uh uh uh the uh
40 of the defense budget is black has
been since that's not bush it's been
since the uh
the university of california's great
contribution since the manhattan project
uh the uh uh and uh uh and the supreme
court has
visited around it for years article one
says the citizens will be told
ultimately given an accurate accounting
of how your tax dollars were spent that
hasn't been true in the united states
for well over 60 years
and
it there's no sign that it likely will
be
uh this
the uh uh
the stonewalling on the freedom of
information act is
certainly it's the worst we've seen the
orders that uh
that both gonzalez and uh and his
predecessor as attorney general put out
uh to stop virtually all requests if you
possibly can
uh have
made it impossible for people to to
follow what's going on
the press has failed us that is
article one of the constitution was not
written to protect people magazine uh
nobody actually gives a damn uh whether
they have
it was written quite ex for a very
explicit reason the press's function was
given these protections in order to
penetrate the bureaucracy and expose it
to public view that's its purpose it's
it's not just to be particularly
entertaining or anything else it's
supposed to get behind what's going on
in uh in washington
they haven't done that uh they've failed
us terribly uh the uh
the new york times has become just a
classic of what's wrong i mean gore
vidal's crack about
the function of the new york times is to
enter the battlefield after the battle
is over and shoot the wounded uh is
is it is essentially what they do do uh
these and they're out there right now
having a wonderful bloodbath uh but they
certainly weren't uh when uh
michael gordon and uh and others were
reporting on the weapons of mass
destruction in saddam hussein's
uh arsenal
television is hopeless i mean we know
that because of uh
that is to say it's owned by
conglomerates
it it functions to uh to make
advertising revenue and it's uh
it's terribly misleading and
ill-informed and i'm afraid you're
probably also right they're fascinated
by explosions and
and uh a fast flying aircraft and and
things of this sort uh it uh so how
could you expect the public
to play this role that uh they uh
that it's not difficult to lead them
around by the nose particularly then
when you get a government that is so
utterly committed to secrecy as this one
is uh it's the it's the cancer on the
government right now and uh and it's
growing exponentially uh just in many
ways just to demonstrate that it uh
that uh that it can be done uh that that
they can
keep
this much information from the general
public and uh
that's
one of the reasons why there's a lot of
things wrong in any one of which
probably could be corrected through
effective political action uh the the
mobilization of inattentive citizens to
this that or the other thing uh could
make a difference
there's too many of them now
it's uh they're uh there's more than one
you can't keep your eye on them all uh
it is uh
more than likely that we are talking
about the short happy life of the
of the american republic uh the whether
we give up our empire or
we have a military coup or we is
my prediction that we go toward
bankruptcy uh that my wife keeps saying
to me come up with something optimistic
would you and i i i said i've i've got
something uh
bankruptcy a uh
uh
a
a
a a financial whimper rather than a
nuclear bang uh the uh and uh
but it uh
and it wouldn't mean literally the end
of the united states any more than it
did for germany in 1923 or
china in 1948 or argentina just in 2001
and two it certainly does mean a drastic
lowering of your level of living the end
of any influence over the rest of the
world a howling recession
and
great impulses toward revolution uh
domestically uh when these things occur
the um
so that it uh
and it could be happening as we talk uh
people are getting awfully tired of
being paid in uh in worthless dollars
particularly china and japan
the uh
but
uh as for the press it's just another
one of the failures to see how easily it
has been co-opted to see how cooperative
it has been
with
this government in particular uh and the
uh
and the unbelievable things that have
happened uh
i live in the 50th district of
california it's in northern san diego
county uh many of you will be aware that
our
our
congressional representative randy duke
cunningham
is
uh is now spending eight and a half
years in a federal penitentiary for
being the uh the worst bribee in the
history of congress uh the uh but it's
important to stress
he was bribed by the military-industrial
complex i mean that's
he claimed to be a hero of the vietnam
war i think things of this sort uh he uh
uh the local press everybody took it on
fine he finally only got caught when he
uh
used a cover to make an extra seven
hundred thousand dollars by selling his
house in del mar and charging more for
it than you could conceivably imagine
and uh and one of his defense
contractors paid for it i mentioned this
to say though that the press wasn't
following this
they weren't paying any attention i
wrote an article in the la times about
cunningham's how he was financed by
lockheed martin and uh and boeing and
and the rest of them uh and uh
uh
i thought it was a good article i got
several letters from people in the 34th
district in downtown los angeles saying
uh god i wish he was my congressman i
could use a good job
uh you know that i i wouldn't mind
making uh uh uh
uh bomlets or uh uh something like that
uh
that's good pay
that's
the problem i think that is that the the
public
uh
we could only be saved by restoration of
the constitutional system with the same
sorts of checks and balances
that
block
uh
dictatorship or tyranny the president
goes around saying i am the decider
it's hard to think of a more
anti-constitutional remark
like helly's decider that we
we do it by committee just as the old
roman republic had two consuls and they
could they changed office every other
month and they could veto anything the
other one did veto was a good latin word
uh and uh and that
the i mean certainly by the time the
republic came to an end
it took an awful lot of ciceronian guile
to make the senate work you had to
produce compromise it was impossible to
uh
to dictate
we now have the most obvious imperial
presidency i find it
impossible to understand i think it's
easier to understand bush and cheney
than it is to understand what happened
to congress
where they just blew away the the that
they that they didn't perform any of
their oversight functions not that they
ever did
you know in the in areas of oversight
where they might have made a difference
i mean the central intelligence agency
had no form of oversight on it at all
the
until
1970s
with the the church committee
that set up the two congressional
oversight committees but remember how
they worked it was a washout on iran
contra when uh
charlie wilson of the texas second
district became chairman of the
committee he rather famously wrote to
the central intelligence agency to his
friends there to say uh
the uh the the fox is now in the hen
house do anything you want to
that was oversight
that's
is it right now it's it's nothing better
the press didn't report this
didn't follow it it wasn't that hard to
do either
people just
vaguely well informed could have uh
could have followed it there are lots of
sources of information on on this sort
of thing
but it
it failed and uh may well be too
late well that brings us to the
responsibility of the public itself and
particularly the
degree of passivity to which they
accepted the coup d'etat of 2000 and now
receive sandra day o'connor as some sort
of icon of moderation and feminism when
she comes around to warn people about uh
the growing tendency towards tyranny in
the united states probably no other
person is more responsible for that coup
d'etat
um
how much how would you
credit the united states public with
this and particularly after the
affirmation of 2004
well precisely remember uh
that that election i mean there is no
question that in 2002 the president was
appointed by a a 5-4 decision of the
supreme court the uh but the election of
2004
he and he did not win in 2000 the
electoral vote in 2004 he won by three
and a half million ballots uh the uh
that made his war
his pictures from abu ghraib
uh
his uh uh
budgets that were
truly threatening bankruptcy uh
his uh uh
those things became in the eyes of the
world ours we had all now endorsed them
and that's the
that's precisely why it's very hard any
longer to listen to people talk about
a political solution or to suggest uh
maybe another dynastic cycle of more
bushes and more clintons uh would uh
would change something
i don't believe it i don't see how
that's going to make any difference
and
so that i um
i think i just have to leave it at that
i
as for the public certainly one could
imagine
one could imagine abstractly
a mass mobilization of the public
comparable to say the civil rights
movement of the
1960s
uh that
determined to retake the congress
reconstitute it and uh cause it to
return to its original purpose
uh throw away all the old saws metaphors
about swinging pendulums and
we swing one way but then we swing back
don't worry about it uh this is an
exceptional country etc etc uh didn't
work in germany yeah exactly you could
imagine it but i don't see how with
the
the size of the country
the enormous difficulties of mobilizing
such a diverse population
the
conglomerate control of the main sources
of information today
uh rupert murdoch is threatening to buy
30 of the los angeles times uh you know
the
this kind of thing uh
it's very very hard to imagine how this
could happen except to notice that there
are
larger audiences
interested in uh in these subjects in
a
less than academic way or i've
discovered also a growing number of
of people at gatherings of this sort who
want to ask me personally what do you
think i could do what and my wife says
i swear to you you just cannot once
again say if you've got a little money
ahead buy that condo in vancouver uh you
know that you know uh i i mean
uh terrible earthquakes up there yeah
you know start preparing your escape
route uh the uh uh i said the other
night on
on tv in which somebody had pushed me i
said i'm look i'm 75 years old i've
decided to write it out but uh the uh
but but i say i did do a little
elementary research i happen to have a a
geriatric russian blue cat that i'm
extremely fond of
and
so i did research to see what countries
around the world would accept
an elderly couple with their cat without
quarantine
it turns out the spaniards don't give a
damn about
this sort of thing
my wife happens to have a degree in
spanish literature
we thought malaga here we come
uh well
after watching
uh why we fight uh which is about the
military industrial complexes eisenhower
warned us and i believe he left out
congressional i think he was going to
put that famously he intended to say the
military-industrial congressional
complex but
it was members of congress who warned
him off what we know from his papers let
me just say about the film i was very
pleased to be included i do believe
jireki probably overstates eisenhower
though that is uh he was the butcher of
guatemala
uh he uh most attacked the certainly the
moza deck affair he was easily
bamboozled by the british
he had presided over this unbelievable
growth of the military industrial
complex particularly the air force
and and it appalled him when he realized
that it was now
out of control that and moreover it was
starting to
penetrate deeply into the society that
uh
it's perfectly logical for the secretary
of defense to want to close military
bases that are redundant useless or go
back to the civil war every time he
tries it
in it would happen in berkeley if you
had a military base here
the the newspapers the preachers and
everybody would say oh my god save our
jobs uh the uh we need to keep open uh
the sewer gas
campus a uh
a bomb disposal uh base or something of
that sort the they it goes on endlessly
uh i mean uh i've said it before but
it's uh
i think it's apropos the state of
washington has two really lovely women
relatively liberal senators who have
represented their state well
say the word boeing to them and before
your very eyes they will turn into
bloodlusting fascist hyenas uh the uh i
mean that it
sounds like feinstein yeah exactly i
mean their function is to keep boeing in
business uh the two mother hands of the
defense facilities
subcommittee of the senate army services
committee are kay bailey hutchinson of
texas and dianne feinstein of california
uh that states with the two largest
number of military bases and they regard
their
business in this world is to
keep those bases functioning keep people
employed uh the military industrial
complex is very good at this sort of
thing on a big project like the b2
bomber they put a piece of that in as
many constituencies as they possibly can
it's what it runs the price up terribly
too uh just so that if anybody got the
idea any
man or woman in congress that we didn't
need a new weapon of
of mass destruction uh they could be put
out of office the next election
by firing a good many of their
constituents it uh this is what i'm in
the book calling military keynesianism
uh it certainly was an idea of john
maynard keynes it's not what he meant by
it uh but it it does refer to the use of
the defense
budget so-called or the military
establishment's funds which is
considerably more than the department of
defense uh the uh
for purposes of maintaining as close to
full employment as possible
to influence the level of employment in
the society to make work
and to live with the vicious cycle that
it sets up
that is
bigger weapons mean more wars more wars
mean bigger weapons so that we go to war
with great regularity now well that's
why i wanted to add to the
military-industrial congressional
complex the academic uh component of
that and particularly because we are
here in berkeley um as you probably know
the university of california has two top
secret campuses one of them not even in
california los alamos they were
deliberately set up by edward teller and
ernest lawrence to compete with one
another to produce the very best means
of mass destruction and um let me just
say we think we all know a lot about
that but your book is truly revelatory
thank you i mean i thought that it was
uh
beautifully put together in a way that
it wasn't just the usual uh you know uh
was j.r oppenheimer nuts or or that
which we forever reading about it uh it
really did
link it so powerfully to
industrial interests
here in california uh and uh it and it's
an appalling story that uh
has never really i think seen the
political light of day
no and i don't think it can it's it's
extremely secret the administration does
not want to talk about it does not want
to have the public associated which is
why you don't see oppenheimer's name
anywhere on campus you see lawrence's
name everywhere but oppenheimer no you
don't um and it becomes worse i think
with every passing year because just
last friday
the department of energy announced that
the lawrence lab would be developing a
new generation of nuclear weapons why we
need them we weren't told but we were
told that
a few years ago when they renewed the
contract for los alamos
where the university will serve as a fig
leaf right bechtel that the labs would
be run now more like a business whose
product is nuclear weapons so um you
don't get the idea of what a
thermonuclear bomb could do to a city in
fact
but it's extremely lucrative and i might
say that the
head of the board of regents uh
financier richard bloom
um has uh extensive um
uh military interests actually and his
wife is senator dianne feinstein who
sits on the appropriations committee of
the senate right
um
and this is something that the chronicle
has not carried actually
um
here here
as i say i uh
when we were going to get together for
this i
sat down and started reading your
book and learned more than i really
needed to know about the history of
mining in california and uh you never
could know too much
especially about uranus well when i gave
it to the chapter on the university of
california i really sat bold upright
you've done a superb job well thank you
you were in the department of political
science it's hard to believe what a
scandalous organization that was
i'm in the department of geography which
actually butted out of the department of
commerce around the time of the
spanish-american war to find out what
was actually out in the in the uh
pacific and particularly in terms of
resources the interesting thing though
is that you're seeing the university is
still playing a malevolent role
whereas
my thought would have been just going
back to your question about
the media and the information level the
public and things of that sort that
there was a disastrous failure
of the universities particularly in the
social sciences in the 1990s
when they i mean
i was a former member of the council on
foreign relations i'm i actually
resigned over sam huntington's article
about the clash of civilizations i was
rather
told rather bluntly no one ever resigns
from the council of foreign relations
they die
and and i said well i'm resigning
because i'm not dead yet uh the uh
but but it is but nonetheless they went
five years without ever publishing a
single article on iraq i mean
and what went wrong
the uh
this a lot of things have gone wrong uh
the way in which fundraising has
devolved from
trustees to deans
and people like that who are actually
rather good at it enjoy it find it
easier than performing their function of
quality control
over
very complex institutions like uh
departments
uh the uh
the the crazy enthusiasm
for
the nobel prize
the nobel prize is an almost unmitigated
disaster academically it drives
everything toward fundamental theory
drives money away from engineering from
applied work
uh the uh
my late colleague rather famous
political scientist aaron waldowski once
asked asser linvik of the uh of the
nobel prize committee why they didn't
give a prize in political science
and that linbeck has responded and said
oh we do it's the literature prize
if you if you if you could write a novel
as good as social nietzsche uh we'll
give you a prize aaron uh the
uh but it is what happened i think was
the
uh the disaster
of the reichsbank of sweden giving nobel
prizes in economics
it economics used to be a useful social
science
but today it is mostly simultaneous
equations and other forms of gibberish
that add up to almost nothing
but that the other social sciences are
out to duplicate them now what this
meant is that people
quit
teaching really they started writing uh
articles for each other uh that nobody
read they were normally weighed uh in
dean's offices uh at
unpublishable junk
that uh
just read quite a bit of that part yes
you know what that is to say there's a
just it is proved to me such a relief to
finally
retire uh the uh
you know
life life after the big organization uh
the i no longer have to pretend my
colleagues are smart uh the uh
and uh
that which as a former chairman of
political science at one time i did have
to do that the
uh what a relief
the uh but it uh
i believe that there is that is to say
the failure is not just one of
malevolence or of vested interests
i also think it has been a rather
serious intellectual failure
in not uh
in not doing this sort of work that
would have
contributed to oversight of the
government
democratic controls uh the the sort of
providing the kind of information that
uh
the professoriate would be able to do
and that the public certainly could use
well as long as we're talking about
economics let's talk about
your idea of military keynesianism many
of these neocons of course just detest
franklin roosevelt see him as something
close to satan would you compare the
kind of keynesianism that produced
schools airports roads sewers etc with
the kind of keynesianism that we have
now yeah as well john maynard keynes uh
it
i particularly admire
very famous english economist uh and of
enormous uh influence one of the things
i always loved particularly is given my
background as a consultant of the cia
many people have asked what on earth
happened to you you know that
boy did you change your mind uh and uh i
think you're being inconsistent uh the
uh uh
keynes when once accused of being
inconsistent rather famously said uh
when i get new information i change my
position what sir do you do with new
information
[Applause]
which is
some of the new information i got was
how fast after the collapse i mean
there's no question i was a cold warrior
i thought the soviet union was a menace
i still do
uh the uh
but that it was astonishing how
remarkably rapidly after the collapse of
the soviet union uh our government set
out to find a replacement enemy uh
to keep the military-industrial complex
at work china
uh
drug lords
terrorism
even instability isn't it we we needed a
defense establishment for that too
but it is uh
the university it seems to me
has has
not carried on
held up standards of the sort of
critical
information that we needed the critical
stance toward our government
understanding
what was necessary and uh and we're
paying a great price for it now
um i just wanted to read a few of the
quotes
talk about military cases yes please
military keynesianism is certainly not
something that keynes invented it was
actually the title the name was invented
by a polish economist during world war
ii to explain the first german economic
miracle adolf hitler's uh restoration of
full employment
in the late 1930s through military
spending and also that keynesianism
this was uh keynes's idea was
that when you have a
when the economy is so depressed that
simply people don't have enough money to
buy anything with
buy anything at all then it's important
to start putting money in the hands of
consumers and he proposed
counter-cyclical
job creation
uh some of it was
he thought was a were great ideas the
triboro bridge the grand coulee dam
all of those sorts of things that were
part of american keynesianism
but he also said we should just do make
work put
put money in disused mines and pay
unemployed workers to go down and dig it
up uh at least gives them something to
do and we'll start getting the economy
back in place he also genuinely meant it
as counter-cyclical we'd do this in
times of depression but when we'd
regained a degree of employment
we would then go back to uh effective
uh
ending deficit spending and uh and pay
back pay down the budget and things of
this sort that's certainly one of the
changes in military keynesianism it
never stops once you once you get hooked
on living off of munitions making uh you
never
there is no cure there is no backing
down from it uh the
and uh
the term i mean we spent
well over five trillion dollars on
nuclear weapons between the 1940s and
the height of the stockpile in 1966.
the uh
uh never one one was never used of
course we're lucky that one was there
except for the two uh in in japan uh but
that uh it's a perfect example of
keynesianism uh it's uh spending a huge
amount of money to put people to work uh
none of it having ever showing up in the
military budget this is the department
of energy
uh the uh uh
which is entirely separate and never
included when people and rumsfeld goes
around telling you what a
small and declining percentage of gross
domestic product the military budget is
this is
the kind of nonsense that the press
accepts when there are geniuses in
washington they can explain it to you in
a half hour and they write good books on
the defense budget
most of them actually work for the
republican party in the budget
committees
they've worked there for 30 years and
they know every trick in the trade how
it's done
earmarks one thing after another uh and
uh
they generally remain working on capitol
hill they don't go to work for
aei or the heritage foundation or
something like that these right-wing
think tanks that dominate washington
these days but it is
to try and
just simply compare
the the simple appropriation simple
it's three-quarters of a trillion
dollars right now it's larger than all
other defense budgets on earth combined
and that's the straightforward
appropriation including the funding for
two wars uh the uh but then you're
starting adding in nuclear weapons you
add in the entire separate budget for
defense facilities that is
737 american military bases abroad uh
leave aside the ones domestically uh
and
defenders of the pentagon like to say oh
you're wrong you're just talking about
marine guards in embassies i guarantee
you there aren't any 737 embassies
anywhere there aren't that many there
that that many countries
uh the uh uh we're talking about real
uh real military
uh real genuine healthy american rapists
uh the uh uh
and uh an inflicted i mean
revolt has been endemic in okinawa since
the battle of okinawa of 1945. that is
there are 37 american military bases on
an island smaller than
kauai in the hawaiian islands
it's a place it's an american
puerto rico
i mean it's a japanese puerto rico the
japanese acquired okinawa late in the
19th century
adapted into the japanese empire it had
always been discriminated against it's a
dumping ground for americans the
the japanese government likes the
japanese american security treaty they
also know that the japanese public
largely likes it but the one thing they
don't like they don't want american
troops located anywhere even slightly
close to them uh therefore you put him
down in okinawa a place with no
political clout
uh
the rate of sexually violent crimes
committed by
american servicemen in okinawa
leading to court-martial which is
important because that means the woman
came forward and testified which in
japanese culture is relatively unusual
the rate is and has been now for 60
years two per month
uh it's uh it goes on and on and on
nothing comes of it
all of this is the these are the the
costs of i'm starting to ramble aren't i
these getting off into into my pet
irritations uh the uh
uh
that is to say
one of the huge the largest items
in the defense
in the military establishment that is
never accounted for is uh interest
payments on the debt on all the previous
wars
it uh that's in the treasury department
of course then we have the uh the whole
issue of veterans benefits and treatment
of the remarkable
veterans of from
iraq who have survived wounds that
normally would have killed him
and has now led to this scandal of
of
another scandal of remarkable
incompetent uh but the costs
of paying for
our wounded are simply skyrocketing
that's of course in the department of
veterans affairs
not in the pentagon
foreign military sales is held is done
by the state department uh so once you
start looking throughout the government
and all the things that add up military
keynesianism doesn't sound quite as
utre
as it uh may coming from me
well in the in the book you talk about
how things like the star wars so-called
star wars defense system is better it it
really doesn't matter whether we use it
or not i mean it serves the function of
using a lot of money but
it looks like we're about to have
another spasm and i'd like to wrap up
with talking about our drive towards war
with iran
back in september there was a
and
an amazing uh op-ed piece in the
chronicle by somebody named
bennett ramberg
who
uh it was called bomb tehran now or be
bombed later and this is tehran not
natanz
and the conclusion of that article was
that the united states had better
launch a conventional attack upon iran
so that israel will not launch a nuclear
attack upon it in
january 7th
the
sunday times of london reported that it
had a report uh showing that there are
advanced israeli plans to launch a
nuclear strike on iran well you can find
this with
seymour hirsch's articles and i just
wondered if you could say something
about israel's role in this kind of
imperial cosmology and
especially this drive towards war now
with iran
well of course israel is a
ward of the united states and we are
determined to protect it it's written in
part of the our defense budget is the
the
several billion dollars annually it goes
to uh israel and with relatively few
controls over how the money is spent uh
moreover as a
an israeli attack on iran is an
israeli-american attack just as the
famous israeli attack on the reactor at
osirak we laid down a radar trail where
our f-16s the israeli pilots were flying
uh to get there and hit the thing uh
properly the israelis asked for a new
one i mean they would like to have a new
a new electronic map put on the ground
uh to uh to guide them uh to uh uh
to uh uh iran
it's uh
it's hard to explain
the enthusiasm for amateur military
theorizing
in washington these days over this kind
of thing what's happening in the case of
iran is relatively simple
the iranians uh we have to learn to live
with the nuclear iran there is no
alternative
we set it up iran is a large and
important country it's surrounded by
nuclear power the soviet union to the
north the united states and the persian
gulf israel in the west india and
pakistan uh on its borders the only way
you can possibly and then along comes a
president who says that he's committed
to preventive war that's what the
japanese did to us in december 1941 uh
the uh
he's committed to preventive war uh and
then he comes out with a list of
countries that he believes
it's in the interest of the united
states to use military force to bring
about regime change he calls them the
axis of evil uh iran iraq and uh and
north korea
the
we of course attacked the one that we
knew didn't have nuclear weapons uh
and that's precisely what we're talking
about here the only way you could defend
yourself against such a threat which is
now made credible by
the
the invasion of iraq and what is
actually occurred there is to have a
retaliatory capacity the uh
de gaulle put it the ability to tear off
an arm
uh
that that will slow the americans down
everybody knows that
i mean we used to say that that's what
had happened in north korea they didn't
actually have a bomb they just went
around and they painted buckets of red
and wrote atom bomb on it and uh
and the news took care of the rest uh
the uh
that
they were always extremely rational
people uh that that uh saw what they
were facing that and
their answer to this has it's
churchillian uh
the americans say they're going to
attack us
well if you've got to go take one with
you as
churchill said at the height of the
blitz and if
the americans are going to attack us we
intend to take out the city of seoul
as many american military bases in
okinawa as we possibly can as many
japanese cities as we can
they don't have much of a capacity to do
that but it's it is now become a
credible threat at the same time there's
nothing easier to deter
than a thing like that
the easiest thing on earth is to tell
where a uh a nuclear-tipped missile came
from and uh
the
we have the the capacity technological
we don't even have to depend on you know
any employee
uh
to uh to know where it came from and if
a country
if israel
were attacked by uh by uh iran iran
would disappear the next day
it would take that long well i wouldn't
it wouldn't actually take that long but
the president goes to bed early uh
he would have to push the button uh the
uh that's part of our rituals
uh the cheney could do it yeah uh so
that i see and i think we've known for
some time that
iran will be relatively easily deterred
uh from ever using its weapon but that
it will
stop this nonsense
of
the israelis believing that they are
beyond
that they are like us beyond all forms
of international law
capable of exercising anything they want
to do in the name of rezondet
and
that uh and maintaining this uh gross
and overwhelming uh uh military power
uh contemptuous of the nuclear
nonproliferation treaty uh and uh uh
the uh
that is the tragedy of our
of our uh uh
not it's not tolerating israel that i'm
thinking of the the tragedy of our uh
playing along with israel uh tolerating
the kinds of things that they have been
doing
is that it probably affects israeli
security more severely
than anything else they get themselves
more and more isolated all the time
the old nation in arms doesn't work very
well anymore uh it and it's it's just uh
extremely dangerous situation uh but um
the um
the signs of life in the country are
that we're told now
this is you know this is
the few smart journalists who work for
the washington post and who follow the
pentagon closely that an attack on
an american attack or an ordered attack
on iran will lead to uh uh high command
mutiny in the american armed forces
uh the uh
uh
and uh
and that that that seems like a a a
distinct uh uh possibility right now
there
actually in some way so disgusted by
their very hard work after vietnam to
try and rebuild the military and then to
have it as thoroughly discredited i mean
right now
this huge high-tech military with 150
000 troops in uh in iraq has been fought
to a standstill by 20 000 insurgents
equipped with man homemade bombs
you would have thought there would be
grounds for an investigation here uh
you know where where did the money go
yes
but i don't know that there's anything
more than i that i could say to it
except uh
yes there is a lot of ominous uh talk
these days
you you do occasionally have
thoughts that dick cheney must think
well
god i never thought we'd get this far
with it anyway it's the last it's the
last chance uh i've still got the uh the
possibility to uh to try and launch it
uh let's just go ahead and and
and see where the pieces fall
uh
the the thought that that would be
possible in this country uh is a measure
of how far from the uh
the constitution the world of madison uh
we really are
well let's wind up on an upbeat note you
said that nemesis is in the house and
and we're facing bankruptcy so when do
you think it's going to come and should
i buy gold
well
that's i mean bear in mind
those in the audience here who are
graduate students and economics at this
great university will be aware that what
they've been taught about international
trade hasn't been true of the united
states for a very long time that is uh
a uh
the world's leading net debtor nation uh
generally
speaking it's just common sense to not
go around insulting your banker that
often
if you are the world's largest net
debtor but we are dependent upon the
chinese and the japanese continuing to
ship
huge amounts of money to us every day
in order to keep up our our lifestyle uh
we
and
when will this happen when they decide
they don't want to take dollars anymore
it could happen
at this moment if saudi arabia decided
tomorrow that they wanted to be paid in
euros instead of dollars for oil
the united states would collapse
right then and there it would be over uh
uh the uh i'm sorry i'm breaking into
japanese uh the uh uh the uh feel free
and uh uh it uh
but it right now
all holders of dollars on earth are
quietly
secretively trying to
cut
their holdings
because
once it's apparent what's happening then
the name of the game is don't be the
last guy through the door
because by the time you're the last one
through the door this stuff is junk
uh and
but that
could happen uh people in economics
departments have been taught for uh
at least 50 years that with a current
account deficit of say
three percent of gross domestic product
uh you're an economy in very serious
trouble and must have corrective
measures that wants to wean you off of
foreign goods
well our current account deficit is at
six percent of gdp
and uh it continues to go ahead uh as an
unbelievably rigged system uh
you don't know when it's going to happen
because it serves so many other people's
interests the chinese and the japanese
decide to continue to accept more or
less disvalued american money
in order to continue to maintain high
employment in their societies and to
continue to develop this industrial base
they we don't manufacture much anymore
these days except weapons and munitions
uh and they know that they make good
ones oh
not not bad at all uh the uh uh actually
they're really rather crappy
i mean they pulled
the chapter that i'm really pleased with
in in nemesis is the one on uh
space the ultimate imperialist project
uh i like the gravel well yes it's that
is and it's interesting to see the
chinese retaliate finally after we've
tried
desperately as they've tried people
around the world have tried desperately
to get the americans on board to
actually begin to prevent through
serious international law the
weaponization of space of all the things
all the countries that should be
interested in this it's us we depend on
this stuff i mean every time you buy
anything at you know with your credit
card at uh walmart or whatever else it
goes up to a high earth orbit
gets punched up walmart notes that we
have one fewer sock than we used to have
or something of that sort it's they they
go on endlessly is what the television
depends on it and now here we are uh
filling up the low earth orbits with
whizzing debris
uh it is there are a lot of people
predicting the johnson space senator
said it's perfectly possible that within
a few years the entire planet will
simply be uh enclosed in
debris flying at 17 500 miles an hour
the the the speed of the uh
of the the the uh shuttle uh and uh
nobody and
space exploration will for all intents
and purposes cease we will never get
through it again sally ride as you may
remember is the commandant of the
challenger before it it's ultimate
unfortunate end
but
when
she was uh commented on
i guess it was her second challenger
flight
uh
a piece of paint
uh hit the windshield on the thing and
she said i just became panic stricken i
mean that is the gouge it made out of
the out of the window i thought this
thing will not withstand re-entry uh it
did and they survived it but when you
start thinking of
lens caps wrenches junk of one sort or
another uh things that have not been put
into graveyard orbits uh
the amount of debris is huge in fact
there's a great deal of strategizing
today about a really rogue nation
could totally blind the united states
there goes global positioning systems
every pledge every uh
cell phone around would end at once by
just firing a um
just you know yeah just
just firing a couple of gravel truck
truck loads of gravel in the low earth
orbit
and let it spin around and kill our
satellites contribute to that uh it
would it would take them right out and
all of a sudden uh no more uh electronic
battlefield or anything else we are
dependent on the stuff but uh
the uh
the johnson space editor
publishes a very interesting global
debris newsletter
which is
well the air force tries to keep track
of somewhere around 17 000
pieces of junk
that are that are floating in low earth
orbit if they're in high earth orbit
they're there forever
they will never
anything happen to them unless we start
developing
uh outer space garbage trucks that uh
which
might not be a too stupid
approach to uh to the way things are
going but the chinese got so irritated
at this the other day that they just
took one of their
uh uh took a a high-powered rocket and
knocked out one of their old satellites
so the satellite goes dead it's dead
there's no way to repair it uh and but
the amount of
debris
they unleashed with this thing was uh
was fantastic uh and
it's uh
the latest uh space debris newsletter
has a wonderful tale of a
old chinese second stage rocket
rear-ending uh a piece of american junk
from the 1980s
and uh it broke into five more large
pieces of junk that all have to be
recorded and uh uncharted and uh
that's
that's astrophysics these days
well on that note of hope um
particularly we can just get rid of
television i think that's a great idea
um
so
sasha is a time for q a
thank you chalmers thank you very much
thank you
[Music]
it is a let me just say if i could
i am in no no let me
let me just make a a comment it i'm
awfully pleased to have this uh as a
kpfa sponsored affair very few people
realize it back in the cenozoic in the
1950s when i was a graduate student at
this university
i was reading the the chinese and
japanese press over uh uh over kpfa in
the days of old elsa knight thompson
most of you don't remember her she uh
she could actually light a uh
a a kitchen match on her leg
it was it was it was it was a fantastic
trick that always impressed my young uh
an inexperienced uh
view of the world but also to be here
with gary breckett is uh truly important
uh my uh uh colleague in in san diego
mike davis you've mentioned him several
times well you're certainly the mike
davis around here well thank you very
very much
can you hear me now yes all right
so we have some questions from the
audience the first one is
if dick cheney were to be indicted would
this change your conclusions
no
that is to say it would take out cheney
obviously
and
i guess it is conceivable if we carry
this game along we could get uh nancy
pelosi uh move further up a rank or two
but i don't see that that
this is what we're talking about cheney
is uh uh
is a serious problem for us no question
but
to say that that's the sort of thing
that's affecting the united states is
simply uh absurd our problems are much
more
serious than any individual man
so another uh person in the audience
asks do any of your your inside the
beltway contact share your alarm at the
current situation
uh there's a few who do yes uh on the
back of nemesis you'll find a plug by
ray mcgovern x of the cia rather famous
analyst uh the uh uh and also the head
of i can't remember exactly the title of
his organization today but intelligence
analyst for peace or something of that
sort sanity i think i think it's sanity
insanity it's for sanity yeah the uh
in writing of his plug the uh uh
the the publisher refused to use it all
the last line he put in was chalmers i'm
so pleased that you finally finished
your book i'll see you in guantanamo bay
[Laughter]
now
he's uh he's already been reading up on
cuban
uh
affairs of his own tropical vacation but
uh no i
potomac fever is such an insidious
disease that most of them are not
actually paying
they can't imagine that they will not go
on forever
all right
so another question is do you think 911
was an inside job what about cheney's
role
well i don't actually think it was an
inside job i think it was an active
asymmetric warfare planned very
effectively
by
al-qaeda and well-executed i grant you
there's been published an awful lot of
odd engineering information
but i still don't think it was done on
the back lot at uh nellis air force base
in nevada and then sold to the rest of
the world i sorry it it seems
implausible to me that that is the case
uh it does begin to suggest that maybe
some building inspectors in new york
city
have a couple of things to answer for
all right
how can we overcome the one party system
which the democrat republican duopoly
has wrought it seems that true
constitutionalism cannot flourish so
long as minority parties are excluded
from the political process well said uh
but i do not see how that will be
altered uh there are so many other
anomalies i'm tired of having who is
nominated chosen by such backward states
as new hampshire and uh and iowa uh the
uh i'm
tired of uh of having our electoral
constituencies made up of such
weird affairs as as our state system and
any number of things that cry out for
reform of a of an 18th century uh
constitution uh
but uh
the uh
that's the way it is right now and
that's why i believe it's very hard to
see
the way out though obviously what do we
think we're doing here
we're trying to mobilize inattentive
citizens to what they're about to lose
and how important it will be to them
once it's gone they'll never get it back
that's
uh what where
now that
whether this is um
uh uh
simply uh whistling past the graveyard
whether it's possible to make any
difference at all is still an open
question there have been mass movements
in the united states that in the past
have made uh
an impact particularly the civil rights
movement of the 1960s
well maybe you touched on this a little
with your advice about the house in
vancouver but um
that wasn't advice it was just
uh the question is as we enter the last
days what can younger people do and
expect the older generation has a little
less to lose do we move et cetera
well precisely uh that's
there's nothing further
ready to say about it except that
of course man makes himself
you must prepare your own escape route
you must think about these things and
start asking yourself you know how many
different kind of passports do we have
in our family what languages do we speak
would you really like to live in new
zealand uh
i've been there
it's so bucolic the sheep sleep on their
backs with their
feet in the air
i remember
the the wife of the man who invited me
an extremely pleasant woman was driving
me around auckland we were looking for
new zealand amber and uh
i remember at one point over lunch he
certainly just simply turned to me and
said i'd kill for two weeks in sydney
and i thought i said my god has she got
cabin fever i mean uh
so
you know beware of what you asked for uh
some
beautifully uh beautiful new zealand uh
but a little dull
the the uh
but of course it is the responsibility
of young people to start thinking about
the future of the country and to be
aware that they are deeply uh caught up
in it
and
that the future
may not be good i mean if we were
holding this conversation in say 1985
and i had said to you
four years from now the soviet union
will not exist
you'd have thought this guy inhales too
deeply on a contraband substance uh the
uh that he's not a good judge of uh of
uh
of these things it's gone
russia is a much smaller place than the
former soviet union was
it essentially the same things that
happened to it are happening to us the
imperial overstretch
extreme economic rigidity
ideological rigidity inability to reform
they went first because they were always
poorer than we were one of the biggest
mistakes we ever made was to conclude
that we won the cold war
both countries lost the cold war they
they went first
gorbachev tried to reform is really one
of the few cases in history we know of
an imperialist who was getting rid of
the empire he knew that he would rather
have friendly relations with france and
germany than he would with those crummy
satellites in eastern europe that stalin
had created
and he tried it he ran head-on into
vested interest so powerful that he was
unable to make headway
are there vested interests in this
country
you know to ask the question is to
answer it uh and uh
uh so that uh
uh
empires go fast
that is they go uh
really with the speed of of fedex these
days uh the i mean in my lifetime i've
seen the fall of the
nazi the imperial japanese british
french dutch
uh portuguese
soviet
uh
that's a lot of empires uh to uh to go
down and uh they come along
very suddenly it seems all of a sudden
the uh it just becomes apparent uh to
everyone that the thing
the farce is over uh and uh
that's unfortunately what i think we're
starting to begin to face in this
country today there's a really genuinely
qualitatively different understanding of
the country and its problems that
existed prior to the collapse of the
soviet union
how can we ignore 240 billion barrels of
oil up for grabs in the middle east
well i don't think we do ignore it
i wish wish we could uh the i mean
without question
the uh the two main pillars of
american foreign policy in the middle
east
were the relationships with saudi arabia
created by franklin roosevelt and uh
and pioneered by the standard oil
company of california that went into the
great and extremely successful
consortium called the arabian american
oil company aramco with
the overwhelming advice put on aramco
don't behave like the british in iran uh
get along
learn don't take your wives don't mess
around in this country
these people don't have the same
religion you do
and and don't expect them to we did that
for years it worked fine slowly over the
years we've lost track of that and saudi
arabia began to restrict
uh seriously
the uh our presence in the country after
the first gulf war to the point that uh
prince sultan air base at riyadh became
essentially functionless we moved
our main centcom headquarters to qatar
from which
franks and company carried out the
attack on iraq the other central pillar
was of course iran
we destroyed iran by becoming a flunkee
of the british empire in 1953
bringing to power the shah and his uh
his notorious police state led by savak
which is then overthrown in
1979 bringing to power uh
the the ayatollah
uh and uh
uh and we have been at loggerheads with
the iranians uh ever since it's unlikely
that we will ever
have influence in this important country
again these were both
extremely serious foreign policy
failures
of the sort for which governments are
normally held responsible
our answer as plotted we now know from
numerous
insiders in the pentagon who have come
out and spoken particularly lieutenant
colonel karen kitovsky and who resigned
on the day of the invasion and extremely
admirable person in my view
but who has said that without doubt the
purpose of the war
was not even to particularly protect
israel or anything of that sort it was
to establish a new main base
for the united states
in the middle east with southern eurasia
having been opened up to imperialist
penetration as a result of the collapse
of the soviet union we have we refuse
ever to say that we are not building
permanent bases in
in iraq five of them are as permanent as
you can get uh kbr pours
just unbelievable amounts of concrete at
every one of them all the time uh the
the congress goes out of its way to say
this is not on our agenda we don't ask
about it we don't pay attention we
certainly don't pay attention to how the
money is spent in building these bases
we know full well that we did not have a
plan for
ending the iraq war because we did not
intend to leave that was
it was an imperialist activity on our
part to take over the place now whether
it was to say that it was oil
that is driving all this i think oil is
certainly an important element in it but
probably oil is also equally important
to our neocon
plotters as a
means of influence over countries like
china and others that are also
net
fuel
importers and uh that they wanted to
control it just as they tried
very seriously under the clinton
administration more seriously than these
amateurs uh to uh
build american military bases in the
former soviet central asian republics uh
uzbekistan kyrgyzstan uh particularly
those two we've been thrown out of one
now the price of the of our bases in the
other have gone from
uh from five million a year to 200
million a year
we're not handling any of this very well
but the purpose there of course was
caspian sea oil
oil is a very important element in it
but
i'm inclined to say that imperialism was
more important that is our intent to
dominate the world
full spectrum dominance as the air force
says
could i just add that
the u.s military is the largest single
consumer of oil in the world so without
it of course the
military can simply not
not work well as it stands right now of
course it is the fuel that
makes the thing go that's jp1 jet fuel
is made of oil
you quoted voltaire in your book
those who can make you believe
absurdities can make you commit
atrocities how has the american public
been changed by its acceptance of so
many absurdities
well that is a good uh question the
i
was trying to deal with that in the
first chapter in a uh
unusual manner and one that
most editors would advise again do not
ever ever ever under any circumstances
make a nazi comparison uh with something
that the americans are doing it's the
third rail don't do it any intelligent
editor would
would take it out at once
one of the things that interested me
a great deal in the torture scandals the
ordering of torture
the uh we now know it was ordered that
is the time of the that the photographs
from abu ghraib were released in in 2003
there was a sign up in the pentagon that
of the six
enlisted men and women who were arrested
by the army intelligence services
for these crimes
these are the six morons who lost the
war
in uh
in my book i have seven morons uh uh
they start with the president and go
down through several high-ranking
generals who uh uh allowed
this to occur uh who ordered it to occur
the uh but one of the things that
that that i was drawn to was in uh
hannah aaron's uh famous
study of uh
eichmann's adolf eichmann's trial in uh
in uh jerusalem as you all know she
ended the book in an ambiguous way that
became greatly uh influential she said
so illustrates the banality of evil
she never said what she meant by
banality of evil she never used it
except in the very last line of the book
but later in life
she and her executors spent a great deal
of time discussing
the banality of evil and she uh
in some new essays that have recently
been published posthumously uh we now
know that what she meant by it was the
inability to think
uh not stupidity the uh one of the most
interesting things that happened in the
eichmann trial
eichmann forever stressed that he was a
very well-educated and quite devout and
sincere man
judge landau asked him at once at one to
point in that case please explain to me
categorical imperative
arant writes that i never heard it
better expressed uh that there is no
question that adolf eichmann was
perfectly familiar with emmanuel kant
and
was able to recite precisely what he had
in mind but that what was wrong with uh
with uh eichmann is that he had ceased
to think
he had uh
he had become a bureaucrat he'd become a
functionary he was
a railroad dispatcher of
death of people to the death camps
i thought of this when you thought of
the when you saw the pictures it came
back today again also looking at
botoro's
paintings over in the library
the
there was one sergeant in abu ghraib
prison sergeant darby
he's been heavily
persecuted
within the army since then
but he also had a computer disc with
photographs
from what was going on there and he
looked at them and said
this is abhorrent
this is not what any army should be
doing it's uh it's a war crime uh and he
set his disk to the
army uh criminal investigation
department uh and that then led to
general takuba's
uh uh investigation and things of this
sort
i'd like to uh remember uh sergeant
darby as one who had not ceased to think
uh
he uh he
was able to uh to think in a way that
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff at
that time general richard myers clearly
had
myers
has
myers has been using the excuse of three
bad apples
so many times for military atrocities
around the world that man has actually
planted orchards of bad apples uh uh
around the world and uh uh we turned out
to be in the in the right place for his
president at the time but
uh what is it done to the public uh i
don't understand why uh
the public
uh is able to uh to tolerate
a uh
an attorney general who comes out and
says that uh
he or then presidential legal counsel
that um
the geneva
treaties on the protection of prisoners
of war and civilians in wartime are now
obsolete the constitution makes clear
that
a signed ratified treaty is a supreme
law of the land
it covers everything else no attorney
general no president no secretary of
defense has any authority to tamper with
this at all
why are the public so gullible why do
they take it with with uh such uh
effrontery thrown up to them as the
torture memos the memos that
the memos that were written to justify
uh this sort of thing uh we seem to have
stopped thinking
in april 2005 a group organized a uc
teach-in on torture sponsored by three
uc departments and over a hundred
faculty endorsers we found that the
university press office would not
distribute our press release and we were
denied the use of any uc auditorium
on the claim that we were uh none were
available rather do you agree that the
main obstacles to coalescence of a
national resistance movement are at the
level of local institutions and
collaboration their collaboration with
imperialism
i don't know the answer to that i i i
really don't i can't say that the
university of california san diego would
have done it any any better they would
have been scared as usual uh or
something of that sort it they seem to
forget what the functions of these
institutions are
and and to just simply again not be not
thinking behaving like uh
uh
uh adolf eichmann uh in his uh
extremely efficient movement of
millions of people to death camps uh
that's
i
i
but what stops
mass mobilization is i'm sure more than
simply local institutions uh it is uh
the extreme complexity and diversity of
life in this country
and i should just say that uh there is
an irony of having the botero show on a
campus which also hosts the man perhaps
most responsible for it john yu teaching
constitutional law at bolt law school
an absolute
shame to my university
don't think you're exclusive though
all law schools have one or two uh
there's dershowitz at harvard oh that's
right
we just have time for just a few more
questions
i believe that saddam hussein was
beginning to use euros and not dollars
right before the invasion oh right
before the invasion do you think this
was in
part the reason for the war
it's really possible but the information
i have and the more you read on the
subject
it seems as though uh saddam hussein
that his problem was one of his problems
he didn't have nuclear weapons uh but
that uh
the uh that was a serious problem uh for
him uh but that he wasn't taking the
united states seriously that is the
countries that he felt menaced by were
iran
uh and israel he didn't really think
he thought the united states was
bluffing uh just as he was in many ways
uh
playing a bluff game too to pretend to
be more powerful than he actually was so
that i uh
i think that he was uh surprised
by uh
uh mr uh ulmer's uh shock and awe
tactics and the belief that that he
could be uh
bombed into uh into submission the uh
uh it's uh
it's hard to but again i don't know
precisely what uh
the kind of reasoning that went on
inside the iraqi government as they came
uh closer to
the americans delivering on their
threats i think the threats were so
extreme
so outrageous that it would have been
in almost any ordinary government
difficult to take them seriously that
you would have come to believe after a
while that these people will
self-destruct they're going too far this
is mao zedong in the and the cultural
revolution uh that it's fascinating to
monitor but it's no longer of any
importance they're just
uh fools that are making serious
mistakes uh the
uh i don't think that he truly imagined
that um
our military high command would have
confidence in these
fantastical ideas uh enough to order the
troops into battle uh but there's a lot
that nobody fully understood that is
that this was uh
this was our professional army
service in the armed forces today is not
an obligation of citizenship as it was
for me when i was in the navy back in
the korean war
uh it is uh it is a career choice
uh very commonly most one most commonly
taken by pekon people who come from
blocked
cul-de-sacs or dead-ends in our society
fifty percent of the women in the armed
forces come from national minorities
it's perfectly understandable uh it's a
root of social mobility uh
what was her name
you remember jessica lynch who was uh
shot up rather badly your colleagues
were killed in the at nazarea in the
assault on baghdad i remember the the
press asked her why did you join the
army
yes i'm from palestine west virginia i
couldn't get a job at walmart
i mean what did i join the army for it
was to get out i was so told that i
wasn't going to be shot at that i was a
i was a a
a supply clerk and uh i drove a truck
down the wrong road in uh
in iraq
this uh
this chain the the high command likes
this military arrangement i'm not
obviously going to try and make a case
for the draft but i'll tell you
if you're in the armed forces
when it is an obligation of citizenship
everybody becomes much more sensitive to
what the war is about whether the
officers know what they're doing
uh
the uh
becomes sensitive
to how things were raised uh
if you've ever never read christian
happy's uh working class war on uh on
vietnam do so it's an absolute classic
of
of things that that uh
that should be understood uh
the number of yale graduates killed in
vietnam is one
we always many times commented how in
the hell did that guy not get the word
you know
that if he only stayed in the library
and uh and that let the dissertation run
onto a thousand pages uh
he'd have pulled a cheney
and uh
but uh
but in our wisdom the sort of signs of
things starting to slip
rather than make the draft draft
equitable we chose to abolish it
uh and that
changes the world uh overnight
one final question
you
spoke of uh empire mainly in terms of
territorial occupation and bases
does empire also take an economic form
say that again please can empire take an
economic form oh yes of course there are
many i mean many people ask and does it
now yeah many people ask what makes you
really think that the united states is
an empire
uh that by empire most americans think
uh or are taken in by the marvelous
cottage in
industry of predifying the british
empire
which goes on endlessly
about how
how lucky people were to be uh to be
colonized by englishmen uh the uh
that's that's those books really sell
well in ireland believing uh and whales
exactly i mean before this year is over
the united kingdom may break up scotland
is thinking of going independent as you
know the uh and with good reason uh
the
the uh
there are other kinds of empires and the
uh clearly
economic empires and neocolonialism the
sorts of relationships that we've had
with latin america since uh the uh the
monroe doctrine are are classic examples
of a different kind of empire the sort
of empire i had in mind
was the one the soviet union created in
eastern europe after world war ii that
is the military occupation of
territories creating uh uh satellites
with uh uh friendly puppet governments
oriented toward moscow and their
economies integrated into the soviet
bloc that's the sort of empire we have
its unit is not the colony it's as of
the current count
737 american military bases in every
continent on earth the the number comes
in something called the base structure
report it's an annual inventory of
our bases around the world and the
pentagon's guess at what the plant
replacement value what it would cost to
replace them would be the
the number is clearly greater than 737
nobody really knows the full number all
the espionage bases are left out the
bases a couple of them in israel that
are left out all the bases in england
are disguised as royal air force bases
there are no englishmen on them but they
are listed as royal air force bases that
was an administrative agreement made
back in the late 1940s uh there are and
then there are many places where we have
bases that is simply too embarrassing
for the country to acknowledge that they
exist here
so the number is probably around a
thousand uh but it is assuredly an
empire uh
just as much as uh
the roman empire are the roman colonies
the world of roman possessions under the
roman republic uh destroyed the roman
republic
well thank you so much chalmers johnson
great
[Music]
thank you for having me
[Applause]
[Music]
nemesis is the final volume in chalmers
johnson's american empire trilogy his
other books are blow back the costs and
consequences of american empire and the
sorrows of empire militarism secrecy and
the end of the republic
learn more at american empire